the following is a presentation of the
St Louis chess
club the fourth leg of the 2023 Grand
chess tour is underway at the capital of
Chess in America with the St Louis rapid
and Blitz the gct's penultimate event is
the final chance for tour players to
Showcase their skills in the faster time
controls last year's Champion Alara
perua picked up right where he left off
defeating current points leader Fabiano
Carana to jump into second place in the
event wildcard Liam L's return to St
Louis has been a triumphant one so far
winning two games and sole lead the rust
has been knocked off and players are
ready to hit the ground running day two
of Rapid chess coming up
[Music]
next
welcome back to day two of the St Louis
rapid in Blitz yesterday we had some
Fighting Chess hopefully that spirit
continues today let's go back to the
studio and get
started welcome to St Louis the home of
Chess in America as the St Louis chess
club proudly presents St Louis rapid and
Blitz day two of Rapid starts right now
I'm International Master t s alongside
me my co- commentators in crime grand
master Yas Saran and grandmas P Tanya I
can see you brought the passion today
hello everyone wow welcome everyone what
a start we had what a day one we had
fantastic chess decisive games fighting
play and yes we have a soul leader yes
we do hello everyone and Welcome to our
live coverage of the St Louis R and
Blitz day two I tell you the wild cards
have been outperforming and ju Liam from
the Webster University here in St Louis
has snagged clear first shocking the
entire Chess World Tanya do the honors
tell us the standings let's take a look
at where we are going into day two of
the rapid Wild Card Liam with a
fantastic day one performance scoring
Five Points and yes it could have been
more he missed that win against RAR
Robson but what a day it was what a
thought F Liam and then we've got the
world Blitz number one alira fuja for
whom these last two events the rapid and
Blitz and sink field cup is so important
to try and overtake Fabby who is the
current GCT leader and he Ali Raza is
the defending
2022 uh champion of the grand chest T so
we'll see if he can pull it off and do a
repeat tell us about the format for
these two tournaments let's take a look
we are in day two off rapid there is
going to be three games today played
with 25 minutes on the clock and a 10
second bonus time every time a move is
made it is the non-standard scoring
system so a player for a win gets two
points a draw is one point each and zero
for a loss and in the blitz U both
players will get 5 minutes to start the
game two second bonus of the traditional
one-point scoring system and no draw
offers for either the Rapid or Blitz
just put that aside and play your hard
art the schedule T got to fight it out
till the very end here and this is our
schedule we are uh going to have two
days of Blitz after rapid which is day
four and day five the rapid is a single
round robin each plays each fit in the
Blitz the players will play against each
other twice so that's a total of 18
games with colors reversed I always felt
that that was the Fair system to play
the two games and to reverse the colors
and Peter marvelous marvelous just to
have you in studio it's just I I know
great pleasure absolutely and it's a
great pleasure to watch this field in
play and let's uh take a look at that
field slightly uh closer uh starting
with the rapid rankings uh there you
have them on your screen the top 10 is
very well represented with Yan pomi
currently the highest rated player uh in
feeder ratings of the field and there at
the bottom you see Ray Robson and samian
not even assigned a number which I think
is uh just plain wrong they're both much
stronger than the ratings suggest and
you will see that uh in the blitz
ranting rankings everybody uh in the
tournament is in the top 50 not even the
top 100 at top 50 ala fua uh world
number one Fabiano caran also above the
2800 uh barrier an incredibly strong
field in both disciplines so uh very
very exciting to watch them uh in play
and on that note uh we should uh
introduce uh woman Grand Master carich
good morning n with more personal
stories about the
good morning Peter good morning yaser
and T it's so nice to be here what a day
one we had it was really fantastic day
with great games and also nice
interviews as well and actually what
happened yesterday was interesting it
stayed behind the scene um Anish giri uh
who was trying to get inside to the
studio couldn't make it because he saw
this interesting sign you know which
said that he cannot knock the door so
what he he he did he published the tweet
and uh Leonard TOS saw the tweet and he
opened the door to
Anish so finally he mentioned we saw
your Tweet so we we're coming we are
going to help you so at the end Anish
found his way to the studio and he gave
us the interview yesterday I didn't know
all this until the round was over until
the broadcast was over and after that I
I was passing by St Louis chairs club
and I noticed there were so many people
there um and I decided to come in and I
noticed that there were but their
sisters there Andrea and Alexandra
famous streamers who have I don't know
more than 1 million followers in their
twitch channels and YouTube channels and
they were playing with local chess fan
fans it was really nice of them and I
think many people really appreciated the
opportunity to play against them and I
also did so so I decided to play a game
with Andrea and to tell you the truth
guys it was really horrible but at the
end I managed somehow to trick uh famous
streamer and won the game it was a
really amazing day yesterday so I would
like to remember to all our followers
please don't forget to follow our social
media accounts Grand chest tour and also
St Louis chess club stay with us check
lots of action here and I think it's
time to go back to the studio because
the round four is about to start
Anastasia Victory is a victory right
Tanya I mean you win you win it's good
it looks like everything everyone won at
the chess club yesterday that looks like
a lot of fun so definitely drop at the
St Louis chess club if you are around
and in just a few moments yeser we will
start with all the action our tournament
leader is ready to go he starts today
with the white pieces what is with these
wild cards and having these amazing
performances during the grand Chester
it's the tradition that continues it's a
an outstanding success as he looks like
he's ready for round four do the honors
Tanya and tell us about the pairings for
this fourth round which we're about to
to see coming up let's take a look and
we start with a bang look at those
matches we've got Jeffrey Jong playing
against the 2021 World Blitz Champion
Maxim vasher lrav Liam will start his
day against Sam savan but the other
match that catches my attention which is
going to be fireworks from the start
their style of play absolutely
aggressive and uncompromising Yan pomi
against Ali RZA fuja that's the one
that's got my attention absolutely a
marquee matchup no doubt about it but
when you come to Wesley so and Fabby you
think well those two could be facing off
for first place not so they've only
scored two out of the possible six
points in the first day as Wesley you
see there setting up the white pieces do
you have that habit I do of just
adjusting all the position before all
the pieces before the start of play I
think it's what players generally tend
to do right you come you want it to be
set up exactly the way you want but the
big question is how do you want your
Knights to be placed because some of the
players wanted fac in each other right
some look up front with the Knights
exactly and some even have it backwards
and you yes what was your always on the
side always on the side how about you
Peter facing front I'm I'm I'm front
facing but the reason I was so happy T
brought this up is that I I've watched
Wesley do it and he I think belong
belongs in a category of one because
both of his Knights are facing to the
queen side this is not his board but we
were watching Wesley set up the pieces
and I think both both the king side and
the queen side night facing left which
is not something I've ever seen I don't
think you're right that is very unique
actually I don't believe I've ever seen
this before I I I have them facing one
another which is of course and Fabby
likes them forward I see yeah yeah see
everybody's got their little Quirk and
yes but I like I like uh you know uh
adjusting each and every one of my
pieces not my opponents my own the
players are fighting hard Tanya what are
they fighting for they're fighting hard
and what they're saying is show us the
money and this is what it is the top
price at $40,000 and all the way down
also big money to be won at $7,000 for
the 10th place but what they're also
fighting for yasa are the grand chest St
points because there is bonus money to
boot for the top three finishers a
$100,000 bonus for the winner of the
grand Chester so uh a lot to play for a
lot to fight for and right now Fabby is
at the top of the leaderboard in the
grandchester standings if this is the
guy watch because last year he won both
the uh rapid and Blitz as well as the
sinkfield cup to Leap Frog everybody and
take the the title and the $100,000 I
think we calculated something like a 20
20,000 uh 3we period there for Ali Raisa
so 1.2 million in total price fund not
too as we see the players what they're
doing there we just saw nepo he signed a
certificate so what what these uh pieces
are they're the house of Stanton pieces
and they're they're specially designed
for this event and people can bid on
them and own a piece of History you can
own the the the the set that was played
in game four between Fabby and Wesley
handshake so history is going to be
written here as well who will win the 23
Grand chest a big day for the players
here Fabby leading the tour siging but
as you mentioned Ali Resa both these
players have got two events remaining
lots of points to be one everything to
play for and it is the Royal lez Peter
and no Archangel boo I mean for I think
the second time already and we are
barely into the second day Fabby refuses
to promote his course I think this
exactly uh wrong yeah I mean breaking
some sort of an unspoken rule there I'm
pretty sure yes but what you have in
front of you actually is the game
between Yan and Ali Rea a scotch that's
that's a scotch and that's a scotch
somewhat classical approach because I
think Yan has been uh playing H4 in this
position quite a bit which I a move I I
think that was introduced by uh
Alexander marovich who uh Yan very much
idolized as as a kid and I think see him
continue maric's Legacy even even in
maturity so to speak is very very nice
but C4 is what you are supposed to play
right for me this is Mainline Mainline
Mainline break it down statistically
Peter how does white perform from this
position reasonably well as you can see
there uh there are some some moves that
are more popular than others but it's uh
not not Sensational you you see
uh 50% is scores F4 is definitely a move
that exists but it's a uh it's one of
the sharper options and it's definitely
one of the options which potentially
takes the game out of equilibrium as
fast as possible I think even even G5 is
a playable move here uh I don't know if
it will be chosen because without
preparation this is a very uh committal
and very risky move to play you're not
obliged to you can play G6 you can play
as you can see Queen before before check
is a legitimate option uh cing quinide
is is always a legitimate option but I
think this is an indication that Yan has
an idea for this game and he wants to
surprise ala as early as possible
because I think the two main moves in
this position are B3 and G3 yeah those
are the two I'm most familiar with I
didn't even know F4 was a move to be are
you a scotch uh I play this position
from the black side um I quite enjoy
playing these positions from the black
side let's take a look at their head to
head so far in Rapid chess it is
absolutely level that's amazing this is
the fight that we are expecting in this
matchup as well a close close one with
11 wins to each of them uh and the
scotch promises to be uh quite a dynamic
opening quite a dynamic play you
mentioned the move F4 that has been
chosen by yanam Nishi it's not it might
not be very popular at the moment in
this particular position but it's a move
that eventually does pop up on the board
you want to keep that Eon the central E
Pawn uh defended very often we will see
black go castling on the queen side the
bishop that is on A6 pins that C4 Pawn
so you don't need to rush about with
your central Knight retreating which
often enough yes falls to the B6 Square
exactly where it puts pressure on the C4
pawn and we we see these positions with
longside castling and a break with D6 or
F6 exactly and that's why F4 at some
point does arise and it looks like
yanan's the one who's prepared a little
bit of a surprise here except when I
break down the position for me mentally
uh what I see is a u disharmony in
White's development for example this
queen is sitting in front of his Bishop
right uh these pieces are all on the
first rank obviously and I'm sitting
there going how does F2 F4 help my cause
you mentioned yes you do need your your
your your Pawn defended on E5 and so F4
is useful except I'm sitting there going
okay how are you going to develop are
you going to go fall back on G3 and I
think that that's that's a very silent
question and there is a good answer to
it a four actually apart from supporting
the E5 pawn it also gives you after
it gives you a very useful sare for this
queen unpinning the C4 Pawn which means
that the Knight is now hanging and also
very importantly uh we're still
controlling the C2 Square meaning that
Knight B4 can be met by immediately
attacking the Knight because we don't
have to worry about Knight C2 check and
that probably forces black to go Knight
B6 does it Queen B4 check Queen B4 check
also also needs to be calculated uh
actually Bishop C5 is very scary that's
what I was about to ask you if you do
play Knight D2 Bishop
C5 yeah who got the initiative here well
the bigger question here is are we still
alive with to be honest because never
mind if we got the initiative or not are
we dead yeah this this night is coming
in and it feels like so far black is you
know making all the running here so yeah
this is this is very very scary
something happened y clearly has an idea
and we will if
black we will find out but what it is he
looks comfy enough I mean of course
castles is as you said Tanya a very
natural move and I think he flicked out
G6 or G5 I think that was G5 yeah yeah
he did I like it you said G5 can be
played and should maybe be played but
only after some preparation I don't know
if uh Ali Ray are prepared or not but
he's he's taken an uncompromising
approach Peter yeah he clearly has
looked at this at some point because I I
don't think you make this move without
any idea whatsoever but the 3 minutes he
spent on it I think would indicate that
he probably hasn't really expected this
position to appear on the board today so
he spent some time kind of trying to
remember what what the notes say and
came to this conclusion the obvious idea
is fg5 already played the idea I'm
guessing is to play Bishop G7 the PA on
E5 is now a Target so you can't really
Queen F2 is now completely unplayable
because Queen takes E5 check yeah uh
wins this Pawn so yeah this is very very
sharp and very uh what does the theory
say after Bishop G7 how does it uh
statistically how does white score and
more important more s que4 Queen E4
almost the uh the only move here and as
you can see uh it split maybe even in
Black's favor it doesn't seem to be very
very exciting so what happens after
Queen E4 just take us through the main
uh Queen E4 kn9 B6 appears to be the
main move and now uh Bishop F4 finally
development coach devel and also I I
think yes I thought you were a pawn
Grabber you'd be happy with I was about
to
say this has to be a move off the
yaser's heart because it it protects the
center doesn't
let yeah and then Queen before before
check I'm guessing Knight D2 right Queen
takes B2 we probably this has all been
played yeah Rook B1 let's say queen
takes A2 and something like Bishop D3
and the King will go King side now and
black black has collected something on
the queen side but both castling Queen
side and castling King side with the the
bishop D3 queen4 battery aiming at the
H7 Pawn don't look that
safe this position looks like an Like An
Almighty mess I have no idea what I
think about it Almighty mess we'll we
we'll we'll keep this on the boil
because we got four other fantastic
games to take a look at where would you
like to take us Tanya we've got to go
over to the All-American clash between
Wesley so and Fabiano Karana another
very exciting outcome from the opening
and you're going to be questioning wait
a second what is up with Black's
development what is the queen doing on
A4 true wh moved the kingside Knight
plenty of times the Central Pawn is
hanging as we see the queen jumped on to
A4 yasa hitting that Knight on E5 falls
back I would be afraid to pick up that
pawn on e4 and even though you're a pawn
Grabber I don't think you'd approve of
that one no I think that actually even
loses on the spot Queen takes E4
obviously walks into Rook E1 Knight
takes E4 invites both Queen D5 Rook E1
and guess what Knight C3 is coming with
a
Peter I'm sorry I'm out of my dep or at
least theoretically speaking I don't
recall seeing a ruy Lopez with a black
queen on A4 in any of my games this
exists and there are even some some very
high-profile games reaching the position
of Knight A5 Queen A4 including as you
can see there game between Carlson and
yeno played in 2021 and a draw between
uh grishuk and kumnick from 2018 wow uh
my big question is Wesley played KN B3
and Wesley played KN B3 reasonably quick
when I think most people play Bishop D2
here even Queen E1 I think is more
popular than Knight B3 because that
Knight on A5 is a very very useful piece
and the Queen on e4 can be smoked out if
you imagine black let's say playing
Bishop B7 we can play Rook E1 taking on
e4 is still sort of instantly losing
yeah I think I think maybe not B3 is the
cleanest but it looks like this should
be punishable by by something maybe
Knight C3 is very strong so you probably
end up castling right and after B3 the
queen probably has to go back right and
then we can play Knight C3 and the
Knight on A5 does a very good job
controlling the bishop Bishop on C8 so
I'm a bit mystified by how quickly
Wesley chose to to retreat because I
think that makes Black's Play Slightly
easier in comparison in comparison to to
Bishop
D2 and these two players uh they're such
great Rivals uh in American chess so you
can imagine a lot of games Tanya between
them 26 to 21 in terms of Victories wow
wow uh wesle say having the upper hand
in Rapid lots of draws too lots of draws
too and still a very close fight and
absolutely this is one of those uh Titan
level rivalries of the Chess World we've
seen it happen so many times and we will
see it happen so many times in the
future as well uh Wesley with the white
pieces an interesting opening abely and
not something that we see very often so
we're going to we are expecting unique
ideas on the board and we see Fabby
there he gets up and leaves times are
Faby looks like he's the one who's
better prepared 25 minutes to boot and
19 minutes that's what I wanted to ask
he he's been playing his moves all snap
them right out and he's getting time on
the clock and it has surprised us that
Fabby having the opportunity to go in
for his archangels which is his big
course right now and a really nicely uh
done one I'm going to let out I'm in the
middle of that one
so it's very extensive and uh it's it's
interesting that Fabby has decided to
not employ that in the opportunities
that he's gotten and I want to ask you
do you think there's additional pressure
that comes on the players when you watch
for an opening so much and uh for all
its strength but then when it comes to
playing after you're out with a cost
that you need to prove a point every
time it's on the board yeah I I feel
that kind of pressure at least I did
when I was you know um uh in favor of an
opening and I knew my opponents were
going to be very well prepared for it
but nonetheless I I went into those
variations and said you know I'm going
to challenge you and uh with the moves
Bishop E6 Bishop E7 and to uh Peter's
point with the Knight no longer on A5 C6
was a
perfectly happy uh Retreat Square for
the queen and I think fabby's got a
decent position in per I think he has to
solve one final problem here uh namely
that you would very much like to Castle
and finish development immediately but I
think that walks into Knight that walks
into Knight D5 you can still take and
play Queen D7 but then returning to your
previous previous conversation the
immediate Knight A5 it's also possible I
was wondering about Knight takes D5 but
that doesn't work I thought there's a
very nice little tactic there for black
but Queen takes D5 actually protects
that Bishop so it doesn't it doesn't
work out so this looks very pleasant for
white the Knight will return to C6 uh if
we can't Castle immediately our options
are somewhat restricted H6 we can start
with H6 I've been wondering how good
this is but maybe this is not that much
honestly maybe the bishop can just drop
back and then we will Castle next move
do I see a pawn you do and I I know you
want ready to with with all with all my
because he want to see a rook after
grabbing that pawn right but with all
your you're going to A3 or no I was kind
of I'm wondering if I could provoke you
to play F4 so Bishop E5 kind of f4
probably have to return the pawn with
Bishop D4 check but n but then you're a
bit worse I think because once again you
will not be able to Castle because of
the fork on E7 true that Queen C5 is
maybe what you will be supposed to do
here is just to drop it back to F6 with
or without F4 by yeah yeah it's a
question because this allows A5 and the5
might be a useful thing but we're
getting I think a little bit too far
into the into the Weirs here Bishop H4
is also playable because I don't think
it changes very much in in the context
of castles 9 D5 this will still annoying
but it does it does yeah now we can take
right yeah now Knight A5 Knight takes D5
oh no not immediately you have to wait
for Knight A5 but white maybe has a way
to prepare Knight A5 here the what we're
talking about with yaser is yes in
exactly the same position the bishop on
H4 is no longer protected by this queen
on D5 so this works out for black
beautifully all of these little details
are I suspect actually going through the
players Minds right now because you do
have to weigh all of this
all of these possibilities H H4 on the
board right it's on the board and we
will see how uh black decides to respond
to this one but let's go back to the
leader of the tournament exactly I
always believe you have to pay uh
respects uh to the leader of the and our
Wild Card coach uh Liam of the Webster
University here in St Louis has snagged
clear first against uh one of the
greatest chess Fields you could possibly
uh put up and how is he doing and I
think very often people tend to
underestimate Liam he might not be a
household name like Fabby is like a
Hikaru like Magnus but Liam and nepo and
Anish but for Liam let's not forget he
is a 2013 World Blitz Champion he's won
so many strong open events uh he's
played in the Olympiad one medals B
medals fantastic experience a speech
specialist and he showed that on day one
yeah he starts with the white pieces
against Sam savan this is the position
that we have Sam's Rook at the center of
the board is under pressure right now
attacked yeah white needs to Castle once
The Rook goes back and even though the
material is balanced looking at the
position I just feel white seems to be
the one with more activity you'll be
getting the Rook to D1 the open line
with a Tempo the bishop on C3 is nicely
placed uh balanced position but I
slightly prefer white here what about
you yes yeah materially speaking uh
you're right I mean it's completely
balanced but the majorities if you will
white has a majority on what we call the
center SL King side so four versus three
and Black's majority on the queen side
three versus two so oftentimes when you
have these types of positions it's all
about whose majority is more meaningful
so uh like should we start with F4 with
the idea of maybe F5 and an E5 and
tickling the king side should we as I
mean you get F5 E5 I'm already betting
on white yeah exactly or should we like
as you said you know just rush to just
you know double our Rooks on the open
file and I do agree with you I like
White's space and I like more I want to
say the freedom of his pieces uh Peter
wein on this one the majorities
queenside versus kingside
Center in this particular one I'm I'm
also speaking white I don't think it's
much but uh it's definitely more
pleasant to uh to play from uh Liam's
side Castle C6 Rook a D1 included I'm a
little bit curious about this last move
it looks like the most obvious move in
the world but right it sort of invites
Queen E7 that's a tick and then you will
you will have to think about how to
protect the pawn on e4 maybe r one you
yeah you can actually do that that's a
very the queen a very nice tou yeah
because I honestly I thought maybe it's
already about time to uh to start with
the push because said if if the pawns
get to E5 and F5 she's betting on white
I think if they get to F5 and E5 black
kind of
resigns it's too late to bed the beds
will be
closed it's understatement the we like
because because I wasn't really sure how
black is supposed to reply to this it's
very difficult to stop those things from
happening you uh F7 F5 is sometimes
playable but it will not be playable
here because we can start with Bishop C4
and then just pick it up next move looks
wondering about Bishop C5 check followed
by Bishop D4 but that runs into Rook ad
D1 and looks frankly horrible it does uh
so Rook A1 it's very difficult to
criticize a move that puts a rook on an
open file and attacks the queen but
specifically because Queen E7 exists if
you have to play Rook F1 I would
actually argue it's better on F1 because
it supports the push of the F Pawn I
still like this for white it doesn't
change my underlying assessment then
this should be slightly better for white
but for instance now I can play Queen G5
and i' I've stopped F4 for a moment and
if black gets to play Bishop E6 Rook a
d8 and starts trading along the dile our
advantage will start becom it'll be gone
yeah it'll go nice all right well we'll
keep an eye on this one let's continue
our uh Ray Robson who's in third place
yes sorry uh Tanya you had uh we should
definitely jump to that but I just
wanted to close our thoughts on Liam's
start here that I also feel it's the
kind of position that Liam really enjoys
to play as he's uh it's just a very
pleasant outcome from the opening so I
think it's uh it's a good start today
too for the tournament leader but let's
go over to Ray to Jeffrey jong's game
against Maxim vasia lra and another
really interesting position it is
opposite color Bishops but the first
feeling that I have with that Bishop on
D5 and we've spoken about these
different complex color positions for
the bishop right that Bishop cannot be
challenged anymore we see uh the players
there and this bishop with a Target on
F7 yes longterm the queen lined up on F3
again materially balanced but I would
pick white ha big time Big Time just
because you like this initiative the
bishop on D5 the opposite color uh
saying that you know you've got to more
or less do something quickly black plays
Bishop C5 A5 King h8 well there goes the
advantage so the question is how do you
increase your pressure on the F Pawn I
mean the desirable Rook up and over
might be a little bit too primitive so
maybe it's one of those sometimes you
have those advantages that are very
visually optically nice but hard to
achieve more absolutely and one of the
things to remember is that if the major
pieces in this position gets traded off
that is just to draw on the spot take
the queens and the Rooks off and that's
game over uh so white has to try to
maximize the placement and one of the
ways of doing that is to keep your major
pieces on light squares so ideas like
Rook D3 double up on the D line try and
set up some traps if you put that Bishop
on C5 which is a desirable Square for
black and I just want to show a small
tactic that could perhaps be on the
board uh and I'm not sure if it's
working but you know what I'm looking at
over here you want to take on F7 trying
to make the most of uh tricks along the
D line and I think it's a marvelous
trick because Queen takes F7 and allows
the immediate Rook takes d8 and Rook
takes F7 uh allows Rook takes d8 so in
fact you just snap I mean daylight
robbery you just stole a pawn the in
broad daylight so you're right Bishop C5
I would probably have to in this case
you know maybe just kind of go Bishop F6
and cover but again the question to my
mind is you've got this bishop on D5
this queen on F3 and it's sort of like
you have to be quick about you know if
you could play Rook C1 Rook C7 and hit
F7 you you you know I I'm looking for
ways and it's not that obvious to me
Peter I mean it again a position that
optically looks like white should be
doing well but is there something
concrete I don't see it I've been trying
to find something that I like a great
deal while you were talking and I
absolutely agree with your general
assessment and it feels to me that
you're just not fast enough here you
will not be able to uh to create enough
problems before black stabilizes and in
terms of Black's plans to stabilize Rook
D6 F6 be something that just putting
putting a pie on F6 stopping the the
White Queen attacking it would be very
useful and if you start with Rook A1 I
think Queen E5 is a very good reply
because it's actually very difficult to
challenge that position for the queen
you cannot play Rook E1 because the
drops C on Bishop on D5 and then black
is ready to play Bishop C5 and you have
to remember that if even when this
bishop is established on C5 you can make
exactly the same arguments about the
pawn on F2 that we're we're now making
about the pawn on F7 so
I think it's mildly annoying for black
for the time being but I wouldn't be
surprised if in five moves time we would
we we will start talking about this
heading towards a draw I I just want to
show to our audience I think every
person who has ever become a chess
master has fallen for this type of a
blunder white plays the move Queen F5
and you're so eager and you're so happy
to play the move Bishop F6 right in
order to stop this attack against the F7
pawn and you further convince yourself
that the bishop on F6 is wonderfully
defended and then you get hit with a
move like Bishop E4 and that hurt it's
the cold shower because you're going to
have to allow Queen H7 G6 drops
submission and if you haven't fallen for
this trap in your career you're not a
chess master CU I must have done it
three times before I got it the second
or third time how about you Peter how
many times do I'm I'm sitting here
trying to figure out if I want to be
unpleasant to yaser this early in the
show or not because this is all
perfectly good and well but I I do have
to say I do have to say that in this
particular case I'm taking on D I'm
playing and I'm saying you you can give
me those two checks I don't really care
you can walk yeah I think I think this
is just dead equal to be honest it might
be dead equal but I think yasa you make
a great point that these are dangers
that do exist in the position that black
needs to watch out for so many of us
just think it's opposite color Bishop
easy to defend easy to play I'm sure it
is at the top level but how many of us
have actually messed up these positions
and but that said I think draw is the
most likely outcome in this one so to
you're definitely getting invited back
I'm not sure about
Peter uh by the way no seriously rookie
won yeah oh the Fight Continues fight
fight get out of here okay okay I think
I'm holding this you're holding
wonderfully well
uh pardon me we have it have we seen Ray
Robson versus Anish giri let's do it Ray
Ray is in third position coming into
round four third position all the pieces
and the pawns on the board nothing has
been traded off exactly so it definitely
is a very rich middle game here and uh
yeah I'd love love for you guys to just
break it down what are the different
plans in this uh we're not in I don't
see any gam so somebody's made a novelty
somewhere but very recently I think up
to Bishop B2 on move 11 so that looks
very we still we still have a game
between two very strong players there up
top Tam rajab have played this against
against Ken in 20 all the way back to
2011 MH U I'm not the biggest slav
specialist in the world it feels to me
like this is fairly balanced also yes so
far all 32 pieces are on the board but
in particular King J2 I think is a very
strong indication that white knows he
will have to take on G6 sooner rather
than later this Knight on H4 cannot be
justified otherwise it's been this this
has been available for already six moves
and Ray is waiting and waiting and
waiting but eventually why the delay now
why not just take that and then play
King G2 why it why King G2 I think maybe
there are some edge cases where uh you
might not take for instance in this
position I think maybe F7 F5 okay
becomes something you could consider
with
establish establishing a kind of a a
kind of a stone wall and then maybe you
offload one pair of kns and bring the
other one over y F6 to E4 and if you do
it with the Knight on H4 and the bishop
on G6 still on the board maybe here I
actually say yes I wasted like five
Tempe but I will not be taking this
bishop anymore because it's so stupid
very inter so maybe you can find some
some scenarios where uh you will
actually postpone or even cancel the
trade all together somehow I feel that's
levels of death that are a little bit
too sophistic that is it's so
instructive as well the bishop on G6 is
not going anywhere you trade on your
terms and not your opponent's terms when
uh you feel the structure is more
favorable for you no rush to take that
Bishop on G6 is it important for black
to actually put that pawn on F5 and if
black decides not to place that
committal pawn on F5 does white ever
want to go F3 E4 in these
positions I think you can definitely
dream of it I think black will probably
have black will have something to say
about it if you if we imagine something
like Knight G6 H gf3 Knight C3 Bishop C3
here for instance if you give white one
let's let's make a passing move here for
black let's go A4 it's semi parsing semi
yeah the the problem is even even let's
say if you achieve all that and you're
met with let's say 65 here I'm not sure
how happy you are and uh another
instructive thing here it looks like
black just gave white a protected
protected passer in the center but it
kills off more as both Bishops black has
a very nice blockading Square on D6 and
I think black is not going to be very
unhappy about the structure in general
obviously exactly depends on where the
pieces are but I would be okay with this
for black uh but you can also definitely
in this position say no I'm not going to
give you a free a free shot at a 34 I
can play F5 myself I can play Knight F6
another thing that they often do in
these types of positions is actually get
get that Bishop pair off the board
because we can chase it forever exactly
Bishop B4 Bishop A3 would be on my
uh radar as something that I would want
to do very interesting and uh it's one
of those positions that once the pawn
breaks come in and as the game develops
it promises to have a lot of these
tactical points as well the position
will explode at some point but as we see
it what do you think about the opening
outcome who is happier
here I think they're both content I
think it's a very playable position that
requires a lot of finesse there's a lot
to play for and uh I think when when
when this is your approach against the
slav you're not aiming for a large
Advantage you're aiming for a game where
you will be able to to try for something
and I think he has achieved that I don't
know what he yes I think yeah for for me
after the move A5 where I'm focused on
is a completely different thing I'm
looking at and he did Play Bishop D3 by
the way I was looking at Knight takes G6
because again you know I'm a I like the
two Bishops I can't get a classical Pawn
Center I would like to take because
okay I've got the two Bishops I'm
looking at Double pawns I'm going to go
Queen C2 now here's where I I kind of
stop a little bit I go F5 F3 and I ask
myself am I happy just that's the key
question am I happy that is an
existential question yes well if I can
go E4 and you know do this quickly uh
then yes I'm going to be happy the
question I have for myself what what
about E5 what about Bishop A3 and that's
that's where I the this judgment and
experience uh plays in absolutely help
me on this final position what did you
think about the analysis after this yeah
let me let me put this on on my on my
board as well so B we take Queen C2
Queen C2 more or less F5 I don't know3
no F5 I think is logical after F3
there's definitely an argument for
Knight F6 but let's let's get here I
think this is very Tempo dependent
because I think E5 is very critical
maybe G5 in some cas but specifically I
think E5 and much depends on c e
continue breaking stuff up yeah I'm just
trying uh for what it's worth this I
think I will be happy unhappy actually
I'm not so sure because my my first
intin was to take and then after Bishop
takes D4 Play Bishop B5 but you're not
going to be playing Bishop takes I'm not
going to help you I'm going to yeah I'm
going to go for and this is going
decision yeah this is going to become
very sharp so I can I can definitely
understand where you're coming from uh
but returning us to to the game Bishop
D3 Bishop D3 and F5 on the board and we
will keep an eye out on this one but
there is so much going on on the Liam
board and I think we have to go over
there and do a little bit of an action
replay from when we left it last year as
when The Rook Oni was hanging take us
through this because the current
position is quite fascinating exactly
well we left at Bishop C3 we envisioned
that The Rook was simply going to drop
back white was going to Castle maybe on
a good day get in F4 and stuff Rook G5
actually happened Rook
D1 uh castles and now uh Sam is he he's
kind of got his Rook stranded frankly if
white plays F4 here you might just be
lost so you're kind of force you're
you're you're on a do you say that
riding the tiger you're riding the tiger
yeah you can't get off you can't get off
you've got to play Bishop
H3 uh oops excuse me you've got to play
Bishop H3 in continue your attack as if
you've had it all worked out this is all
a part of your script Bishop F3 now I
can't play G3 because of Bishop F1 I
must play Bishop F3 Queen E6 and now
you're intimating somewhat that you're
ready to uh reinforce your attack
against G2 Rook E1 now white is uh
pardon me Liam is about to play G3
against further attacks on G2 and I also
let's point out ask the defensive
resource here that if you were to
sacrifice on G2 that Queen on C2 plays a
very important role because after Bishop
takes Bond Bishop takes Bishop the queen
jumps in to H3 or to G4 but the FB moves
forward uh and everything is under
control so the sacrifice doesn't work
right now yeah that Queen on C2 is like
with or without the check it's not
important that Queen on C2 covers G3 um
Peter when you're sitting there riding
the tiger as we're discussing and you're
you you very much understand that
Black's pieces could be you
know misplaced and that's being kind
yeah I think it's time to to pull the
plug on the attack on the king side yeah
and it's also I think time to consider
getting some pieces off the board I
would be looking at the move Bishop G4
here right which I think more or less
forces white to I I mean you can play
Queen E2 but I think uh provoking uh the
black queen to G4 is probably useful for
white more than it is useful for black
because after takes takes on G3 I don't
think there is any mating attack no but
this Rook can be rerouted back to
civilization why maybe C5 C6 that was my
question is The Rook stranded it looks
it looks so awkward on G5 it does look
it does look awkward on G5 but on C5
there's a famous lar game which I'm sure
you you remember where Lasker at some
point very famous game the board boy
yeah where he provoked a lot of his
opponent was trying to capture Rooks
somewhat like that and that didn't quite
work out I think it goes back to C6 the
queen at some point drops back to E6 The
Rook from A8 will come out probably to
E8 and you have to remember that black
has no structural issues there are no
weaknesses there is nothing wrong with
uh Sam's position uh in those terms so
if he survives the slightly awkward two
or three moves here where he will have
to uh reorient his pieces to decent
squares he should be okay well he's gone
for a different approach in the position
and he continues to what looks like
right the tiger I'm more of a don't even
get on the tiger kind of player but of
course these players no no fear we will
come back to this but speaking of Rooks
wesy so has given up sacrificed
blundered and exchanged for compensation
I don't think it was a blunder I think
it was play for compensation but to me
it doesn't look enough and let's do an
action replay and see how we got here
when we left it we saw the move H6 and
Peter was actually going through some of
the variations it was important include
H6 because Knight
D5 uh was a problem otherwise Knight D5
came and then I think we
got yeah we we stopped somewhere there
and I think C4 is still fine uh but H3
probably was a mistake and now well it's
clear that Wesley wanted with the move
H3 he wanted this exchange sacrifice so
I definitely I would not call it a
blunder that can be ruled out
but the question is is is it enough well
exactly and you know you can already see
that uh Fabby is basically saying I'm
ready to uh run my king away imagining
no I can't play Rook E1 because Queen H6
is uh I have to play okay let's do Rook
E4 so I I essentially I wanted to force
you to take some pawns and let my king
run
away let's take it let's go for this
line so Queen takes Pawn uh which one
one not F6 I was thinking to stop King
E7 fair and I'll take a PA you don't
care about Knight
D2 I do care about Knight D2 I think we
should yeah ah I think you should I
think I should I think Fab did play Rook
e one as far as I can tell King H2 has
been met by Rook e One by Rook e one
because Queen takes H6 check King g8m
for some reason I really wanted to play
King E7 but trading Rooks I mean if this
Knight no seriously if this Knight was
anywhere close to the king side I mean
I'd be all over this I'd be going like
oh my gosh put it on F5 is just game
over H5 G3 getting to F5 but on B3
that's a long that's a long way from
civilization Peter yeah and apparently I
was uh misleading you there because as
we can see on our camera rookie one has
not yet been played okay um seems
logical to me though because I think
when H6 King G8 is a perfectly sensible
continuation and the King will still be
able to run later later any trade of
Rook put the Knight on a one and you
giving you a problem like what's the
worst Square for whites night you know
you you'd have a hard time coming up
with one worse than anyone yeah on B3
it's far from civilization there is no
civilization in that is not a square you
want it on D2 but this feels like a
misjudgment error uh to my mind this
exchange sacrifice with the Knight on B3
it just doesn't feel right Peter I think
maybe Wesley misunderstood just how
annoying Queen A4 will be although uh
the engine already prefers black a
little bit after C4 Rook f8 because of
that insistent
uh yeah it keeps on happening for the
time being after C4 at first I thought
why why not just do it immediately but
that allows white uh to to do KN the the
counter little tactic with Knight takes
C5 either this way or perhaps you will
choose to do it in this fashion maybe
this is slightly better I like uh but
Rook f8 it's just difficult to make a
sensible move here for white and H3
Queen A4 I think already more or less
forces you to start to sacrifice stuff
because your C4 Pawn is hanging if you
make a move a normal looking move like
Queen D3 that absolutely does allow
Knight Tak D5 now and because there will
be no more Knight C5 in the end so
that's just a full Pawn for uh for five
to pick up and I think after Queen A4
your hand is more or less forced I don't
think you can keep material so Rook E7
is maybe the the least of all evils and
maybe maybe Wesley thought he is forcing
a draw here because after king
f8 queen F4 you can play Queen G7 that
will lead to repetitions but fa clearly
is having having none of it yeah and now
he is considering how to uh to proceed
all the Rook moves here make some sense
Rook E5 Rook E4 even Rook E2 maybe just
to maybe get a square for you King to
run actually what do we think about
rookieu I like black I I just like black
I I hate the knight uh again if the
Knight was somewhere sensible I i' I'd
be warm but rookie too but it looks like
we're going to have our first result of
the day uh as mvl says I'm going to play
this move and I'm going to make a draw
and guess what they did uh it was a draw
and we were talking about the opposite
color Bishops all the major pieces were
off the board and Maxim made it look
very clean in holding this position the
Bishop as you pointed out did land to
the square that you wanted in lots of
Trades and this ended peacefully Maxim
looks pretty happy with the thought of
the day that he's had nothing to
complain with the black pieces a solid
hold absolutely very very peaceful
indeed uh coming back to the Liam game
because we didn't see uh you you
mentioned that you might want to trade
some pieces we didn't see the bishop G4
we did see Queen G6 G3 Bishop to C5 and
now here I I wanted to pause for just a
a moment because I'm looking at this
bishop on C5 uh uh Flip Wilson loose
lips sink ships and in chess loose
pieces fall off the board LPD loose
pieces drop off there you go but yes
does this ship to is there a big threat
on the board I'm I I want to make it
work and ask I think we have to look at
this line Peter you know the one that I
want to look at yes Rook takes Pawn
bring the queen in King H1
only move it looks like it's you're not
going to survive for too long yeah so I
F I fell into it uh because I I saw that
the queen on C2 was ambushing the bishop
which was only protected by the rook and
so the move Bishop Bishop C5 actually
sets up the threat of Rook takes G3 yes
and I think you're being very modest I
think that was a really good explanation
you wanted to show that line you didn't
fall into anything very nicely done
there yes Bishop D2 r spawn is the big
idea with that last move exactly and
we've caught up no not yet we've caught
up with the players somehow Sam's Rook
on G5 came out roses nothing happened
yeah it's it's it's still there but it
doesn't seem to be presenting him with
too many difficulties and uh finally
right about now I guess the attack
especially after Bishop G2 is played the
attack is probably over it's time to
trade to trade and play Rook G5 for C6
and then Rook G5 black should be
completely fine I would absolutely so uh
Sam looks like he's holding nicely if
you don't mind I just want to go to the
game uh I thought it was going to be our
Marky matchup between uh nepo and Ali
Raa and we've hardly gotten to it it it
was a scotch we left it quite some time
ago after remember G5 that's a long time
ago but uh the players have definitely
played very quickly the queens were
traded off the board Rook B1 yeah and
let's uh let's get to the current
position because yes as I see it it's
still a very non-typical end game that
we've got uh a bishop pair for black but
notice how the light squ Bishop is out
of the game which now fuja tries to get
active by breaking onto the center but I
have to tell you look uh you I'm a space
guy I'm a two Bishop guy I'm seeing this
bishop on E3 anchored in the center I'm
thinking black is as happy as uh can be
but let's see uh we are not quite up to
date with the players last move Knight
F3 Peter over to you how do you judge
this position I think white is okay it
looks like black should be better but I
think U white has a very nice blockading
uh piece on D3 I think it's just going
to be very difficult to for black to
make progress and white should survive
black of course is can never be worse
with the Bishops and and the protected
passer on D4 and uh if you want to draw
with black here you basically at any
point can trade this this bishop for
this Knight and it will be completely
level right but playing for a win I
think for black is going to be a
problematic just because of lack of
breaks and lack of easily attainable
progress I think will will hamper ala
here quite a bit T the big question to
me is yes it's fine for white because of
the bishop that you pointed out keeps
everything together but will ala
actually try to push this position he's
got four minutes on the clock uh no ala
even though the position might be
balanced and fine for white I think as
long as there's something to play for
and he set up a little bit of a trick
here in some positions Bishop takes Pawn
uh is a deflection uh to that G2 Pawn
that supports the Knight so there's a
little trick on the board I feel that
ala yes potentially I feel that ala will
try and push this with the bishop pair
and more activity having this play there
where you can come forward with your
King on the king side March up the board
there's still a lot left to be played
for there is a lot to be played for but
I'm not a big fan of the last move Rook
f8 I thought Rook E3 was the most
straightforward and obvious excuse me
I'm just going to put the uh you you're
you're mentioning Bishop H3 uh Tanya as
what the move Rook f8 did I thought Rook
E3 did the same thing but maybe even a
little bit more convincingly I mean
after all Rook G3 is a better Square for
The Rook than the F arm me yes
absolutely but I think what he didn't
like about this move is perhaps the move
Rook to F1 you hit the bishop and that
Bishop doesn't have a very nice square
right and maybe this is something that
because you really want your Rook on E3
you really want it I did want it I guess
but uh let's just catch up with the
players sorry instead he went with Rook
to f8 because it seems like the players
actually know what they're doing very
way quickly very quickly Bishop E4 stops
any potential threats on the F3 Knight
and now black starts expanding on the
king side controlling the B4 break that
would have given white activity King
D3 um but the question is who has made
more progress than the last two moves it
feels to me like with the bishop on e4
and the King on D3 that was a serious
improvement from White's uh side there's
no Bishop B7 uh to tickle the Knight
anymore Peter or am I splitting hairs is
it too balanced I think it's very
balanced I also wanted to play the role
of the resident uh posture you know body
language expert because I thought I
thought the way Yan played those Bishop
B4 and King D3 moves indicated at least
to me and I've watched him play a lot
the last couple of decades right uh that
he was maybe getting a little bit
interested there I think you can sort of
Imagine
white uh I mean a lot of things have to
happen for white to be seriously better
but I think it looked to me like he was
thinking why is the long diagonal being
abandoned for me like why am I getting
all of these
improvements maybe I can start playing
if not sort of out outright for a win
but maybe I can I can look for
improvements but I think A5 followed by
Bishop G3 probably uh put pay to those
because white really has no way to uh to
do anything proactive you can trade
Queens Sor not Queens you can trade
Queens along the f file but then I think
you you will be a bit annoyed by this
decision because this Knight on F1
cannot rejoin the game without being
traded for the bishop on F4 and then you
will play that Bishop ending with the
protected passer on D4 is probably a
draw but you don't want to I think the
the dream for me would be to play G4 and
Bishop F5 if I could trade off the light
Square Bishop put my king on e4 your
knight on D3 and a good knight versus
Bishop is what you're aiming for but uh
it's just going to stay a dream I feel
it's not yeah hey but you got to have
your fantasy so this current position to
balance you feel like I think it's
balanced but I'm I'm back in thinking
that maybe it's still slightly better
for black because of just how awward it
is to make moves at first I thought
white white with the bishop on e4 and
the King on D3 I thought white will be
quite happy here but I'm struggling to
name a proactive move at all here A3 B4
will not be any any good with the black
pawns on A5 and C5 already right I don't
like The Rook trade but if we don't
trade The Rook what am I doing we don't
really have moves at all right I think
and now Rook just came from B1 so A3 B4
with the Rook on B1 does make some sense
with the Rook on F1 so by the way we do
have a tradeit of Rooks not Queens
Rooks not Bishop F4 I liked your Bishop
F4 he just went back to D6 this is a bit
surprising to me because I think now
after I go let's say knight2 Knight D2
King F6 Knight F3 uh how is black
supposed to W wo you left the PES 87
yeah okay let's not let's not blunder
blunder
for my my larger point was yes this uh
this creates a barrier I just don't see
how you how you Bridge right you're King
we just control all the squares for for
for black to try and enter into this
structure and this seems like this is
just uh just white also has no progress
to to to make at all but how are you
going to ask a single question with
black here I do not know exactly think
uh by the way you they have something
like this on the board with King F6 and
H5 by and you never really want to trade
the light squar Bishops as black here as
you pointed
yes that would be the dream for white if
black ever went Bishop F5 so it looks
like it's going to be a bit of a balance
here with black not being able to make
progress white not being able to make
progress but one player who has made
progress is Fabiano Carana he went for
the idea that you suggested yes with
Rook to E1 a very direct approach of
trading Rooks he's still up in exchange
I'm trying to count material how many
pawns is that well after King H2 we did
see Rook E1 there goes one and there
goes two but Fabby says well while
you're snacking I've got the pawn on C4
and at least in this particular reason
by the way a draw a result coming in
just as we left it just as we left it
Knight A5 uh by Wesley and jump on jump
in Peter on this one I mean if I'm in
Wesley shoes I'm dreaming of a peret
queen d8 and I think it has oh no we
have Rook E8 there sorry I wanted to say
it just been allowed but it hasn't been
I very much like that Wesley was in time
to play Knight A5 Knight C6 because I
think the biggest threat black had here
is just to get the queen over to E5
forcing the queen trade and if the queen
trade happens the game finishes on the
spot one Knight against one Rook can
never be defended but with the Knight on
C6 black has no immediate way to get the
Queens off the board Queen takes B2 is
important though because this creates uh
the passer on C5 to uh additionally uh
threaten the West four on the board F
four is a I think a nice move just to
put pay to to all the checks along this
diagonal well it also has a dream of F5
F6 precisely yeah if the pawn gets to F6
there will be actual mating threats so F
needs to be a bit careful here I would
look at something like Queen G7 you're
not very happy giving up on C7 in
general but specifically here you have
the move Queen F6 which I think frankly
wins on the spot because takes a four
seems to be like a unari threat so I
like Queen G7 right now and I think if
Queen G7 is played it will be very very
difficult for West maybe in that last
position Peter where you had your queen
on F6 white has to go F5 yeah but now I
can actually start pushing just pushing
and should CU my king is now entirely
yeah you can't give a single check to
this King on f8 realistically the Knight
is very tied to C6 because allowing
Queen E5 check probably will lead to
made Y and the C Pawn is running right
so yeah seems like fabbi is starting the
day on on the right foot and uh Wesley's
let's put it in different grunch store
Contin once again to remind our viewers
of their head-to-head Wesley and Fabby
have played each other they're great
Rivals and Wesley is the one who has a
little bit of an edge as I remember it
was 27 victories to 21 victories in
favor of Wesley and lots of draws lots
of draws and yes that is true as we can
see on their 26 to 21 yes their rivalry
lots of lots of games but if you just
compare the kind of year the two players
have had it's so different it is Fabby
has been so informed winning the US
Championship the medal at the world
champion he won the US Championship
wiing yes it was just amazing play that
we've was a was um a participant but not
a big factor in the event and it was
like like sometimes you just you put
your stamp on the tournament and that
was Fab's tournament it was Fab's
tournament and it feels like it's been
Fab's year in many tournaments the super
B classic the first event of the grand
Chester as well speaking of Wesley
somehow we've
seen I'm not able to find the right
words I'm going to go with uninspired
performances throughout the year whether
it was the World Cup the early exit from
there right we've seen him in the speed
chess events uh throughout the year he
has been struggling a little bit with
his form yeah and I also want to say I
feel like the ambition is lacking there
was a in in particular it was the
candidate
uh was it the candidate no or pardon me
I apologize it was the World Cup where
he mentioned that his cat had kittens
and he was anxious to return but his
opponents were were were losing and
somehow he was going on to the next
round but it was sort of like I'm not
ambitious to be a candidate and I was
like Wesley where's your head and the
ambition is not there sometimes you lose
focus quesa as we know is a jealous
mistress she wants you to be focused
fully on chess and only chess Peter what
do you think what is going on with
Wesley this year I want to Tim kittens
right
here you're on team kittens I'm very we
lost we lost people it looks like can't
win against kittens you can never
win he didn't go for the C7 part that's
a very very strong play by by Wesley by
the way because Queen Tak C7 was losing
on the sport to the move Queen F6 which
we mentioned but Queen H4 sets up for
instance a very important trap if you
play C4 you allow F5
this is suddenly not that clear because
F6 is a winning threat even with the
queen on G7 it's a winning if we
continue C3 F6 this is winning a full
Queen because otherwise you get M uh on
the H6 Square uh so Faby recognizing
that blade F6 now the connection between
the queen on H4 and the square on d8 is
broken and the big threat here is Rook
E2 right which will force white in order
to protect the pawn on G2 to trade
queens and that ends the game as we know
so something needs to be done about the
threat of Rook E2 if you have to make a
move like Queen F2 you're obviously
massively massively unhappy so maybe
Queen H5 this is what he plays yeah and
at least by having provoked F6 Peter
sorry to interrupt you there C4 Knight
D4 and I can maybe maybe Rook E3 is
winning though because Queen G3 check is
yeah a very very strong threat that's a
killer check that's a check although
maybe maybe we have a Perpetual there so
as long as it's not a check we can Queen
G3 because if you play Queen G3 here
Queen h8 check will force the queen back
eventually and then I've got
uh so it's not it's not over yet and
Wesley I think is defending uh more or
less perfectly but it might not be
enough because I think with precise play
there should be a way here for black to
uh get the king to safety win are the
clocks a factor it's hard for me to tell
so it's two minutes it's under three
minutes for Wesley and just under six
minutes for Fabby uh Fab's had the upper
hand throughout the game up in exchange
but winning a position that looks
winning is one of the most difficult
things to do in chess and Wesley the
hardest player to beat definitely coming
up with resources I still think for
Fabby to have those extra three minutes
on the clock yes it's very meaningful so
meaningful in this position exactly and
uh I love that move Rook E3 uh just
reminding Wesley who has the initiative
Rook E3 King G1 and maybe you can just
play something like King to G8 I'm
trying to get out of checks and just to
set up stuff so again we're looking at
Rook e three by the way for those
joining us late we do have two draws
already uh in in the
books Rook G3 is strong here he reaches
for the rook and Rook E3 on the board G4
instantly G4 wow lifting is kimono
that's a big exposing his king um now
the idea of King G8 F5 really starts to
look very attractive I don't like this
move G4 I think it was prompted by by
recognizing that King G1 Rook G3 might
just be fatal I think it wasn't because
he liked G4 it's just that he hated King
G1 more Rook G3 yeah I think R G3 is
just very strong here and yeah here I
think King G8 very specifically saw that
after F5 Queen takes F5 is not a check
and just to illustrate let's make you
know a move and we go F5 Queen takes F5
queen2 and now this is what our King M
to no no King shield for the king five
immediately well but that comes in with
a check now yeah so so the point is King
King G8 you give a check check and then
we go I'm not it's on the board by the
way King moved to G8 what does Fab want
F5 now Fabby okay I I think I got
calculate I think I got it there you go
and F4 is hanging there are no more
checks and the Queens come off and as we
already established if the Queens come
off the game the game ends so that's a
very yeah that's a very smart not way to
force matters there exactly very nice he
takes F5 King G8 What do we think about
P C2 though I understand we're not in
love with it but can we still continue
the game for a bit can you go Queen to
F7 I want to get it to E8 and F4 is
attack H nice well talking this gu sorry
even I didn't see that I was about to
play F5 T you got to bail me out you got
we're it's hard to fight against p in
this you know I needed duge a roof I
need protection you got to Tanya you got
to watch my back I'll I was about to I
was going to fall into the exact same
thing the house has been blown away
there's no roof left here there's no
roof but that said F5 going for this
very direct play very concrete and Fabby
finishing it in style feels like a very
nice conversion yeah uh let's go to the
other games that are still go ongoing
let's go to our tournament leader Liam
uh as he's up against Sam Sean when we
left it we thought that Sam was
okay um and what has happened we're
going to find out as we got ourselves
into a rook and pawn
four four no wait a minute what am it's
five versus five right now but I'm
picking up you are going to pick up but
you might even lose uh I Aon and ewn yes
that was why he started with the move
King F3 I was I was kind of focused on
F2 F4 myself but uh uh King F3 I think
the best we can we can hope for after
King F3 here is three against two if
white could get and we're getting into
very technical stuff here but right I'm
not even sure white gets that but it's
very important for black that the pawn
on F5 and the pawn on e4 will disappear
of the board because you occasionally
lose four against three if if the entire
Queen side
one pair of R disappears and you have a
rook and four pawns on one side against
rook and three that end game has been
lost even by very strong players three
against two not so much exactly and I'm
not even sure you're getting that to be
honest it feels to me that it might be
that black survives with uh something on
the green side as well I agree I feel
that this is balanced to draw the most
likely let's jump to Ray Ray Ray Robson
and Anish Gary because our apologies
that's a fun one as well uh good timing
there yes because players are under a
minute uhoh and a very complex position
where Anish has an extra Pawn but one
lot of weaknesses the G Pawn is attacked
currently there are checks on C8 which
would also win a pawn so a lot of
threats with a very active Queen for
white exactly Queen takes G5 as well as
Queen C8 check captures
F5 uh now then the question is the
remaining pawns okay black has a
passer um should I oh should I be
including
G4 let's start with obvious questions
it's a big question I'm going to leave
Peter to answer that but that's said I'm
going to say I like White's position
here I feel that it's got more threats
and I'm down upon but I would want to be
white here what what do you think P
what's going on you're going to lose
membership into the pond grubers uh the
pawners club yeah I think I think the
extra Pawn here has to be of yeah as we
see uh was agreed between Liam and
samess is a simple game two players play
amazing chess and it ends in a draw
there you
go big update by the way coming in that
Fabiano caruana has made a blunder just
when we left it who we thought was in
Cru what happened there but the N C6 is
well we would we saw we left it at F5
and we were we were all
Applause and something went grossly
wrong oh my God look at Fabby he reacts
oh yeah you just saw his head in his
hands as Queen G4 rocked his world queen
G4 forces his
King into a uh double attack Queen F4
check he's dropped his rook and oh no uh
it's now a draw easy draw easy easy easy
draw for uh and he can't believe it he
can't believe wow I haven't seen fabbi
throw away such a winning position in a
long long time yeah and it's a sequence
of very uncharacteristic Mistakes by
Fabi I think Wesley found in the
position that we last Saw after uh Queen
F5 Queen G8 uh Wesley found a way not to
resign immediately which is the move
Queen B1 which is better than Queen C2
specifically because it does give us a
check to give our own meaning that Queen
H7 no longer works Queen F7 is a very
strong move though attacking the pawn on
F4 attacking the pawn on D5 and giving
your king some squares F5 played and
here if Faby goes Queen E8 here then we
can and then gives a check by a rook and
comes in with the queen that would end
the game on the spot but his choice
isn't much worse he took on D5 white
played Queen B8 check and here for I'm
guessing he missed that final check that
happened in the game because had he
played King G7 here Queen takes C7 Queen
F7 this forces the queen trade more or
less because Queen takes A2 and Rook E1
I still I still mate in two if that
happens and queen F7 reminds me of the
queen f8 uh earlier so Queen F7 would
have won the game but instead he played
King H7 depriving himself of that
option and that see this is the key
moment where he could have just played
as you said
and he takes the pawn yes Queen takes D5
check now all he needs to do is go King
G7 and queen F7 and almost instantly he
clearly decided on that when he took on
D5 and right and then uh I'm I'm
guessing he missed very specifically uh
Queen no you can't miss G5 check it's
the only check in the position that is
true you just can't miss that uh he
missed the the the queen maneuver from
G7 to G4 and eventually to F4 yeah wow
and Wesley of course the Beast that he
is in these positions of resourcefulness
he finds it Queen G7 and has the game
ended already no they're still playing
they're still playing I always found it
unbelievable play these 2800s the moment
the moment you give them a window of
Escape they find it yes uh and that was
that was a remarkable uh uh find there
by uh Wesley as that game uh will likely
end in a Perpetual cheze Queen ending
but what about the Anish game with Ray
Robson Peter uh apparently completely
balanced now and was it have a result
yeah and it seems like they uh agre now
uh in the position we were all unsure
about t picking the side with fewer
pawns and I like giving
checks I I think the points have to go
to Tanya there because you know if the
position is complete T won yes if the
position is actually completely equal
apparently right uh whoever picked the
side with fewer pawns has to win the
moral argument the part that's the part
so uh yeah and Reay apparently assessed
it correctly and defended very well and
the game ended in a draw and there now
four out of four games have been drawn
the remaining game Wesley so versus
Bobby Queen ending and will also
potentially end in a draw right which
means we might have five draws and this
Miss by Fabby yes it reminds me of his
game against Yan where he had an extra
exchange was it Yan where he played
Bishop E7 on day one yes yes yes yes yes
and then again it felt like he did
everything right out of the opening gets
a winning position but then somewhere
let's go of that very big advantage and
that's it we've got handshakes it's game
over Wesley so survives yeah vibby looks
very understandably dejected there
because he knows he knows he left a a
lot on the table point a full point on
the table there well we're going to say
two points and uh no he did he did get a
point out of it he did get a point yeah
wow uh well five draws they were
fighting draws and uh a very happy
Wesley a very happy Wesley so they're
I'm I'm sorry excuse me I'm just still
in a little bit of a shock because when
we watch the US championship and you
know whenever Fabby was getting chances
he was taking advantage of them and
never letting us OPP Escape it wasn't
even a question and this uh this one
Peter that that that that's so far
really really has not been his
tournament uh that game he lost to Ala
it never felt like he was in it frankly
right and yeah and for Fabi not to win
the position that that he just before
our eyes hasn't won yeah it's very very
rare so he'll he'll have to and winless
after four rounds is not something he's
very used to and you do want to win a
game at some point it just makes you
feel much better about life yeah one
thing is the score line it's also the
positions that he got so many missed
opportunities there uh he's got to find
his rhythm and he's got to do it quick
Westley so very relieved after that draw
alongside Ray Robson come to
time in our show where we're going to be
taking our break but before we do that
we always check in with our friends at Q
Boutique and I get this you know nice
little flyer to tell me what's up and uh
you know usually we have a discount 5%
what am I getting today 5% discount
maybe maybe play your card this is the
World Chess Hall of Fame athletic jacket
it's the newest edition of the World
Chess Hall of Fame jacket is here and it
is not to be missed jackets are 95%
polyester and 5% sent spandex wonder
where the spandex goes anyway I
featuring durable hot press logo of the
World Chess Hall of Fame on the front
available men's and women's Styles check
out all your chess shopping needs at St
actually CU Boutique stl.com
and uh before we go on break once more
let's review our standings nothing has
changed because we have five draws five
draws and still Liam in first Liam's got
to be in first after that with some
draws players were able to hold with in
a solid way While others were big hits
and misses and there we are going into
round five Liam Le keeps his lead at B
position with six points alira fuja Ray
Robson with five Maxim Anish Sam at Four
Points and Fabby Yan Wesley along with
Jeffrey at the bottom of the board with
three points they need to start scoring
yes still a long tournament to go for me
I if I'm in oi Raza shoes draw with
black against nepo yeah I'm going to
take that result I feel that that he uh
he he's the one who won the most and
maybe Fabby is the one who who earned
definitely the most uh disappointed with
that draw has got to be Fabiana Carana
but there are two big rapid games coming
up don't go anywhere we'll be right
back
[Music]
fana welcome back to St Louis your home
welcome back to Grand chour how do you
feel to come back here after Grand Swiss
it's just one week ago the tournament
has finished how did you assess your
result yeah it was it's good to be back
I I right before Grand Swiss I was
playing an event here the US Chess
Championship and I I had this event in
between which was a very very big and
influential event for a lot of players
and for me there was a little bit less
writing on it because I wasn't trying to
qualify for the candidates um but it was
a very exciting event anyway and uh
decided two places in the candidates
tournament so that was that was very
important vid and Nakamura made their um
had their success there and yeah for me
it was a little bit less um of an
exciting event let's say it was going
quite decently and then at the end I
kind of ran out of steam and the Finish
was very disappointing for me uh so
overall it wasn't like very negative or
very positive uh certainly a little bit
disappointing but I'm hoping that what
I'm looking forward to is that we have
rapid and Blitz now so it's a bit of a
change because I played in the last uh
few months mostly classical chess I had
how many games you played I
wonder like played 11 in the US
Championship quite a long and tough
event and then 11 in the grand Swiss so
a little bit longer than average and
here we have in the singfield cup n
classical games a little bit of a more
usual schedule but it's nice that we
have a kind of intereso before so we
have rapid and Blitz chest a little bit
let's say less pressure in terms of
preparation and and that sort of thing
and more based on like your current form
and how you're feeling your mood so I'm
hoping that I'll be in good shape for
that also for me it's very important of
course um because I'm In Contention in
the grand chest tour standings I'm in a
good position but last two events will
be very critical yeah for sure and
coming back a little bit to this the
candidates tournament and you spot there
I mean you you said that you played in
Grand Swiss with a strange feeling yes
that you were you already qualified you
reached your goal already and how was it
actually to play there I mean having in
mind that let's say you don't need to to
do so and what do you think about the
other players how difficult it was for
them yeah I can say from experience that
these events are a lot of pressure and
even this year when I was playing the
World Cup it was a huge amount of
pressure and I felt it very strongly
physical effects the tiredness and
everything and the grand was a bit
different because I didn't really feel
that pressure but I'm not sure maybe it
wasn't a good thing like maybe it's
better to feel that drive to like uh you
have to win this game I I remember in
The Grand in 2021 it was I I had to
qualify for candidates by that
tournament and I was playing Ali Resa in
penultimate round no sorry two rounds
before the end and I kind of felt like I
really need to win this game and I was
able to win it and to secure Kansas's
qualification mostly because of that win
against Ali Resa and this time I think
if if I needed to qualify I would
consider the game against deak in two
rounds before the end again like
absolute must-win to get top two like
very very important to win this game and
I didn't have this feeling of like
intensity so maybe it also um sort of
let me down in a way in that sense while
during the World Cup I had a really
strong feeling of like intensity like
every game is super crucial so it it
gave me a lot of stress I I wouldn't say
it's like good for my health but maybe
it's good for tournament performance
yeah like for example Nakamura had to to
try to win against you right in order to
get the spot in the candidates and
speaking about this tournament I mean
how often do you think about it you know
it's going to be on April there are so
many events in between and things to do
but still do you think about the event
and what do you think about the field
which we know already the candidates the
candidates yes let's say yeah I know I
for me it's the biggest event on the
calendar for sure like every event is
important every event I care about but
um there's only one two events a year
that I really like
um put all my effort into preparation
and before the tournament and everything
like coming to singfield cup I mostly
have a normal schedule and for
candidates of course everyone is is
taking it so seriously because it's a
unique chance to play a world
championship match that and almost
always first place is the only one which
counts yeah last time was a bit unusual
that second place ended up also counting
but usually you really need to win so of
course you need some luck in order like
you need the right circumstances but you
also also need um very good preparation
and you need to be on form so everyone
takes it the most seriously that they
can and I I've played many already uh so
I have a lot of experience but I
sometimes I wonder if this experience is
like super important or not because the
first time I played in 2016 I had no
experience and my preparation wasn't
ideal let's say looking back on it but
somehow I almost almost almost was able
to to pull it off and Sergey kaken was
the one who who qualified for world
championship match that time so
sometimes I don't know if it's more like
experience or um sometimes coming into
it for the first time like we'll see
some players in next one um is also like
a huge motivation like prag is the first
time I think um also
abasov I know he's not 100% in but uh
but assuming he plays then it's also
first time for him and vidit as well so
we see a few first- timers here I think
it's it's both the most interesting
event of the Year besides the world
championship match but also um for the
players of course takes on a unique
amount of stress and uh pressure yes so
this what I wish you I me all the best
of luck in this in this tournament thank
you thank you thanks the 2023 Grand
chess tour reaches its epic conclusion
with its fifth world class event the
2023 sinkfield cup it's back to
classical chess with Front Runners
settling in for the final push to the
Finish Line however two of America's
Finest stand in their way joining the
Freya wild cards who will try to cash in
on the opportunity while making things
as difficult as possible for hopeful
tour players who can win the illustrious
cup and will it be enough for them to
emerge as the 2023 Grand chess tour
Champion follow the St Louis chess clubs
twitch and YouTube channels to tune in
to live coverage of the 2023 sinkfield
cup November 21st to December 1st to
find
out
hello I'm women's Grand Master V Jan I
will be creating content for Grand chest
store follow us on social media and
catch more behind the scenes
content the St Louis chess club is the
Premier chess facility in the United
States we bring the educational benefits
of Chess to thousands of students across
the St Louis area we also promote Chess
at the highest levels hosting all levels
of the US championships as well as
high-profile tournaments that attract
the world's best players become a member
and enjoy perks such as free classes and
lectures weekly tournaments and so much
more visit St Louis chess club.org to
claim your membership today the World
Chess Hall of Fame located in the heart
of St Louis's historic Central West End
want to know why chess has intrigued
people around the world for nearly 1,500
years stop by and learn about the impact
of Chess from our three floors
showcasing the art culture and history
of the game the World Chess Hall of Fame
has something for everyone to enjoy for
more information on current exhibits
please visit World Chess hf.org
St Louis the chess capital of the United
States it also plays host to an
award-winning shop dedicated to chess
merchandise All Occasion gifts and
plenty more at Q Boutique you can shop
both in store and online from quirky
greeting cards to luxury chest sets
there is something for everyone at Q
Boutique enjoy a shopping experience
like no other make sure to check out Q
Boutique stl.com for a wide variety of
gifts for everyone to enjoy the St Louis
chess club Scholastic program brings the
educational value of Chess to kids and
schools across the St Louis area active
in over 100 schools throughout the St
Louis city and county the St Louis chess
club has been able to reach over 85,000
students in both in school and after
school programs we view chess as a
valuable educational tool learn more
about our Scholastic programming by
visiting St Louis chess club.org
education hello I'm women's Grand Master
R to janua I will take you behind the
scenes of the grand chest St follow us
on social media and don't miss out on
players interviews and more content from
the playing
Hall the St Louis chess club is the
Premier chess facility in the United
States and is among the best in the
world thanks to co-founders Dr jeie
Karen singfield and Rex singfield the St
Louis chess club is a nonprofit
organization committed to promoting the
game of chess locally and
internationally we bring the educational
benefits of Chess to thousands of
students across the St Louis area
promoting cognitive development critical
thinking concentration and analytical
skills the St Louis chess club welcomes
chess lovers of any age and skill level
to come and enjoy the game of chess we
also promote Chess at the highest levels
hosting all levels of the US
championships and the American Cup as
well as high-profile tournaments that
attract the world's best players
including the prestigious sinkfield cup
Karen's cup and many more all
tournaments can be streamed via our
YouTube and twitch channels that also
include over 2,000 chess lectures for
anyone to enjoy become a member and
enjoy perks such as free classes and
lectures weekly tournaments merchandise
discounts and so much more visit St
Louis chess club.org to claim your
membership
[Music]
today the World Chess Hall of Fame
located in the heart of St Louis's
historic Central West End want to know
why chess has intrigued people around
the world for nearly 1,500 years stop by
and learn about the impact of Chess from
our three floors showcasing the art
culture and history of the game
landmarked by the world's largest chess
piece sitting outside our front door the
World Chess Hall of Fame has something
for everyone to enjoy including various
exhibitions monthly concerts and much
more whether you are a beginner or a
professional there is something for
everyone to learn here at the World
Chess Hall of Fame enjoy free admission
to our rotating exhibitions in our
Galleries and sign up for chess events
familyfriendly programming and art
classes and don't forget to stop by our
award-winning gift shop Q Boutique and
Shop a wide selection of Chess related
merchandise for more information on
current exhibits please visit World
Chess h.org
[Music]
St Louis the chess capital of the United
States boasts the world class St Louis
chess club and the World Chess Hall of
Fame it also plays host to an
award-winning shop dedicated to chess
merchandise All Occasion gifts and
plenty more at Q Boutique you can shop
both in store and online for chess
merchandise autograph Collectibles chess
campus souvenirs and much much more from
quirky greeting cards to luxury chess
sets there is something for everyone at
Q Boutique and all purchases go right to
benefiting new exhibitions and programs
at the World Chess Hall of Fame
dedicated to exploring chess and its
immense impact on art and culture
located on the first floor of the World
Chess Hall of Fame enjoy a shopping
experience like no other and become
everyone's favorite Gift Giver if you
can shop in store make sure to check out
Q Boutique stl.com for a wide variety of
gifts for everyone to
[Music]
enjoy the St Louis chess club Scholastic
program brings the educational value of
Chess to kids and schools across the St
Louis area active in over 100 schools
throughout the St Louis city and county
the St Louis chess club has been able to
reach over 85,000 students in both in
school and after school programs we
created the select chess training
program and the junior select chess
training program in order to elevate the
skill level in students across the St
Louis area these students receive
professional training from Grandmaster
verua niobian other programs include
chess cops a partnership with the St
Louis Police Department looking to
improve relationship between atrisk kids
and police officers in the St Louis area
with over 600 students playing chess
over the board since
2019 the St Louis chess club has also
created a chess merit badge for the
scouts BSA quickly becoming one of the
most popular badges with more than
250,000 Scouts earning the badge since
2011 students of chess can also pick up
a copy of read and WR chess thanks to
Club co-founder Dr jeie Karen sinkfield
and anyone can learn how to understand
chess notation in no time we view chess
as a valuable educational tool learn
more about our Scholastic programming by
visiting St Louis chess club.org
[Music]
education welcome back everyone as we
are about to go into round five of the
St Louis rapid and we started with five
draws and yes so let's take a look at
the standings let's do it going into our
next game and this is where we are Liam
still on a pole position with six points
followed by Ali RZA and Ray Robson at
five a bunch of players with four points
and Fabby Yan Wesley still struggling
with form absolutely and tell us about
the pairings for this upcoming round
five and uh we have it on our screens it
is Anish giri taking taking on
tournament leader Liam Le five hard
fought pairings right there which one
stands out to you yasa fuia so Fabby Ray
mvl nepo I would have said mvl and NEPA
would be a marquee matchup but I'm
looking at Fabby Ray fuja Wesley all
around and also for fuja and Wesley as
you say this is going to be a clash of
styles the very Dynamic Ali RZA fuja
against the so solid Wesley uh and
Wesley with that big big save
against Fabby yeah he's feeling very
good Sam Sean's feeling very good as
well Jeffrey Jang needs to find his form
tied for seven there no that's not going
to cut it Sam uh is feeling uh quite
pleased with himself I'm going to say
with the draw in round four I think I
think so starting the day with a with a
solid draw yeah on on the black side
against the tournament there shouldn't
be right unhappy at all uh he played a
very decent game I thought I want to
pick your my your brain a little thereit
Peter about the game that nepo just drew
with fua it's a scotch it's a
double-edged crazy mixed up chaotic
Scotch but it just felt that nepo never
had a opportunity for an advantage but
he consistently plays the scotch
why uh I'm Not My Brother's Keeper uh I
I don't really know and honestly that
game mystified me a little bit because
uh the line he played the line of the
scotch he played could have been and we
showed while he was think we showed very
very crazy lines that could result from
uh their particular line in particular
once uh F4 was met by G5 and Yan just
went into a very quiet ending which
never looked like it would be better for
him right uh I was a bit surprised by
that because the opening Choice seemed
to be saying I want a a full-blooded
fight right and then we got something
which wasn't quite that game and even
slightly worse yeah he had to defend I
would say for for a portion of the game
at least right he clearly isn't playing
his best chest yet but maybe he is
trying to kind of play himself in slowly
there's still five more games of rapid
and then 18 games of Blitz and uh I
still feel somewhat okay about my pick
of the overall winner which
was I think a lot of that credit for Yan
not getting what he wants out of the
opening goes to Ali Resa because when
Yan played the idea of f4 which was
clearly part of his prep Ali Resa
decided to go for the most direct
approach with G5 and it was and it
worked absolutely fine he got out of the
opening without any trouble and uh in
fact at moments we felt he's the one who
could perhaps try for more Ali RZA fuja
in great form so far Yan first day a
little shaky but Yan was Peter's pick
also a little bit we go I was hoping you
wouldn't bring that up no but Faby
played great through what maybe 50 moves
before he didn't play that move King G7
and queen F7 we've seen that that
happened more than once this tournament
already where he's had this great start
he's got everything that you can dream
of in this field of players but just
missing it missing that conversion
something's missing something's missing
uh-oh here is our p and uh
well boy uh ge is it me or is it me that
stands
out the center of the pick right there
with ala but it's Liam Le who has uh
been the big leader so far but I must
say I respect you all uh your
participation has been oh my gosh
where's my participation certificate but
you know what yes there are still lots
of games to go there are there are and
we have seen in the grand Chester uh
players performing a certain way in the
rapid and then raking up a lot of points
in the blitz so anything can happen ex
exactly I'm still waiting for Wesley
also to find this form yeah Wesley is
really not playing not playing anywhere
near his b best and yesterday was a
struggle and today he should have
frankly just should have lost that game
to fa there's no other way to describe
it so um both of them searching for
Forum you kind of I want to say that
Wesley backed his way into that exchange
sacrifice because you judge it you go no
no no that's not working out but then
you kind of said well he didn't really
have a good alternative Yeah by that
point by that point he already misplayed
the position enough that he more or less
had to go for it and uh M the conversion
was very clean until that moment where
Fabby suddenly just chose chose to go
for that King March which looked
suboptimal and was suboptimal you know
guys as we get ready for the start of uh
uh round five I realize that in talking
about our athletic jacket from Q
Boutique yes we didn't get a chance to
show the audience what I was talking
about so we're going to do it all over
again here it comes are you ready from
the world ch Hall of Fame the athletic
jacket the newest edition of the World
Chess Hall of Fame jacket is here and it
is not to be missed jackets are 95%
pester and 5% spandex and feature an
outstanding durable don't make me laugh
Tanya hot press logo of the World Chess
Hall of Fame on the front it is
available in men's and women's sale at Q
Boutique STL faintly Batman doesn't it
Batman yeah like a jacket that Batman
would wear yeah I like that there's this
SK ears there up top as well I know in
those they not oh I see it nicely
noticed once you notice it you you don't
miss it anymore that very good very good
all right well now you know how uh to
get it done as we get ready for this
round five we see Sam taking a seat Neo
just making sure that I'm at the right
board that has happened to me as well I
has it happened to you that you sat down
at the wrong board during the game not
before the game during not during the
game but I think I've done that once
Miguel naidorf once sat in my seat and
he was the Arbiter of the tournament he
was like dude excuse me but can I take
my seat oh yes sir my yeah there are
there are some some fantastic stories
but we have brown starting so right
right the best ever arbit story I have I
have is probably from one of the
European Club cups in in recent times
but it requires for me to have to be
able to set up a position and we don't
have time for that right now I remember
it was a tournament in Yugoslavia I was
a spectator the gong had sounded the
gong had sounded and the Arbiter went to
make sure all of the boards and clocks
were in progress and he came to this
board and he said gentlemen the game is
started no jokes and he put the pawn
back on e4 that story some hampered by
the fact that your your board is not on
screen but okay so the pawn is on E5 and
white says not only is my Pawn on E5 Mr
Arbiter but it's also my
turn the Arbiter is interfering with the
game that was uh that was quite uh
amusing where shall we go well we're
going to let's start with the players on
our screens and we and
nepo as they have started as classically
as possible is it just me but uh Joko
piano seem to be missing uh so far
Bishop e s uh Peter what okay what what
and my
misclicks do it choose this moment to
rear yeah A6 Bishop A4 Bishop B7 not
something I have seen but apparently
still more than 100 games from this
position I think what this does is it
wins you depending on which time control
you're playing I don't know 30 seconds
and maybe maybe maybe a minute and a
half maybe a minute and a half to two
minutes in in Rapid maybe 5 minutes in
classical and then you go KN F six next
move and you're perfectly happy right
that would be my guess but maybe Yan has
something else in mind but but it has
one Yan uh a few seconds as Maxim is
still thinking and the reason why he's
slightly surprised is because the normal
move is that you first develop the
Knight before you take out the bishop so
you want to bring your knight out to F6
which would be the normal move but
instead million games with Knight F6
instead of Bishop E7 now there
is with Bishop B5 there is the is it the
yanos Gambit with F5 okay is that
without A6 or with A6 that's without I
think with A6 it called something else
yeah
that's so then you get some crazy lines
like this right where wow I mean it just
goes it's deep
now is there something that maybe mvl is
thinking that he could be sucker punched
with an F5 no I mean that's it's making
him this this looks really really bad
ridiculous right yeah it's it's not
great even without the inclusion of
bishop7 and castles and with the
inclusion of bishop7 and castles this
looks like it something that should lose
not just just lose right so I'd be I'd
be shocked if that was the intention I'm
I'm fairly certain the intention is to
reply to castles with Knight of six but
of course could be it could be proven
wrong and by the way it wasn't a minute
and a half I think it was closer to two
they move Bishop E7 I have look I've
been around yeah and Bish E7 is not on
the board in any games that I've ever
play he hasn't castled though he played
something C4 or what did he do yeah it
looks like maybe he played
C4 yeah C4 and whoa C4 and almost
instantly Knight comes up no almost
instantly to C4 after playing Bishop E7
what's the most natural move Tanya well
he did play KN F6 he played Knight F6
first yes yes the he played Knight F6
but I know what you want on the next
move yes and of course what is the most
uh obvious move in the position Bishop
E7 to C5 uh forcibly reminds me of the
game C4 the English with Bishop B4 and
then after playing D6 you could play
Bishop B4 back to C5 and I think it was
yeah it was it was also Os game against
Fabby uh which he hasn't lost despite
being completely lost by move 18 he was
trying hard he was yeah he was working
very very hard at creating a miniature
that goes into into opening mistake
books right uh but
in comparison to that English the big
comparison is the bishop is on A4 and
not on F1 right and I'm not sure if that
is good or bad I think it's probably
more good than bad because you're you're
not hampering your own castling you
don't really it probably stays on A4 for
a while but it's not in the way of your
uh play in the center I want to allow
the players because they have done
something that in the history of Chess
is an extraordinary hard to do they have
reached a novel position in a rui Lopez
by move six which I think is just
impossible the Le database says there
was one game which featured the move C4
and Knight F6 although it looks very
very natural is technically a novelty
and Castel castles has been added to the
position in the meantime and the
interesting note here is that you can
play Knight Tak C5 which is a very very
typical little tactic in all of these
types of positions to which I think in
this particular case black is likely not
to recapture I think black is likely to
play something like Knight D4 and play
for positional compens with some D6
Bishop G4 ideas uh the engine is also
suggesting for some reason starting with
the move B7 B5 which I don't quite
understand I I don't know why that
improves uh Black's case I would be very
tempted to play Knight E5 Tanya what
about you especially with black having
spent two tempos to get the Bishop from
E7 to C5 but that said I think for many
for many you know it's it might not be
easy to understand but there is a lot of
sense behind it as well because white
has committed the C Pawn to C4 creating
the dark s weaknesses on theare on the
D4 Square you want to try and control
that very often in these positions white
has the idea of instead going C3 D4
which now is not possible so the bishop
on C5 is a very tempting point and we
see that Knight E5 is now the on the
board and this is the drawback uh of
spending C two tempos yeah and also
Bishop C5 so what are we so excited
about for white we're thinking that if
you do do the obvious thing in capturing
figur out B5 here
D4 and you are about to tell me that
instead of Knight E5 why do they do B5
and in order to explain that I have to
go back to uh the line you were starting
to show the line starting with Knight
takes E5 if you take on E5 white of
course goes D4 and the point is if you
play Bishop
D6 Knight yeah but why white will play
C5 here continuing to attack the bishop
and I think black is in tremendous
amounts of trouble it's possibly beyond
beyond repair even yeah so the reason
you play B5 here is to destruct this
Pawn get it away from the C5 square and
now we go back to this position and we
get
here uh where we're Pawn down but we do
have some counter playay against the
Central Pawn on e4 the bishop will come
out to B7 or if white takes on A6 it
will come out to A6 will occupy a
reasonably active Square The Rook will
come out to E8 I'm still not entirely
sold on this being enough honestly and
neither is the engine as you can see the
engine says it's playable but it doesn't
equalize fully feels but comparing this
to this no comparison you you definitely
take this one over the position with the
pawn on C5 the other option would be to
play after D4 just to
play5 on the board by the way and and
this but yeah B5 played and this I think
reinforces the idea that Yan actually
maybe looked at C4 for a bit but this
brings me to my next question what if I
just say go ahead play positionally you
you you you sacrifice a PA Knight takes
Pawn takes Bishop G4 is going to be very
awkward I I understand but I'm hoping
that I'll be able to you know do some
repair work Queen E1 let let's take a
look at that for a second because I I
think I'd be I'd be very very scared to
to actually enter this uh with white but
maybe it's playable and I'm a bit
saddened by the engine suggestion here
because I wanted to play romantic chess
I wanted to take the pawn that would
have my first question Pawn takes Pawn
yes you've got E5 but I'm not going to
move my knight away from F6 I'm just
going to pin your a queen yes it's your
influence I'm all for Pawn grabbing here
wonderful uh a converted conversion and
an additional plus to this move of
course is that we we keeping the bishop
on C1 restrained by stopping white from
playing D4 or D3 because we are now
controlling the square I still would
very much like my my eye was very drawn
to some ideas of I don't know playing
Knight H5 Knight F4 and giving mate on
the king side but I'm guessing white
isn't time to play D3 Bishop B3 and stop
that but uh to continue your point Peter
takes on C4 King H1 obviously I am
intending
F3 did not see that one yeah I very much
like reading the first line when I'm you
know it's there is a very specific
pleasure to just being able to to show
these things on the screen the things
that you would probably not find if
you're on your own and you just you just
go for something like this and and you
and you look very smug
yeah wow I I don't think it's the only
move in the position I suspect you can
play you can play without it I have a
feeling that you're not going to be
doing too poorly if you just play rookie
8 yeah it's also playable but 9 D5 is
visual yeah preferable yeah I I was
thinking I was going to play F3 and
maybe B3 and Bishop B2 and get out of it
but hey look the round just started of
course nepo and mvl stole our show
because of this move Bishop E7 you're
just getting a novel position after a
half a dozen moves in chess that's
highly highly unlikely turning to the
game of Sam and Jeffrey it looks like
one of these early Queen D7 Uh Russian
defenses that we see and indeed it is
that Queen D7 I mean talk about an
opening circus these days I mean if you
showed this move to a beginning chess
player Queen to D7 don't try this at
home exactly only I I wanted to go in a
similar direction to what you're saying
but slightly differently I want to say
if you show qu7 to I don't know
Alexander Alin right and say 2100 yeah
who is not a beginner yeah yeah yeah at
the height of his powers you just you
just show him the position after move
five and you tell him currently the best
option we have here with according to
the 23rd C spend a Tempo hampering your
own pieces putting the queen in front of
your B Bishop just to stop Knight E4 and
queen takes d8 without allowing some
slightly inferior games and you watch
his reaction his reaction Alan
specifically maybe would have been sort
of okay with it because he was very much
I think ahead of his time in
understanding Dynamics and uh but yeah
chess has moved on from he would look at
you and repeat the immortal words of uh
bent Larson nobody believes you
no queen7 in the 21st century that's
what they play yeah I think I think we
every day change the rules that story
remains relevant every day we see
something that brings that story to mind
exactly Queen D7 remarkable stuff the
current position however say having said
that well Jeffrey looks okay I mean he's
ready to play Knight C6 B6 Bishop B7
complete his development then the queen
on D7 is perfectly placed I know it's
crazy all of a sudden strange let's go
to Le think what you're what you were
talking about right now has been the
biggest influence of computer that moves
and principles that earlier were not
questioned have now become so much more
concrete play has become so much more
concrete ideas that were just dismissed
are now suddenly in play we play H4 in
every position now I know it's crazy
even with our completing development
Queen D7 and everything looks fine but
let's move on to our tournament leader
who has a big game against Anish giri
and where is White's beon
it's got it got tra got tra um I wanted
to say there was a game from um the
tournament that you br her open
specifically it was aaro Nakamura he was
playing some Dutch where he literally in
the first 12 moves moved as
Queen yeah it was like the first 14
moves he moved his Queen like eight
times logical yeah and he was slightly
better and I was The Grandmaster in
residence for the chess club and I had
to write a blog about this because every
chess coach in the world was dying you
like tell people telling their students
don't fall in love with your queen don't
move your queen too often in the opening
he broke every cardinal rule and it
worked out brilliantly he went on and
won the game and I think he won the
tournament too by the way J bror was a
great tournament for him uh Peter how
did they get how did the players get
here uh this is a sort of a classical
Roso with Bishop B5 on move three in a
sicilian met by G6 which used to be
absolutely the main way to respond in
these days it has been somewhat deserved
I think by the move E6 which become has
become very fashionable but G6 is still
the main stay Bishop takes C6 and this
is the old approach I think a lot of
people are are now taking with the B
Pawn aiming for more complicated more
Dynamic play uh and D6 is the the old
way of playing right and we have castles
uh Bishop G7 uh D3 E5 uh A3 very logical
once once the pawn appears on E5 and the
bishop is no longer controlling the long
diagonal the A3 B4 plans are logical and
we're still following some uh some some
games even Queen E7 before is known and
even Knight F6 Bak C5 we have a
reasonably high level game uh played in
uh Autumn of uh last year with GES
playing the black pieces here against CL
sov young Russian player and gkes didn't
touch that pawn I don't know exactly
what he played and I'm kind of worried
to CLI he he castled here I can see he
castled them because I have clicked on
the names a couple of times completely
ruining our and he so I I don't want to
do that but he he clearly he castled
here and instead instead of that our
tournament leader took on C5 here and
then went on back to E7 because Bishop
A3 is obviously a massive threat um I
don't think I like this I don't think
it's horrible but my first reaction is
we just go Bishop A3 which appears to
which appears to provoke C5 right and
then even even this just play C4 play
Knight C3 play Knight D5 next move and I
understand this is some sometimes
double-edged because what black does I
think if black wants this to to be a
double-edged game you allow the Knight
to land on D5 and you try to play around
it and just to play play on the king
side right you move the Knight away from
F6 you play for F5 F4 G5 and try to give
mate but I think you're very far behind
in that race here I think it just not
going to work out and then it I would be
very pleased with myself here with white
I think right now you're talking from
the Prejudice point of view of a
grunfeld player because the grunfeld
player does not have a Pawn on E5 yeah
you've provoked C5 which is a groom F
player you're happy to achieve but both
C5 and E5 then the bishop on G7 looks a
little lousy yeah I think I think that's
a reasonable approach pet C4 and
honestly returning to this position
where GES didn't take on C5 my my point
is very often I've seen not in this
particular position but in this
structure in general youle
and then you will take on C5 if it's if
it's convenient but I think it's very
often possible to just ignore
it and go for that play just saying you
can have it you can spend three hanging
on to it in the mean time I will give
you mate on the other side of the board
and that approach appeals to me uh much
more than what Liam is doing so far
completely different uh approach by
Annie she's played Knight D D2 Bishop
may be coming to A3 but he's Knight is
definitely intending to land on C4 how
do you like these apples it's a more
restrained approach I would say I think
Bishop A3 C5 C4 was sort of very much
defining the structure for the rest of
the game this is more flexible okay uh I
think honestly I liked what I what I
should I thought it was very direct and
I I really didn't like Black's position
there but this should still be quite
Pleasant for white Tanya early moments
but I feel like maybe Liams little
wobbly here he could he could be uh
seriously a disadvantage I thought the
question about the C5 Bond was really
instructive because many times uh not
grabbing the pawn is more beneficial
because you don't end up opening this
very critical diagonal and the D6 sare
where a piece would land with even more
power so it is uh sometimes you just
leave your opponent's pawns on because
they're more useful to you on the board
than off the board now that's a concept
by the way what you just said that I was
very proud when I realized that could be
the case that my opponents got a pawn
right directly in front of my king and
it's helping me it's your defensive
Shield the opposing Pawn is defending my
own King so in this case uh bring us up
to date Peter the KN on C4 looks
impressive uh it still looks very very
harmonious for why the night on C4 is
very pleasant the night the Bon and5 is
doing a very good
job keeping the night keeping the Knight
safe and also restricting the black
structure on the queen side but the
Knight on H5 will at some point jump to
F4 and you will be faced with a somewhat
uncomfortable decision because it looks
like uh it's it's very annoying but if
you take it just to to illustrate the
point these are not very forcing moves
uh you can do it we're back to me not
being able to make a move I think it's
maybe because let me I can do it for you
because because it's not white it's
smovie I understand why uh you got in H3
you missed so let say four and yes you
can yes you can tolerate it for a while
but even if you leave it there G5
already becomes something black could
consider G5 followed by H5 G4 and if you
do
take you definitely will start at some
point Maybe not immediately because
Knight H2 Queen H5 might be good reply
but let's say we start with Bishop B6
and then in let's say the Knight goes
away your king side starts looking a bit
bare and if the pawn storm eventually
comes Bishop it could be quite dangerous
so once again I don't want to overstate
the point but choosing between Bish 3
Follow by c493 95 and what Anish got in
the game I would have chosen I would
have chosen my Approach all right uh I
just have to say that uh we saw the pawn
Sacrifice by nepo uh a moment ago well
he's followed up with another pawn
sacrif another Pawn sacrifice why
sacrifice one when you can sacrifice to
right Knight takes E5 is where we left
it you had mentioned Peter this is idea
of playing positionally like you've
sacrificed tupon not necessarily because
you want to Checkmate your opponent
which is a good idea sacrificing win the
game oh because you want to defeat your
opponent on by by forking them
tactically but you're doing it
positionally so the idea is our Knight
takes up residents in the center of the
board please develop my
pieace and rookie eight but excuse me
two pawns two pawns and I think also the
problem is you would normally want to
follow it up and now that in particular
now that white play D2 D3 especially you
would want to follow it up with D6 let's
say Knight F3 Bishop G4 a dream and if
if if that is the case it's it's
dramatic enough that why start shading
material here just to deal with this uh
with this P but there is a very very
large problem with this plan because now
that we've played B5 why just goes
Knight C6 here and that's over all the
same all the same attacks just lack any
kind of bite if there is no no Knight on
D4 you just play Queen C2 you play
Bishop B3 next move and you you're just
two pawns up with a very healthy
position so it seems like this is slow
it seems like he will have to play the
the engine goes on Rook Rook E8 and then
eight eggs B5 but we can even take we're
we're not we're not really in in any
particular discomfort and it's two pawns
and it remains it Remains Two pawns
black black will have some play some
position like this is never entirely
lost you can you can definitely find
some compensation but it's still I think
if if it was only one I would take this
with black I think I I would think I
have enough take the B2 Pawn off the
board or imagine that for instance I I
would feel that I have enough for a
point I probably don't have enough for
two but how do they score against one
another uh Tanya very close uh wow this
is their head to head again two speech T
specialist
uh 13 wins 13 losses so an absolutely
equal score with a 20 draws have played
each other a bunch of times a really
exciting game to boot and I think that
balance that we saw 13 to 133 I think
we're going to see that shift today okay
well uh with the t-on advantage after
the move D2 D3 we'll keep an eye on that
I wanted to go to our tournament leader
h he is oh pardon me we that was the
game we concentrated on Knight F4 Rook
B1 Que Queen
C7 uh Liam is basically saying if I
don't have to play C5 I'd prefer not to
I would prefer to play Bishop to E6 I
like this approach I like that Knight on
F4 anytime white captures tries to get
rid of it it opens up the bishop things
looking good here for Lim a white spawn
structure on the queen side also can be
weak the Knight on C4 is tied down to
guard A5 we will come back to this with
the position that catches my attention
is one that I know you very interested
in as well uh yasa with Ali Resa with
the white pieces against wesle so and
this also started as a Petro as the
Russian defense but I see a Pawn on H4 I
see those Knights on the king side and I
think we have to break this down what's
going on here exactly well Wesley uh
unfortunately for white E2 E4 players is
really one of the toughest players to
get out of his I want to say Russian SL
Berlin for four versus 4 3 versus three
type of games and he virtually never
loses them and uh this is one of those
cases where maybe it appears more
menacing than it is Knight on G4 Knight
on G5 Bishop F4 a lot of uh white clouds
hovering over Black's King how how
difficult is it Peter it's very
difficult to judge I think you need to
uh to calculate properly to analyze
properly it is very heavily theoretical
even two moves ago this is still a
massive I mean there's not very many
games but they are very very top heavy
yeah there is a victory here for Fab
against shakarov there is also a very
nice victory for uh under burich against
my friend Maxim matlakov which was I
think the 2021 Grand s on is of man I
think I remember that game uh so you do
see good players actually make progress
here and it's not really such a shocker
frankly because the black position on on
the king side does look somewhat exposed
and you still haven't gotten all of your
all of your ducks in a row NE of five is
a novelty though as far as I can tell
this is a a new approach by Wesley and
hard to say hard to say if if if it's
something he just chose over the board
or previously played was instead of
people played Queen D7 people played F6
some kind of natural looking moves were
preferred Queen D7 in particular looks
very normal
stoping making n G4 harder to to realize
white often continues with H5 tries to
sacrifice something on on the king
side and uh the score between them let's
take a look and also a very very close
yeah 10 wins to alira fuja nine losses
against Wesley so with 21 that's a lot
of draws I would have said Wesley played
Ali Raza when Ali Raza was young got an
edge and kept it I would have been wrong
10 wins nine losses so Knight F5 novelty
Knight G4 and the current assessment is
around equal and black apparently can
even afford to make a move like Bishop
D6 not challenging any of uh the the
knights but trying to exchange some
pieces trying to connect the Rooks in
particular if the if the trade happens
even though I can see now on my screen
they're not taking with the queen for
some reason they're taking with the
Knight which honestly looks a bit scary
moving moving a Pieces away from it see
from where it seems they're needed but
right as you can see the evolation keeps
going down because black is more or less
ready now to play F7 F6 and start
driving these Pieces away way but is it
critical for black to use this moment to
actually trade the Bishops on D6 uh if
he doesn't find it could it mean that
white can also potentially look at
sacrificing The Rook for this uh yeah
one one motive which I think might be
relevant here I didn't really check it
properly but if you play F6 I have a
yeah okay there's a simpler there's a
simpler reputation which and Knight C7
follow by6 just wins a lot of material
but the8 Haven caught your eye yeah the
tactic I wanted to show was this which
is is also very very strong so you
probably aren't ready yet to start
chasing these Pieces away with your
pawns so trying to trade them for for
your own light pieces is probably the
wiser course of action and I think the
reason bishop6 attracts your attention
so much is your choices are somewhat
limited I'm not sure which other move to
suggest on the board yeah like 27 feels
like you might be allowing something
yeah allowing H5 for instance doesn't
doesn't feel right
right all right well thank you for that
Peter as we uh continue our look around
the board want to jump into uh the game
between Fabby and Ray Robson this feels
like it came out of something played at
the US Championship but no it's not I I
definitely this is an E3 English and you
know I played these englishes he's like
a reverse Ros alumo to me exactly I
played these positions with white like
my whole career and I have never let me
stress never in this position captured
with the pawn queen takes a has been you
know like the automatic for you know
decades takes with the pawn a new
Wrinkle in this ageold uh position
followed by E3 E4 if I captured with a
pawn I wasn't following it up with E3 E4
either I I would have assumed that my
intention with the pawn capture was to
play D4 but then I have to deal with E4
as a counter so E4 and let's get catch
up with the players and you know somehow
at the end of all of this I'm going to
say I actually have a preference for
White's position slightly I think it's
fairly it's fairly level but uh White
could definitely you can definitely
imagine white becoming a bit better
there crazy D3 D4 on my agenda I've got
the two Bishops Knight on H5 maybe it's
a tactic yeah definitely BL needs to uh
find a decent solution here immediately
here because as you said KN on H5 feels
a bit ify and D4 D5 is a push that needs
to be addressed but there's probably a
decent way to to address it the engine
says supporting The Rook on B5 so that D
doesn't he the rook and also creating
the idea of Rook B5 B4 looks like a
natural start yeah seems Seems like a
perfectly uh sensible way to proceed
here you do have to wonder about the
move like Knight D2 trying to play
against that Knight on H5 but Bishop
G4 um the heartless the heartless
machine says we we have everything under
control here to not to panic and if you
take the move back and I go ahead and
play D4 and you go ahead and play Rook
D2 and I find a square for my queen I
don't know E3 let me just throw Queen E3
and I will start I will start liking
this for black of it like Bishop C4
followed by H6 and your Bishop on G5
isn't such a great piece if uh it's a
good point somehow my pawns on D3 and
pardon me on D4 and E4 my central Pond
Duo aren't scaring anybody are they not
not if we have a good Square for the
bishop to avoid the for Queen E3 was
wrong Queen D3 Peter probably a better
move yeah you can take and take and
somehow hit me with a rook B3 but then
my central draw back but yeah might I
guess we can maybe do something like
this just to solve the problem of
stopping D4 D5 mean E5 you've got Bishop
F5 this looks like Black's peace
activity it compensates for White's play
in the center in many of these lines
last just to continue Knight E5 let's
just I mean I don't think I'm getting
anything out of this but the Knight on
H5 still feels a little yeah a little
off it off sides if this knife was on
any kind of a normal Square D5 G4 would
win the game but probably but we do have
it on H5 so I'm reluctant I'm reluctant
to suggest it Machin still suggests
playing D4 Bishop F3 G6 but wow I'm I
would be okay I would be hard pressed to
advocate for that Frank like
with the bishop already on G5 doing this
to my I have to imagine I am the trainer
for Peter spittler who's about to play
for the world championship and I said
Peter I want you to pay this position as
black and his firing me on the spot
that's not that's not the scenario yeah
that's not the scenario I had in mind I
was going to say that you know if you if
you if you do this if you do this when
you're 11 you just get kicked out of
whichever school you're ex you never
become a Challenger for for the world
your coach says please take your child
back you you get you get kind of
dishonorably discharged from it's very
surprising that the evaluation just
remains balanced even in this position
right but I think uh it's also it's also
concrete because your queen really
doesn't have a good route into the
attack and uh I still feel the peace
activity over here for black I wouldn't
mind playing the this position with the
black pieces with Rook B8 Rook B2 coming
in uh there's still a lot of lot to play
for to funny I mean it goes to show you
that there are certain positions that we
as humans just will not tolerate we
just if we are to continue if we are to
continue discussing this position I will
I will say that I would definitely think
white is close to winning here in 1995
but by now in 2023 I think most of us
have analyzed positions with computer
assistance enough that we know just how
strong defensive resources are so
honestly I think it's possible to sell
this position to people now it wouldn't
have been possible at all 20 years ago
exactly but now I think you can sell
this by telling them I've checked this
it works if you give this position to 10
juniors in the world I I wouldn't be
surprised if half of them actually
picked this with black they're like we
can defend this position and we give us
two moves C5 C4 coming in I'm a happy
Campa wow too much
talent let's H jum big update coming in
yasa that there is a queen sacrifice on
the board the knights that we were
talking about Lesly so what is happening
here when we left it we saw the position
after Bishop to D6 and shame on us uh
well neov is not in studio
but his Spirit lives on Peter yeah this
is a very very interesting sacrifice and
apparently a correct one as well it
doesn't win but it definitely is very
playable it's buta before we go deep
dive let's just get our head around this
that it's Queen for a knight two minor
pieces ah Queen for two minor pieces
yeah because n was famous for
sacrificing his Queen for two minor
pieces yes but here we're going to pick
the bishop he's going to pick up the
bishop at the moment it's Queen takes
nine which is just for one piece but it
comes back with a check on F5 and picks
up the bishop on D exactly so we get a
pawn and two Min pie Min this is
completely unplayable because this costs
like more pieces so you have to go to G7
Knight takes A5 and now you have to
choose a square and white will take on
D6 with something I think that actually
depends on where the King goes because
if the King goes to h8 I'd be tempted to
take with the Knight even though the
engine disagrees and says after Queen D7
I still have no good followup I was
wondering if with with the F7 Pawn as
vulnerable as it looks maybe it would be
better to take with a knife but it
prefers the bishop capture everywhere
you hit the rook and uh
this I'm seeing I'm seeing your computer
valuation going through the roof
computer seems to think G8 is box or
King G6 is box sorry King G6 are you
getting mated after some yeah what if
what if we go back to uh another normal
looking Square we're we're busted once
again amazing date Six coming in yeah
this is beautiful
and continues being really beautiful
because after everything happens here I
think it
hinges it hinges on this oh with KN of
five coming back in and this is just bad
for black so yeah if you actually have
to play King G6 this is not going to be
uh an easy an easy find for Wesley
because so after King h8 white has got
an advantage after King G8 white has got
an advantage so right now Wesley has to
find the move King G6 which is the most
unnatural move in the position a move
you don't want to play which is walking
up the board walking the plank take us
through the variations Peter KN takes D6
and now I think Knight B5 is findable
what I'm curious about is yeah now I
guess he has a choice because I saw the
engine at first suggested immediately
trying to get rid of that Knight on D6
by attacking with our own Knight but now
it also says and he did play King G6
fantastic fantastic amazing find by
Wesley the only move in the position and
he finds it let's just take a a step
back we've got two miners a bishop and a
knight and a pawn we've we've forced our
King our opponent's king to G6 we've
also split the pawns I think if the H
Pawn was on G7 and we might not be as
but you know you're you enjoy the
initiative Peter you're one of those
Dynamic players that
like from afar you you you you suddenly
spotted that you could play Queen F5 now
you've gotten here in your mind forget
about the computer valuation for a
moment do you go oh this is just too
beautiful I got to go for it I I will be
angry with myself if I a good day yeah
like if if I feel if I feel good about
myself I feel good about how my
calculations are working you nice or or
on that specific day I think I'm going
for this just because of how how fun it
looks my biggest issue here so far is
I'm trying to answer a question for
myself what is my threat here with white
true and I'm a bit struggling because
rookie3 Rook E3 G3 but once again I was
somewhat helped by the fact that the
engine after H5 does play Rook E3
without that I would be like I would ask
myself do I threaten H5 because H5 maybe
forces the king further up the board
but then it will return it doesn't like
I go H5 King takes H5 I have no
immediate follow up do I want to play G4
to play H5 comfortably to reestablish
the F square that would be my choice oh
interesting that would beting but also
kind of slow it doesn't really do
anything immediately yeah you feel a
good reply to F6 yeah you feel like you
need to have something in the immediacy
now I hear you loud and clear in terms
of like what is my threat well I might
be threatening Knight B7 however the
question is what is black going to do
queen D7 Rook d8 that's not scaring me
F7 F6 I'm not even sure that scares me
so I do feel I have time to play Rook E3
Rook e one that is that is a very fair
point yeah and queen D7 I think is a
very important uh topic here because
that's a very natural move it covers the
G4 Square so that g G2 G4 is no longer
playable it maybe creates an idea of
Rook A8 because like it looks a bit
strange just to give up the exchange but
we are so much ahead in material Stakes
that returning One exchange to stop the
attack you can be generous yeah you can
you can actually it 96 is very much part
of the conversation I'm guessing either
Rook e 3 or as we can see on the screen
the engine actually drives the king
further forward and then goes Rook E3
and it becomes very very I want you to
jump in here you see Queen a F5 you see
the outcome here you haven't made a a
firm judgment but you just feel like
this might be the game of your life yeah
to me this is chess uh would I go for it
that's it's such a big question I'm not
sure I think this is what we're seeing
right now from Ali resa is ala at his
best he feels instinctively that this is
a position that's fun I don't think he's
uh thinking so much about the objective
evaluation how much better it is it's
enough to play for it's rapid and he's
gone for it I would uh I like my
material I like my queen would be very
difficult to take this except for one
thing one thing why would I do what Ali
RIS I'm playing my opponent my opponent
in this case is Wesley so Wesley so is
one of those players he has his comfort
zone he's got his four versus four his
three versus three he plays them as well
as anybody in the world you I am not
going to beat Wesley in that situation
I'm going to beat Wesley in a chaotic
crazed material imbalance where the king
is marching up the board that is not a
Wesley so position yeah it's bringing
Wesley out into T's Forest of
complication where the path is narrow
enough for only one of them to get out
and that's exactly what I think Ali Resa
with his form in the tournament so far
with his style of play I think Queen F5
is not surprising when fuja makes this
move see the clock times is being
severely uh in Peru's favor it's five
it's less than six minutes for Wesley to
defend the position that's just starting
to get tricky
way on the board so the idea of stopping
G4 was something that Wesley wanted uh
and it's a move that keeps the balance
by the way also an update this is not
the only big sacrifice what's going on
that we have had what do you have for us
I believe that in the game say it say it
I'm looking for it right now in leang in
Liam's game we have another big moment
D5 what what happened here well when we
left it Anish was playing very nicely
he's got his Knight on C4 his Rook on B1
he's
pressing the B Pawn maybe on a good day
we just go Rook B2 rook and he's just
played Queen F3 and suddenly and very
unexpectedly 95 wow that is a very
beautiful res a beautiful move no why
you guys are amazed I'm I'm confused you
know when we put this position on I'm
not going to lie I thought it was
Black's move next like that's the only s
but then I'm like how did the pawn get
on e4 it's not possible that it's
Black's move next so we're going to take
take and we're presuming that The
Bishop's trapped yeah the the big
question here is what happens after
Knight B6 precisely and I'm threatening
The Rook so yes you can trap my Bishop
but I'll take your Rook so I presum I
wonder if we still have time enough to
play Rook B8 which would be quite
something but I don't see the immediate
reputation for that just sort of
reestablishing the threat of D5 D4 and
saying so you're hitting the bishop and
so yeah you're threatening if you will
D4 but then I'll move my Knight come on
no then you'll play D4 and then you I
will play D4 and then I will take on B6
very very comfortably having diffused
okay I think I'm getting uh D4 ab6 here
ab6 and no G5 I mean even Queen takes C5
I will I will avoid the the like Bishop
F4 allows yeah maybe Rook dc8 here then
would be you know something um Knight D5
what a tactic it's on the board he's
decided to take the night we're going to
see this happen KN by the way did you
see the little twist there at the end
Anish SC just played KN B6 with a little
twist we had the triple twist at the US
championships did you see the triple
triple twist we had
um the uh triple twist while making a
move yeah oh wow we had uh the bad man
the bad man Hans NE H nean was down to
seconds and he made a move and he
twisted it back and he twisted it the
third time and pressed his clock with a
second on his clock against
R it was really the triple twist
somewhat shockingly to me I think I was
introduced to the idea that this is
called the SMI LOF Twist by I think
Martin
Amos I think a in a book by Martin Amos
chess played a small part and the this
particular way of finishing your move
was referred to as a SMI twist and U I
even played against vasil V I I was not
aware that called that so yeah that's a
haven't seen that happen you well I
played vasil a number of games and the
candidates and so on and uh um Vil uh I
always had this idea that the world
champions especially especially the
world champions had a Grace like a Paul
Carz type of uh languishing Grace and
they moved and put their pieces accuracy
accurately on the board Vil's opening
move against me was like D2 D4 and it
was rumbling around and it came to D5
and it landed a little bit off of kilter
to C4 to D4 and I realized that later he
was going blind and he was literally
having a trouble finding the squares for
his pieces cuz he would be fumbling
tumbling like what's going on I would be
adjusting and he thank you thank
you pieces on the squares what's going
on this is a crazy position in me time
yeah 96 was met by r and a very nice
touch here uh we didn't uh discuss the
move C2 C3 here properly okay and it's a
very clever move stopping D5 D4 and sort
of reinforcing the idea that you
eventually will have to take on B6 and
give me The Rook on d8 but but very very
importantly after C3 black very quiet
lost very quietly play Queen C6 saying
and then Knight on B6 isare we're the
only Square for the only square is and
we are also stepping pretty though we're
also stepping away from Bishop B6 taking
attacking both the queen and the and the
Rook so we will play a a B6 next move
and be completely fine apparently
instead of capturing the Knight you're
trapping the Knight that's remarkable C6
really nice by the way as far as a
pattern is concerned if you go back put
the Knight on F4 for just a
moment when I see this position Peter in
my experience the move Knight F4 D5 with
the pawn on C6 I've never seen before I
mean it just you don't get
yeah this is and to even have this
awareness that I could play Knight D5 is
remarkable uh I either he had seen it
before in similar position I I think
this exists in some types of positions
but it's yeah as far as tactics go in
reasonably standard structures this is
very very unusual uh and very good
awareness there by by leang let's go
back to it actually reminds me a little
bit of these English sacrifices on the
D5 Square sometimes you give up a piece
and then you recapture uh when you go
Bishop D5 you take it and then white
wins a piece so because it's trapped
because it's trapped somehow this D5
Square it uh reminds me of that patn wow
but a lot has happened in this one we
will keep an eye out on the Lim game but
I think we have to rush back to this
position the fuja Wesley so we left it
at H5 Peter take it away and after H5
there honestly somewhat surprisingly to
my eyes he went for the for a very kind
of a materialistic approach here he went
Knight B7 Knight C5 which is not
something I would advocate for because
it gives black precisely this move Rook
E8 forcing a pair of Rooks off the board
and my immediate reaction would be we
have done perhaps irreparable harm to
our position because we sacrific so much
material that allowing black to trade
off some of our attacking pieces limit
the material Drive the knight from the6
to much safer for our King Square on C5
at least at first glance right that we
must be in a lot of trouble M but as you
can see the engine disagrees the engine
says the King on G6 is permanently
unsafe we still have very importantly
full control over the one open file on
the board and the S C5 can drop back to
D3 and threaten checks from both E5 and
F4 squares further further down the road
so this is still very very unclear uh
for me the fact that white is playing it
so slowly positionally I'm with you 100%
I thought the move Rook E3 Rook E1 it
was Absolut after H5 I'd almost embraced
the move H5 thank you you're not playing
F6 you're not playing H6 you're not I
want to play Rook E3 to G3 Rook E3 Rook
A1 to E1 inviting everybody to the party
my guess is my guess
is didn't like F6 and after F6 he would
have a very interesting choice because I
think Rook G3 makes an immediate draw
because after fg5 Rook G5 I don't think
Queen takes G5 is a play is playing for
a win and if King H7 Rook H5 let's say
King G6 is just a draw after Rook G5
which becomes a Perpetual or
interestingly you can play Knight E6
Knight E6 Rook
E6 follow it up by bringing the other
Rook over to lifting to E3 giving a
check from G3 and so on and we are
continuing to play for this kind of a
slow positional compensation based very
much on the fact that the a E8 square is
covered by the Knight meaning that we
have absolute full control over the one
open file and that gives us enough play
at least enough play play as you can see
it says uh black can equalize but black
is not better despite despite having a
queen for two light pieces and the move
it's it's even black moves here and it's
still zeros and I suspect it might be
the kind of zeros you prefer with white
exactly I that's the thing when the
engine with when when you have lots of
material and the engine is going Z zeros
it's one way of saying you have to play
accurately to draw you would actually
then prefer the side which has the
material deficit because engines are
materialistic and that's good news for
you but I still feel that the position
that we have the live position that we
have it's not without danger still Yes
you want both Rooks one has been traded
off which is good news for black but it
still goes on and F6 hits the Knight is
something he's got something for us the
first line okay you can find Rook e 7
because F takes G5 knight5 check is very
findable followed by Bishop takes G5 and
you win yeah so Bishop G5 and Rook F7
you put you have to see F7 but it's not
really very difficult ni but after Rook
E7 you spot Knight G7 and now H7 square
is available for the king so fg5 becomes
a massive threat and the engine just
goes bishop5
whoa
because one piece hanging is not going
to be enough this is getting very tricky
for check on ont things and this and
this is where I started giggling I
wonder if we can just take and if this
is maybe a draw yeah this seems to just
be a draw all right we will keep eye out
on this one very spicy stuff going on
but Ray Robson in huge time trouble
against that's not a mediate Fabiano
Carana under 30 seconds look Ray doesn't
feel any pressure under 3
seconds that is true we've seen him make
20 moves was it yesterday with 2 seconds
on the clock and playing it to accuracy
exactly exactly Ray is a remarkable uh
Blitz player sorry pet no I just wanted
to say that compared to some of the
stuff he's already done in this
tournament yes he is very much down on
the clock compared to fa is's very
comfortable 11 minutes but this is just
such a comfortable position for BL so
despite the time deficit it should be
fine for Ray to uh make the required
moves here because not not so many
weaknesses everything under control
pieces nicely placed but big news coming
in from the Anish board as well well
let's go back to our tournament leader
Liam when we left it he had just played
this remarkable Retreat Knight to D5 and
when we got Rook B8 C4 not C3 Queen C6
but after C4 D4 okay that was kind of
what we expected
right and yeah this is all logical but
Queen takes A5 honestly boggles the mind
like why F7 is hanging right is it
possible he didn't realize F7 was
hanging because you never allow Queen
takes F7 it just well you would not
trade such a beautiful Pawn for a lousy
a pawn a Side Pawn for a pawn that def
funds and shields your own King and now
it feels like it's possible what you're
saying because the F the E3 Pawn was on
F2 just a move ago and the file has
opened up and sometimes you get these
your mind shifts it doesn't realize that
suddenly The Rook is in the attack it's
open I think that's just a a huge
mistake blind spot yeah because iook s
is Just Killer it's a killer threat if
you if you add black a Pawn on C6 and
another Pawn on B5 this is probably lost
right and he's only one Pawn up it just
looks lost from absolutely every
direction I really don't understand what
happened there cuz he is just way too
good of a player to to go for this
willingly this has to be a blind spot
this has to be a big miss that the F
Pawn has just opened up and these ghosts
in the mind they happened they've
happened to everyone even the best in
the world and I Want To Praise this move
King to H2 in the midst of attack you
make a quiet move like that just sidest
stepping not only the check on E3 yes
but also the check if the Rook on B1 was
captured exactly I mean you you
desperately want to play Rook F7 and win
the game instantly with Rook F7 then
play King H2 and maybe the move Rook G8
kind of likes you cuz you had prepared
Knight F6 I about to see it forgetting
that you're Queen so the move King H2 is
a beautiful uh preparation for the move
Rook F7 and boy uh for Liam I mean it's
a go feel that for our tournament
leader that was not nice no that wasn't
that wasn't good at all and yeah I have
I have to think this just
was weird moment of CH exactly you can't
you can't go for this willingly no it
just looks horrible I apologize got to
uh I'm going to uh pull in some uh
Capital here NV nepo this is a game that
you know we have two of the greatest
chess players in the world and we' kind
of ignored them
why what's going on in their game uh
Peter uh let's take a look yeah I think
there was the two Pawn sacrif Yan had a
brief moment where he could have gotten
a playable position let's briefly go
through uh through what happened there
uh I I took a look earlier he played uh
ab5 Knight takes B5 on move on move 10
went back to E6 white retreated with his
pieces and in this position I think the
engine slightly disagreed with the
option which I think most of us would
play in an instant the move P B3 which
mvl also chose m there were probably
slightly better moves than this uh and
now after Queen B6 Queen D2 if Yan
played D7 D5 here he would have had it's
still not a good position but using the
fact that for the time being the bishop
pins the pawn on D3 you do get to play
the move D5 D4 ah and that breaks the
white structure open mhm and gives you
some play against the somewhat weakened
white king you get rid of all of your
slightly weak weaker pawns on the queen
side it's still not great but it's
playable and instead Yan uh collected a
pawn he played Knight C5 Queen takes B2
and yes he is now one down instead of
two down but the position becomes very
very ugly and then we've had a lot of
moves since and now we are in an end
game if we get caught up with our live
board a night end game with a still a
pawn deficit for Yan but it's not just
that it's not just the pawn deficit it's
the activity of the king as well
everything it's like these pawns are
beautiful uh White is about to go Knight
to D4 Knight to F5 established uh the
old uh Canard is it true that night
endings resemble or they are the most
the most resembling of of the king and
pawn end and that if you're a pawn up in
a king end King and pawn end game you're
winning you're a pawn up in a night
ending provided it's not three versus
two or two versus one there should be a
win this should be a win with correct
play you Ste I mean Knights are tricky
pieces and in particular if you go down
to very low on the clock you can make
mistakes and of course Yan still feels
like he's he's in the game because you
still require Precision here with white
but you should win this for the
defensive side it's really important to
try and trade off as many pawns as
possible to try to get that draw we will
come back to this and see if uh Maxim is
able to get the job done but let's head
back to our tournament leader because we
could have a big shuffling on our
standings with that win the game yes
then he will actually tie uh
Liam uh and we've just I was about to
say I'm so desperate to play the move
Knight F6 when the queen left this
diagonal but with this last move Queen
takes E3 he did have Queen F4 yeah we
should point that out that Knight F6
would have run into Queen F4 losing that
Knight on F6 I mean at first blush it's
mate uh until you see this uh please
take my Rook by the way please take my
Rook uh Rook F7 on the board and even
though materially speaking uh it's not
that bad for Liam it's actually totally
lost if white gets Knight F6 it's game
over this is finished it resigns on the
spot and Rook F7 renews that threat
because now the Knight on F6 cannot be
captured after
Queen and you think it's going to be a
Perpetual we do have a result by the way
that Jeffrey Jeong against Sam Sean has
finished in a draw but it's all eyes on
this board so Knight of6 you're saying
there was still a threat of pet check
but he stops it anyway he goes Queen to
D3 pinning that Knight on e4 how are you
making progress in this beautiful
looking position Zach I think it's just
completely lost because it's Black's
pieces are going to be so tied up I'm
thinking Rook F3 to G3 and white has to
Pardon Me black has to keep his Queen on
let let's play a move let's do it uh
let's play so Rook F3 Rook F3 uh and um
I put my queen on D4 just to demonstrate
your idea uh why do I need to keep the
queen on the on the diagonal uh Knight
F6 is and queen6 is Checkmate right so
you have to keep your queen on the
diagonal and we get some position let's
just say here
right and now I just have to coordinate
my pieces so let's play Rook G4 I always
like these building you know
solid I I I do nothing and now uh I have
to you want to go Rook H4 and then
you're threatening Rook takes Pawn thank
you you're welcome The Rook H4 would be
and then you're that's what I was
waiting for you're supposed to have my
back I got you did it beautifully on Q
too and the problem is that your queen
is the only Defender and once you leave
the diagonal the KN F6 yes yes it's
busted it's it's it bued I've been
trying I I think the engine might be
defending against these uh these sort of
simplistic threats if if you give this
to to a human player against the engine
with black you probably still win it but
you will encounter more problems than
you would expect because it looks like
black will never make a move yeah and
one thing I noticed which kind of
surprised me but then stopped surprising
me is that the engine very often wins it
by what I think I I haven't really
clicked through enough but I think what
it likes is getting the king over to H5
and then playing G4 and H4 and then
black will never have any perpetuals and
then we can do whatever we please
basically like it completely so you make
a king walk first yeah like you you
drive the queen away from D3 yes and
then at some point you're just bling G3
sort of up up the board to a good
Square provided black cannot play Bishop
f8 at that moment you have to make sure
that you have your all all of your ducks
in a row and once it gets to H5 and then
and then you block it up with your own
pawns black cannot touch it and
eventually you will create one threat
somewhere and that threat will be
winning that's hilarious how easy is
that over the board how easy is it your
move on the board so great idea they
appointed out by you Anish does go for
Rook to F3 so he is rerouting The Rook
to that H file to uh try and deflect the
queen from the diagonal we're seeing
this being played out as we see Rook F3
we get in those cheapos uh we we allow
ourselves to do that as commentators
when the
players make our moves we explain to our
audience these players are really good
they're really good those cheapos that
was a stroke of Genius truly but I
really think this whole maneuver of
transferring a rook from a seemingly
very active spot on the seventh rank to
bring it back and rerouted to the H file
to put pressure on H4 by the way Anish
goes for another idea H4 also just
making sure there's going to be no
Perpetual checks gives your king just an
extra little uh Loof but it does take
take away Rook G4 H4 yeah interesting
this is interesting after Queen B1 I was
almost sure that Anish would go for this
Rook G3 and we just bat ourselves on the
back for this well done but he just
doesn't allow it he goes back to uh com
Cur H4 so he wants to play H5 what
happened this is apparently no longer
winning which is very very striking one
little pawn move disrupt it disrupted
everything I'm guessing we can no longer
run the king up H5 so comfortably uh
yeah this is this is really really
strange because we sort of knew what the
winning plan was but H4 doesn't feel
like a mistake it feels like a move that
might not be the absolute best way to to
to get it to a win but should still
spiling nothing yeah should still win
but apparently it doesn't the only thing
that explains it is the clock Anish gir
down to 5 Seconds now no yes so not
finding the Rook G3 maneuver he plays H4
a big inaccuracy letting go of most of
the advantage
he's coming back and the thing is when
you play Rook F3 Rook F7 Rook F3 you can
feel that something's gone wrong Anish
is feeling the nerves here we're just
seconds on the clock absolutely I well
Maurice actually said it best uh you
know time trouble makes fools of all of
us and you don't know what ghost you
suddenly see as you're about to make a
move you suddenly see something for your
opponent that distracts you Tanya yes
I'm just trying to understand what was
his idea of H4 is he trying to get that
Knight to G5 so that he can take with
the pawn why do you include H4 though
that that's peculiar unless his thinking
was I'll play H5 which secures the
defense of my queen which means I can
move my knight so imagine I'm going to
make a bad move well I'm not going to
make bad moves but I'm just going to
make these moves right so we get
something here and I know this is wrong
but maybe in his mind you got to show it
you know something of this nature so
like the hbond gets transferred to G6
I've still got these checkmating threats
maybe my Rook is on I don't care B7 or
D7 when I'm doing this something like
this is in his pattern is in his mind I
don't he's going to need a lot of
cooperation from Liam for all of that to
happen on the board I am just going to
flash back and forth because I got the
Wesley so game that I'm so anxious to
jump to as uh we've got seconds on the
clock with Anish how is seconds on the
clock for Ali Resa as well so we can
actually take a quick look at that one
yes if you want we can quickly jump I do
want because look at this King Madness
on the board there a king on on F5 Peter
you don't see that every day yeah after
Knight G7 he found a way not to play
Bishop E5 and offer a draw he played
Rook F7 which uh I don't know if that's
great apparently Knight D6 was now
playable with a very good
position yeah okay let me just uh do let
let me take over for just that uh moment
here as for rusia he has gotten this
position and he's driven the black
king and we're up to date we're up to
date
and right now yeah Rook plate and this
now looks very very dangerous for black
because I have three connected four
pawns two minor pieces and four pawns
right Queen
B7 even up material actually right after
check you might have to play Rook takes
H5 because King F7 H6 looks this looks
massiv really really scary H5 H5 on the
board uh Wesley was hoping for some
counterplay with Queen takes King F7 not
sacrificing he's still looking at Rook
F6 you can go Rook h8 as well Rook B
very nice very nice I love that move
because not only does that take away
Queen takes B2 I get out of
tempo seven play played by by Wesley
very you have to assess H6 H7 it does
win I think yeah he plays H6 he does
he's just pushing the pawns is Rook E5
playable trying to give some kind of
peral on the on the have to play Rook E5
whether you like it or not he played
Rook E5 and then you take with the pawn
you take with the queen so your hope is
that you give checks on E1 and
H4 yes check and check that's your M
that's your pardon me your and for a
second there I thought maybe takes takes
Rook f8 check was winning but there is
King G6 there so doesn't do no but that
is winning yes absolutely Rook f8 check
it's on the board by the way all of that
is happening just G4 no n G4 still
allows theet H7 oh no that's Perpetual
Perpetual still Queen H4 is the idea the
peret how do we stop the perpet we can
play King F1 but it looks just so vague
honestly I like King F1 King F1 I'm
king6 KN G he needs to make a move and
he goes 8 s but that's a draw on the
spot he no Wesley Wesley saves it Queen
E1 Queen H4 correct Wesley survives
Wesley Wesley is trying to figure out if
Queen if Queen E3 check wins because
then if the King goes to the H file we
have Queen H6 takes f f but I think but
I don't think it wins so Queen E3 check
we have to play we have to play King F1
but then this is the cold shower right
how many seconds for Wesley he has to
take a decision and he has to do it now
this is the cold shower for white now he
he goes Queeny one he does now it will
be a would have been one of the most
beautiful games and that is it we see
the repetition and the smiles saved by
Wesley Ali Resa with a smile at the end
but what would have been the most
beautiful finish to one of the most
beautiful sacrifices we've seen a queen
sacrifice just at the last moment
somewhere he's not smiling on the inside
Ali Resa right now right somewhere NE
medin off is like these young kids of
today they don't know how the old guys
did I think I think he would have
approved of this game honestly I think
impressive the fa game where are you
Fabiano he's up against Ray they're in a
rook and pun end game but uh Fabby is
enjoying himself he's a pressing but the
engine apparently holds this despite
white being a pawn up and the other one
on C5 also falling but King G4 and Rook
H you have to you have to keep it in in
in in reserve yeah Rook D7 is a very
very strong move there by Ray you have
to force Rook takes C5 and then play
King so there is no Rook G8 check
available to White very nice so yeah Ray
so far playing this end game very very
nicely accurately so the idea is I'm two
pawns down after Rook C5 King G4 but my
counterplay based on Rook check and King
takes G3 is sufficient he incredibly
strong yeah incredibly fast incredibly
strong for uh a draw so this is the
current position uh Fabi Aon up time
what's the clock uh situation against 12
seconds what you mentioned Ray Robson
play playing superb chess with just
seconds on the clock to boot made the
last move with 2
seconds D7 it's infuriating he only has
seconds on his clock and he he's not
collapsing yes exactly he keeps finding
the best moves despite the time troubles
and I think Rook D7 Fabby as well he's
gone into a bit of a think after that
it's been about a minute but it might
not be enough because King G4 is a big
threat if you take on C5 otherwise The
Rook is anyways jumping on to D2 yeah uh
and your king will be for to drive back
otherwise you lose the sewn and uh wow
I've got my eye out on the Anish Liam
game as well because that's our
tournament leader we're talking about
and he's down two Pawns in a queen and
pawn end game and I see that ending and
I think it's that one that John nun says
draw it's the famous One the table base
draw it's crazy but what about the human
base the human base humans lose do you
hold lose it no of course we lose it uh
I just want to say we're seeing
incredible games but we're not getting
results I mean that sacrifice that Ali
that fuan made was fabulous but not
enough seven out of seven so far we have
three games running but seven out of
seven are drawn so far what what drawn
games they're fantastic Peter yeah
they're very good and we can't complain
but the results do matter do matter and
we haven't had a decisive game yet so
far is NBL winning against Neo and that
that was that was a weird one there's
been did take in King G4 King G2 and
they are in the night inning sorry I I
interrupted you yeah mv's game is now uh
equal but uh he was winning three moves
ago maybe four moves ago and he bleeded
out a move which gave away the win but
uh the win wasn't that straightforward
you you you can't blame him too hard for
it but yeah H3 now H3 now makes so he
gets rid of the last Pawn on the board
amazing an extra piece but not enough
material big smiles from nepo as he's
saved to Lost position uh let's just
jump to anisha's game uh ding L ding uh
Liam uh apologies ding's replacement
ding replacement thank you that's what I
meant to say King H3 okay we know in our
minds that this is a table based draw
but nobody's drawing this right I think
people have drawn this but um you you
lose it more often than not with 30
seconds on the clock it's not going to
be easy you have to make sure that you
don't put your queen on the wrong Square
where you going to a King Pawn ending
with a check
arees I I think whatever table base
might say this is such a difficult hold
and if Liam does it it's just going to
be super impressive yeah I mean think
miracle I mean my goodness this is a
very good sign by the way because he's
allowing que6 check which means that
he's correctly estimated that this Pawn
ending is not winning and it's very
important because once you start being
worried about those Queen trades you
limit the options uh that you have and
yeah if he is confident that he's not
losing that pawn ending it means that he
is
pretty pretty much in control of what's
happening on the board by the way is
King H6 here no he did play Queen E3
check I was wondering if uh King H6
would have made a a comfortable draw
Queen mate would have been a good though
yeah sorry mate thank you you see how
how easy it is for the human to lose
King to G3 AB yeah Queen E5 and I think
Anish wants to play Queen F4 Queen I
think that pawn that PA is winning yeah
think we can play because Queen takes H5
Queen H4 is winning as far as I can
Queen H4 yeah yeah so we play queen4 and
we ask the question please take my pawn
and the whole idea is that when you go
into a King Pawn ending you want to
calculate who has the opposition of the
king and if black is able to get that in
a good moment then you can be down upon
and hold it but in this case if the
Queens get traded off you get King H6
yes you get the opposition PA on G3 this
is a draw but with a Pawn on G2 is
showing yeah that's it that's the
opposition now the black king has to
make room for the white king to move up
the board opposition that was why he did
not capture the pawn in fact after Queen
F4 he played Queen E6 well he's doing
everything right so far so Liam playing
it really well but he needs to keep this
up and Anish is going to play this till
the very end of course there's no
question of that so Liam will really
have to earn this half point in the
meantime Ray is very comfortably holding
his position against against fabis so
no real reason for us to switch back to
that and now Anish is also under a
minute on the clock King H2 Queen
D5 um when do you start pushing the G
Pawn now now it's time like it's time
you put your Pawn on G4 you put your
queen on F3 you put your King on H3 and
then you hope that Queen F5 check will
be a winning threat so you go G4 and
he's thinking about it yes is he going
to do it he's reaching for the king no
he doesn't he doesn't want I think he
wants to go King G1 and then Queen Queen
H2 but that might not actually win that
might be a bit too fanciful yeah yeah we
already had this Liam already played
Queen E6 here which is a good move so it
will not be and we do have a draw Ray
saves Ray's got some Smiles uh he and
Wesley uh from the earlier round were
sharing their happiness nine out of nine
so far not nine out of nine draws so far
it's uh incredible but the chess has
been very different from the results
that we've had absolutely for me that
Ali RZA game I think for me has been the
game of the tournament so far agreed
absolutely stop stop right there I mean
sometimes you have a a tournaments that
seem like everybody's playing a
Catalan there and berlins and we're
seeing so many draws and not big fights
but that one between Wesley and Ali in
the meantime I'm I'm keeping an eye on
the table base here and the the options
are Contracting uh black is still
there's seven moves here which make a
draw but considering how many there are
at some point I think pretty much every
legal move was making a draw this is no
longer true you can definitely see black
misplaying this the path is getting
narrower P to hold this position and
that's what very often happens uh in
these kind of end games qu1 is fine qu1
is definitely not a mistake not a
certainty behind that that H uh Victor
kcho had a line he said with Trembling
Hands we play the move Queen D1 and you
mentioned that only seven moves hold for
black in a certain position there will
be a moment where Liam will have to find
the most accurate move and with seconds
on the clock that's where humans slip
Queen d8 I think or queen yeah Queen G7
is also completely fine just restricting
the path forward for for the white king
and I think Anish will probably it's 20
moves since the last pawn move by the
way since H5 was played and I think
relevantly Anish is now down on uh on
the clock consistently below what Liam
has really 8 against 34 currently well
move King F5 is an indication he's
probably going to pick up like a minute
very quickly after a series of checks
what's yes are we going to see a
decisive result I if Liam hold really
you just have to tip your hat and say
there's this miracle on the chessboard
because it's so incredibly difficult uh
when you're under pressure constantly
every every move and you feel like your
life hangs in the balance with each move
you it's it's impossible to keep calm
under the under that duress and it's
impressive to see him do just that he's
playing confidently he's picked up the
seconds on the clock as well with the
last few I think he can claim yeah I
think he's doing the right thing here
he's claiming and he said with the move
Queen C3 no I think it's Queen E6
specifically I think it's Queen E6 and
Anish cannot be happy right now oh if I
if this claim is accurate and we'll ask
our production as well if that's
accurate
that would be I think I think it is
we're getting a confirmation wow it's
the correct claim which amazing and this
this continues the story of Anish not
winning very very good positions he's
had a bunch of them yesterday and today
again he uh hold on he
said Queen D5 is a three-time repe queen
it's Queen E6 if he's claiming Queen D5
I think that might not be correct yeah I
see the queen on D5 too so Queen so
you're saying queen queen
E6 yeah I was pretty sure it was Queen
E6 holy smokes I don't think I've seen
that kind of a repetition unbelievable
so Liam claims correctly but with the
wrong move so he's not going to be
awarded and he's smiling right now does
he realize that he's claim with the
wrong being he's being told that and you
are not you cannot adjust your claim to
the cor and for those who are new to the
game I think we should explain this I
really meant to say was Queen E6 you
didn't let me write down my move I
misspoke wait is that or did he claim
Queen D5 or did he claim Queen E6 okay
well let's see and look at an he's
actually thinking about the position
right now acius leang the deputy Arbiter
from Singapore Chris bird our chief
Arbiter are showing the oh my it was
this position right here where uh Liam
sto the clock and yes I think for those
who are new to chess we should explain
what really is going on here the
three-fold repetition a player is
allowed to claim a position but he has
to speak the move that he intended to
play that's right that this is the
position that's occurred twice and a
draw is awarded exactly now according to
what we're seeing the queen move to E6
would be a correct three move repetition
we so the idea is if Liam had said I'm
intending Queen e and we've reached this
position this precise position twice
before this is the third time his claim
would have been upheld yes what he did
it appears to our eyes is he said this
is a three-time repetition and I'm
playing Queen to D5 and the Arbiter
rejects the claim because Queen to D5 is
the wrong move for the three-fold
repetition and he gets a Time penalty as
well which means Anish gets an
additional minute on the clock minute
that's
correct
and let's go back to that moment when
Liam stopped the clock after the move
Queen F4 Liam says I'm about to make a
claim of a three-time repetition and he
correctly pauses the clock before making
the move correct because according to
the rules you pause the clock and you
speak out the move you intend to make
and this is what happens so he stops the
clock and oh any points
where it looked like D5 but then it was
some hesitation it was and he he says D5
he clearly points at D5 that's right the
Arbiter comes in puts the queen on D5 as
the intended move right I think there
was a little confusion by Liam there he
wasn't sure as well exactly now where is
that three time I have never seen a
three-time repetition claim like this
and it continues valid Peter but it was
the wrong move yeah this is this is a
first for me as well and what I I I
badly want I I badly want to make a
cricket ology and I'm can't find it I I
actually started looking at my phone
just not to talk about Cricket here but
but yeah I don't know how long I can
okay so a faulty claim means that aniri
gets an extra minute added to his clock
thank you very much for that Liam and
the game flares a new and now in a sense
Anish has been alerted he's been alerted
and there's also so much psychology at
play right now for Liam because
undoubtedly he felt that this is a
position that's come twice in the game
but it was the wrong Square he was right
about the feeling but wrong about the
square he chose and there are only only
four moves here which draw by the way
the b gets narrower and this is one of
them Queen E3 is okay oh my gosh after
what we just saw Yes I'm going to be
heartbroken if this actually ends badly
for Liam well now with a check Queen F5
check we force the king away from H7 and
that gets rid of all of those positions
that might have been a three time rep I
think the line we want to show first is
Queen G6 Check Yes King h8 H6 okay and
it might have been winning if not for
the fact that you can start playing
Queen H3 chicken response right exactly
nice so here Black's King is in a
stalemate so if I didn't have my queen
please take my queen the game would be
drawn and if you refuse to take my queen
I insist that you take my queen and
continue insisting yeah I continue
insisting and I can put my queen on all
kinds of double protected squares it's
called The Mad Queen when we get into
those situations that did not happen by
the way both players certainly aware of
that uh Theory we did see Queen F5 check
King G7 yeah still the Narrow Path he is
he is continuing to play incredibly well
and uh this is still a draw but you can
see how tricky it is now that he's
missed an opportunity to actually end
the game on the spot by the by claiming
correctly uh the three-fold by the way
just allowed King H7 did an Niche
already I mean my Spidey Sense would be
tingling like wait a minute oh oh now
we've got the now we've got the St mate
yeah and he wants he wants to play H6
next move here this is very clever Bish
he wants to uh he is creating this
threat of H6 Queen takes H6 Queen H3 so
if we put our queen I'm trying to find a
terrible Square I think I found one
Queen A7 H6 now and then we want to play
Queen G7 check next move and win and win
Pawn endings are just winning you get
the H Pawn but you lose the end game
yeah exactly I've got the G2 Pawn which
I can use as finding a good Square here
on 13 seconds is not going to be very
and the good squares do they include the
square E6 E6 is fine E6 is fine he's
playing I'm I'm very very impressed by
how is defending yes I'm how do you with
with 10 seconds a move how do you
consistently find the Narrow Path Queen
C7 time and it all could have been over
it all could have been done with the
draw could have been achieved if you had
just chosen the right Square for your
intended move Liam exactly Queen F5 on
the board now uh I'm kind of surprised
we haven't seen G4 with the queen on
F3 and just get the you know yeah he he
had options he definitely had a moment
where he could have played G4 without
allowing in the media Perpetual more
than once maybe even but he's choosing
to keep this in in his back
down to single figure seconds of course
he will make a move but both players and
he got an additional minute as well so
he's back to his seconds and just
another update that it is now been 32
moves since the last Bond move was made
so the 50 move rule I wonder I wonder if
Liam is also aware of that because maybe
they didn't let him scroll high high
enough to actually Che okay fin finally
we have G it resets it res resets no
longer relevant do we play King H6 here
and just take on H5 next move by the way
that's what I wanted to ask I mean I I I
I would have been more tempted tempted
by King H3 to keep the pawn on G2 sorry
you know yes I think the reason we saw
G3 is one because it would have been a
draw apparently because King H3 would be
a three-fold repetition oh being told
and also I think it's in anisha's mind
the 50 move rule that at some point he
needs to push the reset by the way this
last move King H6 I think it does set up
for que we take on H5 now take take on
H5 quite safely this is no longer
difficult because there's no opposition
to be one and he's going for it and he
does it now I think we can say a defense
by Liam amazing and look at that he oh
he did he didn't offer he offered him a
draw I think I okay I had enough I offer
a draw and Liam said I can't
accept this is this is fantastic
tenacity by uh by the coach wow and that
means 10 draws so far today but what a
round we've had Ali rza's Queen
sacrifice Liam's a wrong claim with a
wrong queen move and eventually holding
this exceptionally difficult end game
amazing great stuff guys I mean it
hasn't effect our standings one iota I
mean nothing changed since they started
to play today but what games we've been
treated
to oh shall we have uh the worst
handshake in the
here it comes okay I trade the Queens
play play play take my Pawn play play
okay I'll take your P now can we shake
hands the worst handshake
ever that's not oh come on come on oh
that game deserves a high five let Al on
a handshake exactly what a performance
by both these players an Nish pushing as
well but Liam incredible incredible
defense there no I don't know what's
more impressive Peter ala's Queen
sacrifice or Liam's hold I think I'm
still taking the queen sack but yeah I
people people lose these Queen endings
every day it's I think and they're
supposed to lose them
routinely not supposed to put up that
kind of resistance on 10 seconds as well
he made a number of very difficult
decisions and honestly once he claimed I
was so sure he will claim correctly as
well this really is a first for me I
I've not seen the the claim was correct
the square was the wrong move that's
that's a very unusual occurrence for
sure yeah because of course we have our
score sheets where we see from our score
sheets that you know Queen E6 is the one
that's been played twice before let's
take a look at our standings which again
have not changed since round three round
that was yes just unbelievable drama
start to finish there Liam keeps his
lead after surviving a very difficult
two-on down Queen end game Ali Resa fuja
with a fantastic game but couldn't
convert it to a full point what could
have been the game of the year for Ali
Resa had he won it at the end so close
yet so far Shar second place with Ray
Robson and then we've got three players
at Five Points including uh Maxim an
Anish and for Fabby he's kind of feeling
like well that was two pwns up against
Ray Yan still needs F but if I'm in
Wesley shoes I'm feeling really good
like this kind of put some wind in my
CES I've I've made a draw from a very
difficult position yeah I and it's time
to to make a win we're going to go on
break but as we go on break we want to
tell you that Anastasia caught up with
uh Sam Sean hope you enjoy the
[Music]
interview so Sam welcome to St Louis
it's uh actually your first event in gr
chur if I'm not mistaken it's the first
time you were taking part in s St Louis
rapid and Blitz uh are you looking
forward to this event yeah definitely
I'm very excited to debut in the grand
Chester it's b t I've been watching
since I was a kid and I'm very excited
to be part of it uh this one is a very
exciting event actually I was thinking
what was the first ever GCT event you
have watched and um which one is the
most memorable for you um I mean I I've
been watching since the singfield cups
began I think in 2013 exactly and
probably the most memorable one is
definitely the one where probably
started 7
and0 I'm not sure that was a GCT event
but it was a singfield cup yeah it was
singfield cup and let's say the seven
out of seven I mean did make a huge
impression on you how old were you I was
probably 12 or 13 at the time it was
pretty incredible to see someone at the
top be able to beat so many high level
players in a row game after a game so
that's probably the one most memorable
one yeah I actually you were here just
not long time ago and you won 9lx
tournament I mean congratulations on
this Victory and I was wondering um do
you feel more confident after you know
winning this event especially now that
you will play with many players from
that one uh yeah thank you I mean it was
definitely a big achievement for me
winning this tournament and it
definitely gives confidence to you know
be able to win a tournament with so many
elite players I think I have gain
confidence and I'm playing better
against them yeah just a few days ago
you actually took part in a grand Swiss
event in I of men and um I I was
wondering how do you assess the your
participation there and of course
everybody saw the game you be where you
beat lza fua was nice game and so how
can you assess your participation there
uh I overall it was good um I had some
serious chances of getting the top two
spots and I had like two really tough
losses in both scenarios so uh it was
kind of a sour taste at the end but
overall I think yeah I had some good
wins one of them fuia it was decent
tourament overall do you think you will
try to get the Revenge right now are
looking forward to play against him in
this tournament yeah uh I mean playing
him I me he's very good at fast chess
speed chess so it'll be exciting to play
him in a different format as well whom
else are you looking forward to play
against in this event and C Louis R I
think I've played most of the players in
this field but probably NPO the least so
that would be a very interesting match
up MH uh how do you actually deal with
those fears you know playing against uh
you know higher rated players top rated
players in the world you know how do you
deal with that yeah well I mean the fear
was definitely a long time ago when I
was probably 14 15 I think just playing
them over and over again helps you get
over the fear and at this point it's
just I'm just playing and with healthy
respect but I know I can definitely beat
them yeah you were one of the students
of this program from Kasparov chess
foundation for young talents uh what
impact on your chest it had and um how
how did it feel actually to work with
Gary casparo himself uh I do think the
Casper shash had a huge impact on me I
was 101 when I joined it and just
analyzing with Gary was really helpful
for me I always tried to you know get
into his brain try to see how he thinks
about the game and I think that was like
a 3 four year period which really helped
me a lot yeah uh that's great and what
actually my last question is what are
your short-term goals and long-term
goals goals you I know that you're
professional chess player so how is it
to be the
one uh short-term goals I mean well we
just had two very serious tournaments
the US championship and Grand Swiss so
there's nothing uh as serious as that in
the short term but I'm just looking to
do well in this tournament I think it's
a fun tournament a good opportunity yeah
but let's say what what what do you
think you can reach uh which levels uh
in the Chess World let's say maybe 2,800
do you think is one of the goals of
course yeah I definitely have the the
highest goals possible I mean that's why
I started playing chess when I was six 5
years old and I still have that goal
today do you enjoy playing chess and
studying yeah yeah I enjoy playing chess
maybe not so much uh some years ago but
now that it's only chess I mean it's all
I
do I definitely enjoy playing that's
great all the best of luck for you thank
you the 2023 Grand chess tour reaches
its epic conclusion with its fifth world
class event the 2023 sinkfield cup it's
back to classical chess with Front
Runners settling in for the final push
to the Finish Line however two of
America's Finest stand in their way
joining the frey as wild cards who will
try to cash in on the opportunity while
making things as difficult as possible
for hopeful tour players who can win the
illustrious cop and will it be enough
for them to emerge as the 2023 Grand
chess tour Champion follow the St Louis
chess club's twitch and YouTube channels
to tune in to live coverage of the 2023
sinkfield cup November 21st to December
for first to find
out hello I'm women's Grand Master Bim
TOA I will be creating content for Grand
chest stour follow us on social media
and catch more behind the SS
content the St Louis chess club is the
Premier chess facility in the United
States we bring the educational benefits
of Chess to thousands of students across
the St Louis area we also promote Chess
at the highest levels hosting all levels
of the US championships as well as
high-profile tournaments that attract
the world's best players become a member
and enjoy perks such as free classes and
lectures weekly tournaments and so much
more visit St Louis chess club.org to
claim your membership
today the World Chess Hall of Fame
located in the heart of St Louis's
historic Central West End want to know
why chess has intrigued people around
the world for nearly 1,500 years stop by
and learn about the impact of Chess from
our three floors showcasing the art
culture and history of the game the
World Chess Hall of Fame has something
for everyone to enjoy for more
information on current exhibits please
visit World Chess h.org
St Louis the chess capital of the United
States it also plays host to an
award-winning shop dedicated to chess
merchandise All Occasion gifts and
plenty more at Q Boutique you can shop
both in store and online from quirky
greeting cards to luxury chest sets
there is something for everyone at Q
Boutique enjoy a shopping experience
like no other make sure to check out Q
Boutique stl.com for a wide variety of
gifts for everyone to enjoy the St Louis
chess club Scholastic program brings the
educational value of Chess to kids and
schools across the St Louis area active
in over 100 schools throughout the St
Louis city and County the St Louis chess
club has been able to reach over 85,000
students in both in school and after
school programs we view chess as a
valuable educational tool learn more
about our Scholastic programming by
visiting St Louis chess club.org
education hello I'm women's
[Music]
girl welcome back everyone what a
dramatic finish we had in round still
recovering and I think that's going to
take a while and I think we can expect
more of that going into this final round
of the day y so let's take a look at
what the players stand yes indeed uh no
changes at the top or the bottom because
we've had 10 draws today exactly two
rounds all the games finished in draw
but dramatic dramatic chest there Liam
Le still at the top of the table after a
fantastic hold against uh Anish Ali Resa
what a game he played perhaps could be
one of the best games and I'd love to
know in his interview later if he
considers this one of his best games
maybe a revolutionary idea let's
introduce a standing game into chess if
they if they make like 10 draws in a row
they all play standing up and if you win
a game you can sit down right and the
pairings for this the final round of the
day let's take a look some big big
matchups coming up with the tournament
leader Liam Le facing off Fabiano Carana
very important game absolutely for both
these players Faby needs to start
climbing up the rankings but Liam is in
such great form the two players are tied
for first tied for second I apologize
and they're facing up yes it's Ray
Robson against alira fuja again
exceptional form by both these players
so we can expect some fireworks in that
one that will be a Marky match up Sam
seon versus Anish Gary Jeffrey Jang
versus Yan and Wesley so versus mvl
where would you like to take us Tanya I
really want to start with the tournament
leader let's do it Liam against Fabi
Carana it's a Queen's Gambit declined
let's take it from the top we're we're
getting a move that I have to give
Magnus credit Magnus Carlson credit for
when he played A7 A6 I thought this was
a oneoff twoof type of thing but then
when he started playing it consistently
Peter I had to look deeper and I have to
tell you with a white players are
struggling trying to find an advantage
against A7 A6 it is very sturdy and it
really feels like it shouldn't be
honestly it feels a bit unfair that you
can even do that these days and and
still not really be much if if it all
wars out of the opening but it's it's
very well established that there is no
reputation and what you can get is sort
of what Liam here got against Faby which
is a pleasant little position and your
advantage is mostly based on the fact
that the bishop on the6 is me me whereas
the bishop on D3 is a very very nice
piece and uh you see white very much
inviting black to take on F4 you know
quote unquote spoil our structure but
this actually improves White's chances
greatly because now E5 square is very
available for the Knight and you can
also go for Pawn storms on the king side
so I'm not sure if Faby is even
considering taking on F4 here I'm sure
he's not in fact uh you could maybe
think of playing Knight C8 and then
taking and immediately putting the
Knight on D6 let's let me illustrate
what I mean like if you if we just just
make some kind of a indifferent move
here like Rook C1 and we take on F4 take
on F4 and immediately play Knight D6
with the intention of playing Bishop F5
next because if I do get to trade the
bishop on E6 for the bishop on D3 then
many things become tolerable but I'd be
very worried about either Rook E5 or
maybe even G2 G4 here stopping Bishop F5
and this is a very committal decision by
Fabby uh and yeah he is continuing to
make waiting moves for now H6 Rook ad d8
maybe coming next you still pick white
here because structurally it's a it's a
pleasant Carl's bad but right nothing
dramatic it just looks perfectly normal
just before we move on from this game
and I we're very quickly going to go to
alira I think the point of 4 A6 is also
really interesting and if we just back
up and show why A6 actually helps black
in getting that light squat Bishop to E6
is because if white makes a normal move
like a development of the bishop the
move A6 actually threatens to capture on
C4 and defend the pawn with B5
so it forces White's hand in the center
so after the trade on D5 it gives black
the additional opportunity to develop
the Bishop from C8 to E6 which is where
you want your Queen's Gambit declined
bishop and uh we see the game continuing
with that uh placement in the opening
yasa good time to go ahead to the fight
for the second place currently between R
Robson and Ali Resa and uh
surprisingly um we talked about the
king's Indian defense because the king's
Indian defense is one of those romantic
modern defenses that the computers hate
like you put the Kings indan defense
into modern computer and it's coming out
plus one plus 1.5 and you this is like
too big an advantage uh to give up to
your opponent And yet when the king's
Indian defense is played it's sort of
like yeah the human Spirit overcomes you
know the AI the commentators love it the
fans love it and Ali Rea loves it seen
him play the Kings Indians so many times
and it just shows the kind of mood that
he is in he's coming in for a fight
exactly now Ry also with the move H2 H3
like in my repertoire against the um
Kings Indian I favored the aox system
which was Bishop E2 and Bishop G5 and I
absolutely love the sameish as well
that's mine that's that's is a beautiful
line against the Kings inun well I'm so
happy Tanya congratulations I mean did
you you came to that on your own accord
or who influenced you to go in the
sameish I I have played the samish for
about 10 years now and I just think I've
had really great results I enjoy the
positions that come out of it I don't
think Kings Indian players get the kind
of uh kingside attack and flow that they
really want and that you want to avoid
with white so I'm kind of loving the
whole samish situation exactly but
regardless of how white responds in the
Kings Indian we are headed towards quite
a dynamic opening uh middle game exactly
but in this particular case instead of
the Pawn on F3 we have the pawn on H3
and Ray kind of threw down the move D5
Knight E5 F4 and this is about the most
consequent way that white can play Peter
I wanted to step in and I i' waved to my
colleagues there that I I need a little
time on my phone because I before this
round started there is also another
important chess event going on right now
and that's the European teams in which
Magnus is playing and Magnus today was
black against Stan shito who uh famously
was a giant killer in the World Cup
knocking Sam shankland out in the first
round and I had a feeling I've seen this
today and in fact yes H3 Bishop B3 was
the choice by by Ian shito in that game
Knight C6 was played by Magnus and after
D5 Magnus actually chose Knight B4 I had
a feeling Knight B4 yeah he went 94 and
then back to yeah the board is back to
not allowing me to make moves but trust
me he played Knight B4 in that position
not Knight E5 and my question is D5
Knight B4 Peter and my goodness what I
want to say is that game started at
about maybe I want to say 10 11 a.m.
here uh hours before and I mean I would
assume ala fua is about as compulsive
Watcher of life life chess as most top
professionals are yeah so I wouldn't R
out him knowing that Magus played this
today and maybe he even checked it a
little bit and came to the conclusion
that 95 is a better option interesting
wow it could be the case because they're
following all the top level events so
when I think about today's modern chess
players and I thinking that they're
having not one but possibly two and even
more coaches yeah everybody's on the
look out and it's sort of like you wake
up in the morning somebody's prepared
you a file that says you got to look at
this today you know this first thing
that you have to do is double check this
line because Magnus just played it it's
hot and if you don't play it someone
else will play Novelties and new moves
need to be employed as quickly as
possible and a yes we were talking about
the samish right the kind of development
that we're seeing it does arise in some
of the lines in the samish as well where
black does go Knight C6 Knight E5 and
you push the F4 Pawn Knight coming to E2
and not the F3 Square the bishop
developing to E3 so we might be seeing
some ideas into mix yeah the the the
players do make that uh cross
pollination if you will but this move C6
KN E2 uh Peter I wanted to throw this
over to you if white you know just
throws out the gauntlet this is the
correct approach here and uh it's it's
also the top move I think in practice
this is still not novelty there are some
uh some decent games here you see uh
Matias blue bom playing this on the
white side G4 makes a ton of sense
because you need to be prepared for the
attack against your Center so it's very
important it looks very natural to put
your knight on D4 here but that would
allow the Black Knight to come to C5 you
very much want to be able to take that
Knight once it appears there and play E5
so G4 works very well in retrospect this
position is I think more or less please
come on
please no uh trust me
dc5 we trust you we have to trust you
yeah and uh and now it makes the move
dc5 we play E5 we drive the Knight away
we play Bishop G2 and we have full
control full control in the center
so the one thing you would have to be
somewhat I no longer want this computer
please stop making those moves the one
thing to be mindful of is some kind of
counterplay like uh you can also click
maybe on the yeah like that
B5 I will eventually I think actually if
if I step away and pretend like I'm no
longer interested it will play B5 on
itself you have an an electri mag there
we go thank you
electromagnetism going on with your hand
and the Tomy mat that you're on you were
about to say B5 and your Center's
collapsing no not really no the engine
uh keeps things together you can play
Knight D4 meid before before with Knight
C6 it works out but you do have to be
very very precise and obviously the
stakes rise very very seriously if you
allow all of this because you are so far
severely underdeveloped you would have
to say you also opened up your King's
side you played you4 with the King back
on one you still are two moves away from
castling so this is a very very
committal decision by white if if you
are by the way you do have G4 on the
board it's on the board this is going to
get spicy very quickly and uh your
opponent plays on the flank you want to
try and play in the center of the board
try and open up and by the way we've got
two players who are not backing down uh
from what we've seen from Fu's two games
that he played earlier against Jan and
against Wesley uh they're going to
embrace this position
um what is the theoretically recommended
move Peter against G4 I mean what does
fua have to do takes D5 actually black
is doing completely fine here it seems
like uh Queen A5 Queen A5 is also
playable I'm assuming with the intention
of meeting Bishop G2 with something
concrete perhaps uh cd5 and now B5 or
maybe Knight C5 although Knight C5 seems
a bit slow uh I mean if if I'm white and
if I can get in the move castling and
you've let we very happy here very very
happy here very happy campers Knight B6
might be playable as I can see on my
screen because right we are still a
couple of moves away from completely
stabilizing and after if we play B2 B3
the pawn the Knight on C3 is vulnerable
to tactics like this one like we can
take we can take any of Pawns and Bishop
takes C3 check we do have a decision we
do cd5 ala and I think that is the most
human approach as well undoubtedly Ali
Resa has uh ideas of what he's doing he
has so much experience in the Kings
Indian but traditional chess wisdom
right your opponent overe expands on the
flank you want to create more play and
not uh block the center try to attack in
the center and now I think even ideas of
the Knight jumping into B6 and to C4 are
always in the air something we have cd5
cd5 on the board and what you're saying
Tanya is a knight B6 with the idea of
maybe Knight C4 and also perhaps trying
to play E6 and then recapture with is
what you really want when you want to
open up the center E6 is a move that
you're really looking at and the reason
we're not suggesting it in the current
position is that why just goes D6 I can
show it on this board which you can just
take take eventually take somebody
grabbed the pawn it's so so happy it's
coming up Queen takes Pawn so
enthusiastic yes okay very very very
nice uh as we get our sixth and final
way final round
uh underway let's just go around the
tables and take a look at the game
between Wesley so and mvl because so
glad you chose that one I you read my
mind it's so wonderful when you do have
a player like mvl who's true to his word
he is going to live and die on the
nidorf Sicilian and he says to his
opponents look you go ahead and prepare
yourselves as best you can and I'm going
to play the night or
and it's nice to see this Fisher San no
we're going to call it the Bobby Fisher
attack uh for white and let's get up to
date with the position because this is
double edged night takes a for Bishop
takes is very double-edged and the
engine suggest suggests that the very
reasonably natural move 96 is according
to the engine a bad mistake even a bad
mistake pretty bad mistake yeah which is
very very uh surprising to me because it
looks normal but I guess it just doesn't
work out move by move I would assume
because I have to take yeah I assume
Wesley plans to recapture with Czech and
then go Bishop I would say E3 not to D2
but to E3 because I think I need to
control the C5 Square because just to
illustrate my point I don't know if it's
the correct point if you go Bishop D2
here I would like to play Rook C3 okay
and follow it up with Knight C5 you take
with the bishop Knight I go Knight C5
and then this is I think you kind of
have to play Bishop D5 I would to say
beauti G A Beautiful Exchange sacrifice
my king is stranded in the center and I
obviously with your King on B1 I would
be lost right if you already had the
long Castle played and you could play
King C1 B1 here I would be in probably
irreparable trouble but but with the
stuck in the center I like this for
black I think this is very Bishop F4
Queen H4 and it's so easy to play the
Black side uh so maybe bishop E3 I
thought okay with the idea I I
understand I will have to take take with
the pawn on C3 but I think stopping
Knight C5 is a more relevant detail here
okay but judging by what the engine
suggests the evaluation is I would say
something here doesn't quite work out
Knight E6 F6 so Bishop B6 King h8 Bishop
B3 and apparently you can take on G5 I
which is a bit surprising say you're
hanging D7 right yeah exactly let's
check so we take take we take on D7 I
guess we start by Queen H4 check King
has to go to D1 we go Rook
F2
and yeah you kind of sense a little
compensation but you're not certain
what's happening for Queen G4 your idea
is to go Queen at6 We Still we still
have a bishop on D7 this is the no I
mean like white white go Queen like and
maybe Queen 86 is the problem here
because it's start
threatening I like that reminding you
that the bishop protects G MC Queen I
apologize it's okay no no you were
brilliant Peter you were your best loved
it
yeah you you can sense another round of
apology uh but this is bad apparently
Queen D3 is a bit stronger I guess but
for some reason the engine suggests
after Rook d8 the threats which I can't
even name honestly to me it's not
obvious what the threats are but they
are strong enough that the engine was
suggesting just playing B3 Rook takes D7
King C1 and running so I'm seeing the
minus two by the way on your obviously
if Bishop is it the comp of the because
now can we try Bishop takes D7 in this
moment we just go Bop H check and take7
that doesn't work that doesn't work at
all so I guess maybe the best case the
best case for white is just to Castle
and admet that we are Pawn down but
we'll have some compensation but knowing
Maxim this position he doesn't even
blink and takes on C3 yeah take on
C3 but hold on I just want to say I'm
wesle so and wesle so is incredibly
well-prepared player he may denigrate
himself and say you know like these
these players they study so much and I'm
not so good and all but he's very very
well prepared he doesn't play the Fisher
attack in order to sacrifice a pawn and
get a worse position we never call it
the San do we no never never uh and why
would he do that why would he because 96
fe6 it's not like uh um Maxine is
Reinventing the automobile here
I
think he didn't really realize he has
other options and the engine suggests
you can just play H4 the engine suggests
keeping the pawn on G5 Alive by force is
much more important than E4 Knight D5
with a very with a very unclear position
yeah Knight D5 even though honestly like
even this looks like it might on a bad
day just completely collapse after
Knight C5 creating a threat of D4 D3 and
you have to be very sure this is good I
I honestly I don't don't know why the
engine likes it so much by the way it's
a delayed delivery mhm I I noticed that
you make a move and 12 seconds later
when it feels like it it'll play the mov
you want it's like some Twisted
anti-cheating measure by the computer
12C deer I think he just wants to show
me who BST I will I will make you move
but don't think I will make you not on
your spe
my right I love it Peter with a computer
with its own mind it's it's nice
nice and how do they match head head
let's take a look yeah so uh Wesley so
against Maxim bashra as expected played
each other a bunch of times another one
of those epic rivalries of CH and it is
18 wins in favor of Wesley to 16 losses
look at that 43 draws 43 draws I'm
telling you you could write a Trilogy on
those games alone but does not surprise
you Max seem such a speach CH specialist
the 2021 World Blitz champion and he's
the one who's trailing Wesley on that
score in Rapid I'm telling you Wesley is
so underrated what he does in Rapid and
Blitz I and we talked about a golden
period there for him maybe 2016 through
2019 where he was in the top three maybe
top two in the world and seemingly
untouchable when he's in form well all
of these guys I I mean that's unfair any
of these guys are are in form you
sometimes feel Peter like these guys
just see everything it it's like they're
monsters absolutely yeah on that note
Rook takes Knight has been played The
Exchange sacrifice is on the board
because white hasn't sto this is a
mistake by the way and this is exactly
the line that we were showing earlier
and Bishop takes C3 is actually worse
than Bak C3 the engine was suggesting
despite you seemingly having played Play
Bishop G2 to take with the bishop you
still should be taking with the pawn
regardless yeah and this is and allowing
Knight C5 yeah because I think it
actually wants to be able to Castle
Queen side more than anything else in in
these types of positions and now he will
not be able to so B takes C3 Knight C it
goes Bishop D5 allows you to take on G5
but compare it with the other position
you can immediately Castle along and it
looks scary but it looks scary and
Bishop C3 is just such a natural
response
looks very very scary it does right you
really want your Bishop recapturing
which is what Wesley did and Maxim there
he captures G5 Pawn not rushing with
Knight C5 and before we Deep dive into
this it just feels like Maxim has such
an immense understanding of these nof
positions I've seen him Blitz out these
sacrifices in so many games and find and
prove his compensation it's actually
beautiful the way he plays the night off
truly and I felt the same way watching
Gary Kasparov I literally grew up with
Gary and it was like he had this kinetic
feeling for the night orph and he just
he played some games against Mickey
Adams vishy and
nand Boris gelfin Alexi sheriff and it
was sort of like no matter what
positions he had this innate
understanding and he always landed on
his feet it feels like you're seeing a
masterpiece in process and of course
it's early to call on anything but these
sacrifices just come so naturally uh to
Maxim knowing where the pieces belong in
these kind of positions like you're
saying that innate understanding it's
fantastic to watch um I'm I'm kind of
baffled because again I do have a great
respect for Wesley's opening play and
this has been a disaster it has been
yeah it's something has not gone wrong
in less than 20 moves uh Peter yeah
don't expect this
this particular uh Fisher attack uh has
thank you oh this is really a blessing
but
honestly I feel like this should be
called the sain because of how they
follow it up these days because Fisher
would just like already Bishop E3
doesn't feel very Fisher like fish
Fisher would just go for the very very
quick F4 or5 in these days what they do
is they put the bishop on B3 then they
actually play A2 A3 to stop b54 all
together they play F3 and they play it
like the English attack in which your
Bishop is for some reason on B3 and not
on F1 which could be could be honestly
feels like you've wasted two temp and
also put it on a poor square right uh so
my initial reaction when I saw people do
this and I for instance caught Vladimir
Kik do this quite a bit and he did this
recently against me and I was completely
busted by move 20 I thought what is he
doing and then I thought why is my
position so bad and between those two
thoughts not very many moves passed as
well so it's like uh this is a new mod
approach but maybe it doesn't suit
Wesley uh as much and uh well I think
that Wesley is going to Ru the moment he
chose to play this position because I
like what mvl has done I'm seeing Knight
C5 I'm seeing Bishop F4 I'm seeing Queen
H4 check and you know what else you're
seeing you're seeing white king stuck in
the center for the rest of the game
hello I mean I've got I've got a
principle in the opening my principles
are very clear as as white or black I'm
trying to control the center I want
effective development and I want a safe
King I don't see a safe King I'm not
happy with what and Bishop takes D7 is
an indication right there best by the
way that uh you know corre immediate
compensation with the two Bishops you
can also include Bishop H4 check which I
think mvl decided not to do need to
there's no rush uh I think he hasn't
decided yet it's still on the7 you can
definitely throw in Bishop H4 check put
put the white King on D1 not that it's
running away very far but just to make
sure it goes to D1 can I do I have to go
to D1 I would love to be able to play
two I apologize is com I you have to
play King D1 and then we take on D7 and
the point I think of Bishop takes D7 is
that with black lacking uh the Luft on
the king side you can play Rook f one
here which is very important I think if
you couldn't play Rook f one here you
probably are close to Lost Rook F2 Queen
G4 streaming and then I think we are
running we go King C1 three King B2 and
we say we probably it probably costs us
the pawn on e4 right but it gets our
King to safety which we're very happy
about y by the way the Brilliance of A3
is revealed after you get to go King C1
King B1 King A2 a longterm vision and
eventually and by the way we do have
takes D7 before giving a check before
giving a check yeah so we it's clear
that Maxim has got a lot of compensation
and perhaps Wesley has to be precise the
next couple of moves uh to try to
restore some kind of balance in danger
Wesley so but we've got other games on
and a lot is happening there I want to
take your attention to our tournament
leader absolutely I brought it
upus this was the Queen's gamit declin
the Queen's Gambit declined with the
move A6 which allowed development from
Fabby with the bishop to E6 but if we
just do the action replay and get up to
date with the position that we had it's
quite a strategic fight we saw upon
structure change it just feels like like
white has got so much control you're
controlling the C line my knight on E5
is better than your knight on C8 yeah
sure you can come to D6 but the D5 Pawn
is hanging and that's a bit of a battery
on the C file that we're seeing by Liam
uh to me it feels like a game that white
is playing for two results and I would
pick quite any uh true that by the way I
thought that the whole play of of Fabby
purposefully was because of what you
were just describing you wanted to play
F7 F6 you want to drive the Knight away
from E5 and then you want to bounce with
your knight to a better square but the
the how do you say the the the actual
move on move F6 Queen takes C Queen
takes C8 is a threat uh
Peter Liam is very fast here is Fabby in
trouble well he he will play KN B6 I
think he's already played KN B6 yes one
thing I wanted to say is that apart from
F6 driving the KN away I would also
point out there is the idea of
and then play F6 and say where are your
squares right sir yeah sir where would
you like to put that KN so that I can
take it right uh you probably don't have
time enough but the fact that the engine
actually suggests running away right
away itself with he does by the way he
gives him he gives him a chance go ahead
if you don't mind put H5 on the board
and how do we like these and for some
reason it doesn't try to play Knight A8
wondering what you can play Knight D7
here and you probably actually end up
holding this position but I'm curious
what the reputation of Knight A8
is okay Queen B4 with the threat of Rook
C8 with a threat of Rook C8 and E7 is
hanging yes yes so this is a very very
important detail I suspect I didn't see
it either I suspect without Queen B4
black might be okay here because if you
play Queen A3 with a similar idea you
will be allowing Knight C7 and that's a
massive massive Improvement that goes to
B5 it gets to good squares but Queen B4
is basically winning here because
tarting B7 so C7 is not possible anymore
and the fact that Liam has played A4 I
think he has seen this idea because
otherwise this trapping of the White
Knight on E5 can be very scary for white
exactly A2 A4 on the board we'll keep an
eye on this one Let's us uh go back to
Ray versus for for a moment the def even
though
uh they were in a theoretical dispute I
was more than curious to see he did play
B6 and Knight C5 and allowed you
know in my time the knights on C6 were
considered glorious Beast we didn't Game
ending pretty muching beast but here uh
it feels like black just needs the night
on C5 so much that he felt this is his
best shot and guess what we've got a a
tricky check and Ray captured and went
long I've got to say this is
double-edged Stu Peter jump in we've
left I assume Theory some time ago that
there's actually there is still I think
a correspondence game which I judging by
the fact that I don't know either of
these names and they're pretty high
rated there must be a correspondence
yeah this is this is a good hint that
this is probably a correspondence game
which these days means computer versus
computer pretty much I hope which means
that the top players in the world follow
this correspond this is a very high
level line I suppose and I'm a bit
surprised just how much the engine still
likes this for white because the bishop
on G7 is very alive we had to Castle
Queen side because we just legally
couldn't Castle Ken side with the bishop
on A6 uh but once again returning to how
important this Knight on C6 is uh it
stops black putting a rook on B8 and
starting some counter playay along the
open open B file
and at first I thought this must be very
unclear but the engine I don't know why
it starts with the move Bishop F3
currently I would put a I don't know
which one you have to discuss which of
the Rooks goes to Ivan first but the
engine suggest starting with the move
Bishop F3 maybe it creates the threat of
G4
G uh but yeah this is still supposedly
good for white that Knight on C6 that
you're talking about it's a monster
piece and I'm just wondering can in
these kind of positions because you've
got this bishop on G7 iing B2 can alira
have in his mind to actually sacrifice
an exchange and B8 Rook be would be
something that would be on my mind
because I feel that Knight is uh so much
worth getting getting rid off and I'm
sure the computer kind of doesn't
compete the evaluation dropped by 2/10
of a pawn we gave up a full exchange and
we don't have a direct threat yet so I
think the engine actually agrees with
you entirely I would say this is a full
agreement and yeah this is I think this
is just a good idea people used to do
this in Dragons and and in all kinds of
uh situations where the bishop on G7 is
so valuable it's so thematic that's
that's my partner that's what I got this
i got this and yes ala is giv up the
queen that's a rook right now come on
especially amongst friends no seriously
the bishop on G7 those monster kings
Indian Bishops we actually used to call
them Dragon uh Bishops but I like it
that Bishop on G7 eyeballing B2 and
forget about it you control B8 yeah
Bishop F3 by the way would not be in my
repertoire I would be playing Rook e one
to play Rook e 7 like in an N the
Assumption has to be black plays a a
rook to E8 well thank you but now I
don't have to worry about Rook B8
anymore now I might think about Bishop
F3 sorry I sure I think the the bigger
question here is if you imagine because
once you start this operation you can
sort of expect all four Rooks coming off
right right and then we get we get to a
a position like please come on by the
way you're on point Bishop F3 I think
has been played here inclusing including
rookie one or not oh sorry rookie one
has been played here as you pointed out
and rookie it on the bo Peter the line
that you're showing we're going to see
that happen E1 go ahead now I think you
just go Rook E8 right and now we're
going to go g five take and Knight E8
and that loses to Bishop G4 though very
unfortunate o that's nasty and straight
up loses to Bishop G4 you stole my
thunder Bishop G4 you waiting I was for
this one this one yes F5 I have an AAS
on the Knight on E8 but in principle yes
you want to chop off all the Rooks but
you've got a in this position hold on a
very very big tactical problem with G5 I
have to play an ugly move rookie Knight
H5 no that that probably is also very
bad because of Knight G4 uh Bishop G the
indic the indication of just how bad
this is and also how uh resilient the
engines are if you play G5 here which is
the best move the engine takes on E1 and
then just says uh please come on oh wait
is it Queeny it no it just takes on H3
and says I will Play aie Down position
with both of my Bishops roaming free
good luck playing that on the board just
sacrificing a piece with Queen takes
Pawn yep and then you take it on age
three and white takes the Knight on I'm
going to call this screen
Marvin and I will have a Marvin hates
you I will have a very specific reason
for that yeah it's Marvin the screen
yeah but do you see this happening do
you think that Queen takes Pawn are we
going to see no I don't I don't think
this is happening but I just wanted to
illustrate it and eventually I will
Illustrated after a pause of 12 seconds
for each move U that I'm telling you
it's the electrical current that's in
your fingertips
Peter okay go for it I think it's ready
there you go yes and this is the
position I wanted to show where of
course white is still better as you can
see but this is not going to be easy to
to convert into a full point because
your king is not very safe the other
Bishop probably is coming into D the D3
Square you can start pushing your king
side quite safely because the King on G7
probably will at some point come to G7
it will be pretty comfy and as long as
we like the way white wins as I see it
is the Pawn on A7 actually falls very
quickly and then white starts pushing as
well because if this becomes like a
protracted battle where black survives
the pawn in A7 survives somehow I would
say black draws this more often than
than not fair white upper piece I mean
you've got to pick white every day of
the week every week of the year right
looking H5 King G7 safe pieces let's
move let's move on because uh again this
is rapid and things go quickly we've got
Jeffrey Jang versus Yan we're seeing a
lots of Bishops of opposite color and
what it's equal material right now not
the most exciting let's move on it
should be a balanced position to wrap
this up looks like it this looks like a
Berlin
ending between uh Sam and what's the
material count here it's down in
exchange for black for a pawn and two
Bish beautiful Bishops yeah Gorge Bish
Sam is better it's it's going to take
some winning but Sam is clearly better
here you can play at some point I'm I'm
assuming B2 B3 just to free up your KN
and start including your knight in the
game it has a very beautiful C4 Square
as Y is indicating to look forward to
exactly yeah Anish is after missing a
bunch of chances Anish is now having to
defend what it what has to be a pretty
unpleasant position okay very good and
uh did we did we at least uh check in on
everybody did we yes we did and the most
exciting battle still according to me
Remains the Wesley versus Maxim vasher
lra okay uh the night off that we saw so
let's get an update on that and we did
see Rook F1 by
Wesley and we did see Rook to F do a
very very nice move by the way no Bishop
checks nothing like that Queen F3 Peter
why do you say Rook C8 was so important
in this position because I think it's it
might be at first at first glance some
counterintuitive just to abandon the f
file which we liked so very much but
having provoked Rook F1 we no longer
have to worry about white castling King
side we're still controlling the H6 C1
diagonal meaning that the king is stuck
in the center and The Rook on C8 creates
this very very strong idea of Rook C4
yes uh which will cause almost instant
collapse of the white and H6 follow
Queen F3 H6 is also a very nice
indication that mvl understands he does
not need to he does not need to hurry he
yeah there was a threat of Queen
understands back rank
mates Queen a was a bit of a threat and
uh sidest stepping that and by the way
we just saw a I think a Fabiano move
there is a knight on A8 and well I've
got to go to the Fabby game a Liam our
tournament leader is playing boss
chess as still night is on A8 and it's
not coming out anytime soon yes look at
the way the Rooks and the queen are
taking away all the Escape squares for
that Knight on A8 you're essentially
playing down a piece right now exactly
I'm looking at this Knight on A8 I am
forcibly reminded of a Tavern there's a
name of a Tavern in
vikon and in Dutch it's called raise par
or Grandmaster Hans Ray's
KN and Hans Ray played the move night A1
against Bishop A4 by hiy westerinen a
grandmas from Finland and the night on
A1 was so abysmal yeah they named The
Tavern to
mock for having the worst night of all
times if that night isn't coming out
that right on a that looks really gross
how gross is it Peter I mean it looks
funny looks so bad pretty pretty gross I
was wondering why rookie 8 isn't just
winning on the spot but I guess there's
no need to uh commit to that just now uh
the why isn't it winning on good
question actually good take a look let's
check yeah Rook C8 because you can
actually go back to f8 and stop stop
yourself Oh you mean queen A3 to f8 how
do you get back to it goes back and that
preserves your material your position is
still going to be
quite point out that if black actually
trades on C8 the Knight just drops I
think after Rook C8 we have Knight F1
and we always have Knight F1 so we we
don't have to worry about the back rank
yeah so the engine just goes before
because it's hanging and also maybe at
some point you will want to play before
B5 maybe Rook C then you will play
Knight F1 you will play Knight G3 get it
to a good Square you know on a good day
this Knight might go all the way to F4
F4 would be a very very good Square for
it whereas black is not really doing
anything the dream is to rescue the
Knight and bring it back to E6 we're
talking about the Knight I mean the
queen on A3 isn't looking that pretty
anymore either this is this is a horror
a horror show and by the way let me
boldly State the obvious tournament
leader has a great position against
Fabby who I mean our grand leader a wild
card is
outperforming Liam on fire wow
unbelievable chess he's played he's
played Rook C8 and not play dting did
Fabby play Queen F has he found it yet
ret but retreating moves tricky but
you've got to find it otherwise you're
just down a piece it's just game over
well it's it's but yeah but that's the
other thing when you you when you're as
black and you play quote the active move
Queen f8 pardon me Queen E7 to A3 it's
not like you want to play Queen back to
f8 on the very next turn right I mean
that's an indication like you
something's wrong absolutely but I think
in the process of elimination you just
realize that black has no other move the
Rook on D7 can't move cuz the D5 Pawn
needs to be kept defended so Rook E7 is
out of the question maybe Queen E7 is
also playable but Queen f it seems like
it's more forcing because you at least
are inviting white to make a decision
either offload some pieces or go back
from C queen7 doesn't Force white to do
anything so also I'm up on the clock yes
I wanted to ask yes okay and again Ray
Ray Robson versus
fuja easy Play Bishop F3 H6 nothing UNT
is happened in this game Jeffrey versus
Yan this is the uh Bishops of opposite
color where is now a PA up but it feels
like draw should be still the the likel
result although people do lose these
positions I love how all of white Army
is on dark squares right now the color
of your own bishop and that's what you
need to do that's very instructive right
because when you're playing with
different color complexes you need to
Black needs to play Rook D7 oh that
beautiful stat yes put your Rook on a
light square and then it's perfect
harmony Perfect Harmony Wesley so versus
mvl again
two did so great players who have a
amazing records against one another
Bishop D2 okay I like that move by the
way because it does kind of
get threats and I'm looking at Rook C4
to E4 and I would prepare resignation so
I have to do something Peter yeah I
think Bishop G2 is is an attempt to to
force the the issue and uh solve at
least some of your problems by force I
think Bish is very strong I I would
exactly
prefer this is the way that you can help
me repair my position exactly Yeah by
trading Bishops and letting me play the
move Rook E1 you're not going to allow
that to happen you're going to play
Bishop H4 check force me to put my king
and queen C6 in particular and we win
the pawn on e4 with with Tempo and yes
it probably will involve trading the
Queens off but the position will remain
ugly with the ugly ugly ugly for white
with the two bit it wouldn't be so bad
if my on A1 we're somehow on G1 magic
you know uh but the fact that it's it's
still here I definitely definitely like
NBL Tanya where do you want to take us
100% agree with the your final
evaluation of this position I think
Maxim's going to be pushing this one and
Wesley's got a tough job ahead of him
defending this right and again lots of
exciting games uh for me the most
exciting is Fu's battle against Ray
Robson and Liam against Fabby and this
is also very crucial for our standings
at the end of the day so let's get an
update at this G5 move that has been
played and I'm guessing Peter that with
the move 86 what black has done is
vacated the 87 Square for the Knight
yeah uh I would assume that was his
intention but once again my screen
suggests some really really strange
things because we played H6 seemingly to
save this Knight but the the top line of
the engine right now is this I guess
because of this tactic now existing very
nice but you have the move Bishop G2
here which stops the tactic from
happening you and the engine goes Queen
G3 and now I guess if we take on F6 it
just yeah it says this is winning for
black for some reason you've just given
for black yeah we are a piece down and
the only direct threat we seem to have
is Bishop G5 but that threat is so
strong that I don't have a good swear
with the queen yeah you E1 is hanging
yes yeah Rook takes E1 was even stronger
but I I don't trust myself to make three
moves in a row without computer so I
wanted to make the shortest move
available and see if it's also winning
and it is still winning uh so I don't
know how easy all of this is to find
because you have to process not only
that but also the fact that there is 97
check to which you have to give give up
this exchange but I think you're happy
to give up the exch self-respecting uh
Kings Indian player will know that this
is very playable at least that Bishop on
G7 is beautiful yeah no joyfully but the
peace sacrifice once again I want to
just look at the position and process
that Queen takes H3 and why did you play
after Bishop G2 why didn't you play
Queen H4 in order to keep the the
variation hook H1 forcing forcing white
to make good moves is probably not
really important point that you make
because Queen H4 renews the threat of
Bishop H6 that what I was thinking but
Rook H1 okay wow but it it looks
like because he just went he didn't even
take on G5 he went Knight H7 immediately
and uh yeah the engine is back to to
liking this quite a bit because it goes
Bishop G4 forces the queen away goes H3
H4 and says you are welcome to this race
par yeah it's not
night the night is better on H7 than it
would be on H5 but I think the line that
you showed Peter it's stunning take on
G5 take that pawn on H3 but it's so
difficult to find this idea I'm pretty
sure he considered it but to assess it
properly on what I assume is pretty low
time is not going to be easy and I think
the difficulty was by the way we do have
a result it's a draw it's a draw uh with
Jeffrey Jong against yanomi who
immediately gets up and leaves I think
Yan is thinking I'm going to be ready
for the blitz yeah I think I think he's
shifting his attention to he is sh the
properly properly quick quick play yeah
okay back 11 out of 11 by the way by the
way back to Ray versus fua for for for a
moment uh Ray versus fuja because what
you did there that peace sacrifice is so
astounding that you know you go Queen
takes H3 you lose a piece and then you
say you're lost and you go what did I do
that was bad I did everything
consequential I think the difficult part
was finding this idea of the bishop
Retreat which hits the queen and then
the square of G3 where you're hitting
the rook and all these uh different
geometries that exist with attacking the
queen from G5 not an easy find uh which
was missed by Al again is we're back
on on uh face I think even optically
very clear to see yes and by the way a
huge update coming in that Fabiano
Carana has blundered against Liam we
were talking about the move Queen to f8
as the defensive resource he goes up
with The Rook to D6 what's happening
here he went Queen A5 Queen A3 Rook
C8 what Rook D6 The Rook onang he traded
no no he didn't trade
first is hanging on C1 and Liam very
quickly played Knight of one which is a
very understandable
decision securing the back rank trade on
C8 happens and the Knight on A8 is
finally in the game and Rook C3 is a
very natural looking move but I think it
maybe no it's still very good where was
the blunder cuz we got an update that
there was this no this night I'm no I
mean the position is this position is
just bad the position is bad Rook C3 is
not maybe the top move because I think
Rook C7 and or Rook B8 were borderline
winning for by way how do you not play
Rook C7 in that position it's because B3
is hanging yes uh I'm curious because it
looks very very natural maybe he thought
Queen B3 Rook B7 and now something
existing I don't know what like Rook C6
maybe and he was worried he will blunder
some kind of Rook C1 Rook takes F1 Queen
D1 M somewhere okay but yeah the engine
suggests this is completely winning
because you actually switch no honestly
looking at the first line I understand
why he hasn't played it because the
machine says you go Queen E1 Queen takes
A4 Queen E2 and he just switched to
giving mate on the king side oh wow this
is not the where did that come from yeah
this is not the switch you can make very
very easily you're playing on the queen
side for the last 15 moves and then
suddenly a check on the other side of
the board but the Rook on the seventh
rank that's what we that's what Rooks
Aspire for that's what the their whole
purpose in life Peter is to invade on
the open file abely absolutely but once
again if you get here and you realize
that there is no immediate way for you
to win the night and queen takes A4 is a
thread right um
yeah so uh Rook C3 was played let's get
an update of the the position and que4
played by queen4 is actually a massive
massive mistake it looks so it looks so
natural to play Queen B4 you're hitting
the Rook on D6 you can't KN C4 exists
here and I'm pretty sure Fabi should
spot it is that the only move should be
yeah I think I think if you don't play
it now you probably get mated if Rook to
E6
that you will get M I think we should
point that out that Knight C4 here
cral this looks like a a fabulous move
for white the the queen and he's played
the uh reputation if you will but when
you play the move Queen B4 at fir
visually speaking you say oh my gosh
this is so winning I'm going to go Rook
to the seventh and I'm going to go queen
f8 I'm going to Checkmate You Queen B4
I'm winning your opponent plays Knight
C4 taking advantage of the fact that you
can't play bc3 by the way now suddenly
Rook to D6 to B6 is a
possible and The Rook is hanging and
suddenly am I forced to play A5 uh Peter
what's going on well there is an
immediate draw available you can take on
we should address the elephant in the
room here that this looks like a blunder
of a piece Rook C4 DC4 Queen takes D6
but black will play C3 or I think C3 is
faster and this Pawn is queening so
quickly that you have to play Queen E6
and give this perpet nice
idea uh leang leang Li has a bailout
available to him immediately he can
actually continue playing if you will
plays A5 or Knight G3 because Knight G3
that's a nice move I like Knight G3 I
can also connected with a very nice trap
because if you play Rook B6 here it
seems like you've won a rook but now
after Queen I assume E7 is stronger than
f8 okay and queen C3 and then Knight F5
there's a very picturesque M by the way
King G6 Queen takes G7 oh that's we got
to show that yeah drag it drag it all
the way to F5 and mate it on the F5
Square walk the
plank there you go very nice finish
there and I think it might be important
to go for this because I'm wondering if
white does go for the idea of A5 does
that give black the opportunity to try
try for more in that position or is A5
good enough as well cuz I was thinking
about I wanted to go Queen B1 but now I
see that you have Rook ticks C4 in all
cases in all cases I can bail out for
any point that you A5 A5 after Rook C6
for some reason the engine starts
preferring black I don't really
understand why Knight G3 is so bad okay
Knight
E5 oh no that looks like Knight
F4 after Rook C6 you
get no this is this is very very
difficult to find play but because we
just played Queen E7 and Knight F5 for
white might as well play Knight E5 to D
and the point is we're not losing a Pawn
on F2 we're actually getting mated which
the whole point which is a bit of an
issue yeah yeah
that is gorgeous all right some really
nice tactics and countertactics in this
one and the play continues in our other
boards as well yasa where there's a lot
of attack going on even in this end game
we see uh exchange down let see what
Wesley has done we're going to back up
to where we left it and indeed we did
see the Queens come off the board and as
you were saying in your view you just
saw that Maxine was the one who is going
to be pressing and we've caught up to
the players and yes he's the one
pressing that Bishop on D3 is a monster
and it's not even a material deficit
anymore you do the ma it's Bishop in two
pawns worth five points against a rook
and blacks Rook so active attacking on
B2 no coordination between white Rooks
exactly what you want where you won
those Rooks is on the seventh rank
that's not happening anytime soon no
Maxim still fighting for the win in this
one oh big time yeah I wonder if it's
already completely winning you still
have to pay attention to some counter
threats because what I think what Wesley
wants is to play like Rook A7 Rook G1 in
short order and start attacking the pawn
on G7 because we can take on B2
immediately or we can play Rook H2 take
H4 this also is available but it does
allow white some semblance of C the the
the nice part about playing Rook takes
B2 is I can force the trade of a rook
you don't have Rook G1 on your I think I
I think if one pair of Rooks come come
comes off wies drawing chances improve
exponentially I would very much like to
preserve my rook in particular you know
looking at how active our Rook is and
how horrible that Rook on E1 is trading
The Rook on B2 for The Rook on E1 feels
like you know crime against humanity we
don't need to because when you play Rook
G1 there is Rook B1 check anyway so you
just keep the Rook on B2 right but Rook
takes B2 I was snipping the pawn and
making sure that the Rook wasn't going
anywhere I love uh so but the other
point that Peter was mentioning is you
could be even more gross and say look I
want to Ed pass pawns let me let me
aspire to win the H4 Pawn which do you
prefer Peter uh B2 or H4 I'm not sure
and I I briefly uh took a look at what
the engine is saying the engine is
saying this is defensible for white
which honestly shocked me yeah I thought
uh my my evaluation was I probably won't
win it but the engine will but the the
engine also suggests that it probably is
a draw with absolute best play which
surprising yeah I would have thought
this has to be winning for black yeah I
I was very dismissed
as well yes and well it looks like
Wesley still on the back foot here a
very big task of trying to hold his
position Maxim exceptional play in the
night off and we're seeing some
exceptional play by Ray Robson as well
in his game against Ali RZA that night
on 87 well makes a wful impression it
does but it's not dead forever because
after this onong a streamer's favorite
move here takes on F6 Bishop took on F6
but this does create a long-term
weakness on G6 wow
uh here I mean there's so many reasons
not to play aasan including just the
idea that you could play Bishop G2 and
snuggle up nicely on the E6 square but
that was that his choice he
took and whoa and he's ahead on the
clock as well no no no no nobody
believes you it's I know right I don't
believe myself while saying that I think
this could be a first in the tournament
Ray Robson who's been playing
exceptional chess with seconds on the
clock is ahead by 2 minutes this time in
a position where he's pushing for an
advantage yes I would say so King h8 on
the board and okay everybody's favorite
question why can't I take the pawn you
can you
should everybody's favorite answer Rook
takes G6 on the board and he did he can
you should and he did and Ali rais H4
about to be played that seems that seems
like suicide you are not surviving this
not Bishop E6 Bishop E6 Rook H1 thank
you for opening up the H file no no that
this this doesn't look but that means
that it all went wrong when Ali RZA
decided to retreat the night to 87 it 86
was okay but it was Queen H3 was the
necessary uh thing but that's a really
Narrow Path at keeping the balance to
find this idea of Queen takes Pawn from
a human perspective so difficult not
easy and look at Ry Ray saying
uh raaza I mean are you serious you're
going to let me post up my Bishop on E6
my knight on C I have the best I have
the best minor pieces ever I mean and
Rook H1 takes H5 as a threat as well
everything is uh it's gone coming coming
apart here completely gone with the
night on 87 this might be our first win
of the day uh people I mean and uh for
oi Razer that will be stunning it would
be taking down uh taking ala fua for Ray
Robson it would be a huge huge result
and you're right we've had 11 draws so
far right might be the first decisive
game of the day wow and Bishop E6 on the
board and I just you know you whenever
you're in a bad position you you look
for a Hail Mary you know you're just you
know what can I do to uh get a tactic in
right like make a mess here yeah I I I'm
ready to make something chaotic and he's
gone to play Bishop F6 it looks like
this has gone uh what about the Fabby
game Peter the Fabby game is uh very
very level but in such a way that you
know you you feel you feel it's a
travesty uh this is a forest draw but
the the first line of the computer in
this position you start by playing Queen
f8 which I think is a very findable
move and and Black's way to make a draw
here involves at some point pretty much
in every single variation to play KN D2
and to establish this very well well
known mechanism of a Perpetual with the
Knight on F1 stopping the king escaping
by the G3 square and then we give a
check from anywhere and we give this
Perpetual this wouldn't be so tricky but
after Knight D2 you can play Knight
takes F6 to which black is supposed to
answer King G6 and after Queen E8 check
I think the it might be the only move to
play Rook F7 please point out Peter that
King takes Knight actually why that
doesn't work because it actually runs
into Queen E5 check Queen E5 check and
then Queen takes C7 and we have and we
have
I didn't understand very important Point
nice and then finally after Rook F7
white has so many pieces hanging and
that he does aot you have to allow Queen
A1 Knight F1 and then Knight somewhere
what a drawing me this is a this is not
going to be uh that easy to find and I
think King H2 was played by by Liam to
which I correctly replied F5 correctly
F5 yeah this is now I think it will end
in some kind of a Perpetual but it feels
like Liam perhaps isend in slightly
dangerous ter Tri it's such a strange
position I mean just visually the KN on
e4 attacked by these two pawns the
Knight on C4 is hanging uh the queen on
B2 Rook on C7 this there's no time on
the clock X Ring no time on the clock
and the computer just says you know what
0.0 get out of here it's easy no I don't
believe this this is an and by the way
the move F5 according to the computer
was not only the the best move only move
but slight slight slight Edge for black
I would have never guessed that if I'm
Liam and I don't know the engines of I'm
thinking I'm the one for Choice yes I'm
not thinking I'm worse it's one of those
positions yes where the engine Nal is
0.0 but I feel that draw is the least
likely outcome here well the issue the
issue is the KN is now attacked by two
two pawns and FTC is an actual threat
because it doesn't relinquish control of
the Knight on C4 and if the Knight goes
somewhere
you lose your Rook on C3 with 6 A5 so uh
this is a legitimately a problem for
White and the way to make a draw I think
judging by what I see on my screen is
you start by Rook take C4 you wait for
DC you have to see this move Queen A5 oh
F5 hanging eventually we'll make it I'm
sure all right we will see if the
players find their way out but right now
we're getting a huge uh huge update that
the game Ray Robson is about to finish
and it looks like Ray has found the way
out exactly well takes E6 by Ali Raza F
takes Queen takes C6 Knight D5 Bishop D4
Knight E7 hitting the G8 Square so that
after Queen E8 pick up the queen it's
three pieces for the queen and normally
the three pieces actually do pretty good
but in this case it's the two connected
pass pawns Queen a check Queen takes A7
Queen takes A6
unfortunately wins a wins a piece as
well so I mean that E6 Pawn is also so
strong
position so we've got unfortunately
sometimes this helps when we have only
one choice Queen A8 check is the most
attractive but he goes for it yes E7 is
also uh winning a piece at least it
remind me who said it that if you see if
you see a mate and you see you're
winning material go for the material
take the material the mate not might not
be there might not be there you might
have miscalculated so just go for the
material well that's exactly what Ray
has done and I think think we're going
to see a resignation shortly here this
is breaking the the the drought for sure
yeah G6 and you can you can play five
check I think taking on A6 is just good
enough you don't have to be fancy the
position is just utterly winning don't
look for the mate here don't look for
the mate no I not being
fancy but with this Victory and we think
it's it's about to unfold he will jump
to first
place uh with the come of the Liam game
still un decided I mean our wild cards
are gone wild yes they're on a wild
spree right now just uh somebody tell
them that you know like the regular
players of the of the grand chest or are
favorites but we saw this in the first
two events as well of the grand happens
to be your biggest wild card ever Queen
F theard queen7 followed by F5 is
actually the machine prescribed solution
here creating a threat of6 yeah is there
a way to fight it you have to go Knight
f8 and that doesn't look like a happy
Choice King G5 and then we will take on
H7 then we will Queen the E Pawn as well
so yeah it's not a very that's greedy I
like it I like
this oh so you can pick up the Knight on
H7 so here it comes Queen takes H7
followed by E7 and queen G6 and goodbye
and goodbye it was nice knowing you
Queen takes H
Queen 87 on the board and Ali Resa fuja
trying to push the pawn but it's too far
back is it time for white to give a
check or do you just go with E7 yeah uh
I always like to drive the king away
from the followed by F6 F7 I think
forces resignation quicker than anything
else Drive the king away from the
connected pass pawns and and promote the
pawns that's going to promote with check
sorry go you're right and very
instructive how R has slowed down he's
taking his time to find the most
accurate way to actually wrap up matters
and he does it yeah Queen G6 and we
expect F6 and F7 when you are a Time
trouble addict and your opponent gets
into time trouble and you just perform
brilliantly well you think to yourself
you know what maybe I shouldn't get
myself into time trouble so much he has
played E6 Bishop he gone F6 and that's
it we Ali Resa resigns hand shakes and
re Robson climbs up the leader board and
let's jump to the game of Fabby uh for a
moment because his game against Liam can
Liam keep Pace now with um Ray Robson I
think he's completely lost now what
Fab's winning this game I see an extra
Queen
happened extra Queen but he's also
giving mate yeah Queen did follow
missed he missed Rook C4 and then heed
que A5 he missed a probably a drawn
chance on the next move as well after
Queen yeah Rook C4 is a bad bad mistake
Queen f8 here was still sort of holding
the equilibrium queen f8 queen C3 taking
on C4 then taking on F5 with check that
wasn't that bad it looks maybe like it
should be bad but it's not that bad and
it's definitely better than have a
result look we do have a result and it's
Fabby who has knocked Liam off out of
first and
is like hey guys thanks for inviting me
to the tournament he's the Soul Leader
Soul Leader amazing and in the meantime
uh Maxim has beaten Wesley in that end
game wow which Le means we've got one
game remaining and that's the game
between Sam and Anish giri now when we
left it some time ago we thought that
Sam was for Choice how is it now remains
for choice I don't know if it's easily
winning I think the pawn on C3 can just
be picked up right now by playing Knight
D1
one uh and then you will have to win
that three against three one flank on
one side with rook and Knight against
the Bishops which is going to take a
while but I think in Practical terms you
win it more often than not because it's
just so much more fun so much more fun
asking questions rather thaning
questions in and the problem is maybe
the Pawn's not on F7 or F6 it's a little
bit uh uh vulnerable uh isolated on E6
so yeah Knight D1 and this will be a
grind but I'm still still uh stunned we
had this moment there Tanya of 11 draws
in a row yes and we're kind of getting
used to games ending in draws and then
suddenly we had a flourish of three
victories decisive games and this might
be the fourth decisive game of the day
uh but just amazing how our leaderboard
has changed and Fabiano with some
critical misses throughout the
tournament finally eventually takes on
the leader of the tourn and opens up the
field for Ray Ray RS it's getting Wild
for the wild cards it is great knight1
also notice how The Rook on F4 it
defends everything on the fourth rank so
you don't have any Bishop A4 checks to
boot yeah that's sad uh that that's a
mist5 if5 played by move you never make
with any kind of enthusiasm because I
really don't like that move either I
think he wants to play Bishop F1 next I
think the only explation that is it yes
it has to be Bishop F1 is that he's
hunting uh hunting the ball on H3 so you
move the Rook to B4 the only Square to
stop as anticipated and wow Anish just
banged the clock there did he really um
Bishop on H3 looks a little bit for laor
can it be trapped Knight E3 Bishop
Bishop H3 King takes C3 so the bishop
for the moment is a little bit stuck
usually in these kind of geometries we
see the bishop dominate The Knight when
it's two squares away
here it's tables of turn the knights
dominating the bishop on H3 exactly so
what Tanya is referring to imagine a
black Bishop on E3 and a white knight on
H3 and then you say the White Knight is
dominated right now you say the White
Knight dominates the bishop very unusual
and Bishop to G5 trying to get rid of
that Knight this is very concrete
because Rook B7 Rook takes G7 exists but
it might not be that great surprisingly
because then the king will start chasing
that Rook trying to prepare to trade on
E3 and then to win the the G4 pawn and
Sam understandably says no to all of
that and tries too yeah he wants to play
F3 and then the bishop on H3 really will
have no squares and no way out yeah the
bishop would be trapped on H3 might you
don't even have time actually to get out
and it's on the board King E6 F3 and how
are you winning this are you just
bringing your Rook
back this is a okay this this gets lets
the bishop out but structurally I think
this is very very you have to play
Bishop F1 if you don't play Bishop F1
now he probably never gets out exact now
we have making moves
on start playing Rook B goes check check
is followed by King E4 and then Bishop
G2 I guess or bishop and then I'll and
then I'll just uh chase the bishop chase
the bishop and then eventually and we've
got that so if Bishop E2 Rook B2 chasing
the bishop away and you don't have
enough squares to keep the attack on the
F3 Pawn the diagonal be two versus two
now if it was the F3 Pawn were on the H3
Square I think there'd be some real
drawing chances in this case I don't
believe so I think this has to be
reasonably uh easily lost G5 I think is
the correct approach you have to you
have to fix the white pawns on on the
light squares yes so that at least some
positions will be drawn you can Target
but I think this sort of loses by force
somehow the bishop is on very poor
squares you probably can just make sure
it has no no way to attack the F3 pawn
and then force a king to
G6 whoa we're being baruan is telling us
guys
G5 is a draw King takes C5 apparently
was a decisive
mistake he had to he had to probably
give a check on D7 then go Rook D6 check
or something I don't I don't even know
it's one of those takes E5 G5 table base
table base human base I always say these
are two different things and you're were
right by the way they are two different
things check check instead of King Tak
C5 was winning and this is a draw
now because if your Rook was on
d66 would be G5 wouldn't have been
playable yeah wow so the point is that
whenever white does get the king to F5
black will have a check with the bishop
to drive it away so you really are not
able to push black king to the eighth
rank which is a dream like so just to to
tell our viewers if white were able to
play King F5 and a rook and drive the
king to the eighth rank then we easily
win by yeah targeting the pawns so Rook
to D7 sha King to G6 is the problem
always G6 yeah you can't you never go
back because that would lose on the spot
and King G6 and what you were saying
Tanya is if we ever get in a situation
where our King is on F5 and we're ready
to drive your king back to the first
rank you always have a check which is
why very smartly very tricky Sam puts it
on B7 okay so now you wouldn't have the
check on B1 which is why Anish moves it
to another Square so there'll be a check
from D3 next exactly you always want to
make sure that you'll be able to check
the white king away from the F5 Square
very nice uh and I think Anish knows
what he's doing and I think he's doing
it very confidently the again uh we are
seeing some endgame prowess on a
different level you've only got seconds
and you you find G5 and you find all of
these resources and Liam holding that
Queen is ridiculous if Anish holds this
this has been an endgame masterclass day
wow
wow and second Anish giri with 15
seconds both players but Anish has to be
careful he has to make sure he doesn't
allow King F5 without a check so he s
side steps with the bishop now the C2
square is Target and I'm expecting
Bishop to
A2 it's funny it's like the chess board
at 8 by8 is just big enough if it was
6x6 the bishop wouldn't have the length
of the diagonal to give the check and I
think this these are the kind of
positions where you're saying Bishop is
three and a half points and the Knight
is three points because Bishops are long
range pieces they can move around to
defend the position like this uh King F5
and gives a check he just wanted to make
sure that okay the king is trying to
enter the camp Visa V E7 but how do you
improve next and let's point out if the
pawns are traded off that's just an
immediate draw because black is also on
the right corner yes and by that I mean
it is the opposite color of the light
squar Bishop which is exactly the
defensive resource you want with just a
pure Rook versus Bishop exactly um yeah
even though we've managed to cross uh
the Rubicon once we get our Rook here
and check we're not really
interfering can I put my king on the
f8 no I don't think I do anything I keep
my Bishop I keep my Bishop on this
diagonal yeah you won't be allowed to
give a check on F7 I think he just
defends any check with the Rook on F7
exactly exactly that's the whole point
so this is the key diagonal as Anisha is
showing and he made that move with just
two seconds on the clock I saw that he
was looking at the clock when he slapped
it as he realized his clock and take
down to two seconds and it's so so
common to just forget those seconds and
even though you're confident of your
hold the time just Slips Away it does I
tell you the time the space-time
metric CH Matrix changes when you're in
time trouble those 30 seconds that you
get in in classical chest those 10
seconds you get two seconds they just
bleed away they're gone I mean all
do you have that expression they're gone
in a hiccup now I do but I completely
get it and I think you're absolutely
right about the clock it's all gone in a
hiccup in those last seconds so Anish
needs to be a little aware of the clock
which he is so far 3 seconds by the way
that
time but he's figured it out that this
is the construction he needs to hold and
I think G5 was his endgame knowledge he
knew that this is the way to go by the
way shame on me but when he played the
move G5 I was still of the opinion that
white was in Cruise mode and was doing
winning I hadn't realized the Fortress
he he set up and I think he was aware of
it that this is the ideal position and
it's that's the most difficult part
about these end games you don't know how
to position your pawns so it's so
critical it's a difference between half
a point and a loss here exactly again uh
Sam has been very good at keeping 30
seconds this clock um Anish on the other
hand has been going down in the
teens I am checking when was our last uh
pawn move and that was G5 g yep which
was on move number 61 so there's still a
long way to go before the 50 move
rule uh Peter when you're looking at
this position
uh you know give us a sense you're
playing for F4 what could no I'm pretty
sure you're playing for a mistake which
suddenly robs your opponent of of a
check somehow so you get your King on E7
your Rook on F6 you Shuffle and then you
Shuffle some more and then you Shuffle
some more and you hope that at some
point your opponent puts his Bishop on
such an unfortunate square that suddenly
you can sort of Zoom it back to where
you have the threat of king of five whoa
whoa whoa whoa whoa we just saw the king
we just
which is a move I desperately wanted to
avoid yes and that's because now can you
actually Shuffle with your Rook on E7
and get your king back to where you want
it which is F6 yeah that would be the
dream right if we could go Rook E7 King
D7 King E6 and King F6 then you you have
to assume that black will be in time to
play Bishop A2 Bishop D5 and distract
white by attacking the F3 Pawn because
otherwise yeah that would be winning
right but that but why did he put his
King well now you can put your king back
right
is but was King the only move here I I
think he he was very worried about
allowing king of F I think it's
understandable because if you if you had
he played King G6 you would have to
contend with King G King f8 creating the
threat of Rook C6 check and then your
king would have to go to H7 that doesn't
look right either yes because your king
lands to F6 then so was it right T that
he played King G8 that that was a that
was a decent move let's have that moment
on the analysis board we've got the live
board Yas can you put that because Ki
I instantly yeah I was stunned by King
G8 and let me just put on my analysis
engine and my analysis engine says
slightly better for white which
is of saying it holds so okay there you
go let me just refresh very nice
understanding there by Anish because
King
G6 you know or King F6 would be just the
move that you want to make
yep are we going to see see another
claim
of that would that would be that would
be quite something if we had two of them
in one
day and by the way as we keep a close
eye on this uh we're going to go to
Anastasia who has a guest in studio
Anastasia over to
you great thank you yes sir and I'm here
with Fabiano Carana fa congratulations
you made it you won the game today and
the two previous games finished in a
draw let's see the last one was really
crazy I thought you were in trouble I
also thought I was in trouble no I think
I was losing but I I think I defended it
very well even low on time yeah this
position didn't look that nice because
he controls C file and I don't know yeah
he he always controls the C file and my
knight is very bad the only thing I have
for me is that his Knight is also bad
for the moment but if he gets to G3 I I
resign yeah but you managed to play this
Knight C4 fantastic move which
immediately yeah changed the whole
situation I think this was tricky okay I
wasn't sure I could be losing on the
spot with this move um yeah there were
some lines I was a bit surprised by Rook
C3 because I thought uh that other moves
like Rook C7 is very critical of course
did you did you see this um funny line
that Queen B3 and Rook C6 I thought yeah
Rook C6 yes and actually computer Peter
schro suggested Queen E1 and then Queen
E2 and you go I didn't queen1 I didn't
see Queen E1 that's interesting no I was
thinking Queen A6 and queen A4 okay I'm
uh yeah I I wasn't sure if I'm surviving
or not but at least I'm not losing on
the spot but I was very happy when I got
this okay Queen B2 I thought anyway he
can play Rook C7 but I was surprised by
this very surprised because well first
the point I was quite happy about was
that there is this this little tactic
okay it's kind of cute uh and I win in
exchange wow so he played Queen B4 okay
Knight C4 I thought it's a draw he just
missed it this Knight C4 move yeah it
wasn't sure but I like I thought okay
we're going to make a draw he'll do this
I'll do this and yeah yeah Perpetual
check or something like that and I
thought if he wants to play on okay he
can play A5 but it's extremely risky to
play A5 because then he's really stuck
so he played this and I realized that
I'm getting checkmated like Rook B6
Queen E7 A5 Queen B7 so okay Rook D7 I
need it to play but it looked quite
solid at least and I was happy that for
example if A5 here where he blocks the
the queen side that I probably have
um uh well no sorry Knight E4 I think
this is critical and Rook C7 I was very
happy with this move because if A5 then
I have this Knight D2 yeah Knight D2 is
was and queen check and I don't think I
have more than draw but okay draw is
anyway I was quite happy with it this
moment uh
and and I thought okay maybe I have some
other move but I didn't really see it so
I was going to go for this and then he
surprised me can get to because I had
seen that this F5 is um suddenly I'm
playing for a win like wherever his
Knight moves I have A5 and he can't get
to my king anymore because the Rook on
C7 is performing a really nice job so I
I thought it's still a complete mess
have seconds I don't know Rook C4 is it
working here no nothing like that yes
yeah there's like this queen A5 I mean I
didn't really I think I saw this
possibility but I wasn't worried because
like let's say in this position I I have
a draw yeah in my hand like I can play c
c C3 cb3 and it's a draw and so maybe it
was his last chance to to make a draw or
something yeah probably probably it is a
draw it does feel like white should not
be losing in this position where he is
up material for the moment and position
is very opened but he went straight for
a line which I actually had while he was
thinking I kind of was thinking about it
so I I very quickly made these moves
because I expected this it looks very
natural what he's doing cuz here like he
gets this he takes here he takes B7 and
I don't know it's a lot of Pawns I
wasn't wasn't so sure about that one so
so I saw this and the point is of course
that if he takes then uh I don't care
about the queen side so much it's just
that I play H5 and and win his Knight
and okay Knight H1 is basically res
but yeah it it was a very lucky Escape
yeah but before you missed also a great
chance against Wesley so let's have a
look at this game hope we have some time
for that um you want me to relive my
painful yes yes yes of course we have to
check this one I mean I just was
wondering what did you miss exactly like
G5 or or which no no I'll tell you so I
just I just came here so of course like
we I I I feel like I played quite
accurately of course I don't know if
everything I did was correct but it felt
like all of these moves I made were
quite accurate and once I saw this yeah
this moment I saw that like I have F5
and King G8 and I thought game is over I
saw Queen B1 and like I thought
everything wins in this position like
literally everything wins okay Queen H6
for example is basically immediate
resignation because he has to give his
check and then Queen f8 and any Queen
trade my C Pawn promotes okay Queen F7
is very good F5 and if I don't want to
calculate a single thing just Queen E8
and he resigns just prevent this checks
yeah just stop checks and he's
checkmated and trade of Queens also wins
for black so I think that maybe he won't
resign at this moment but it's actually
not too it's not like it's too early to
resign all so basically I just
calculated up to this moment and I I
thought in my calculations I can do this
I realized I blender check made in one
move ah this is what you missed okay M
yeah I I basically I missed this queen
G4 so I thought okay also King F5 wins I
was what I was thinking like everything
wins but king of four super safe and uh
then I realized that I'm lucky not to
lose my first thought was oh my God I'm
losing cuz I lose my Rook yeah um yeah
this was terrible and then also against
Ray I think I had serious winning
chances despite probably being losing as
well uh against Yan I I had a complete
meltdown yeah just plus eight out of the
opening yeah yeah I saw this game I mean
I think you have some kind of shaky
start and how can you explain this do
you feel a bit tired after Grand swis or
I just blend every game I'm blundering I
like my player is extremely poor I have
to say uh every game I think has been
poor except maybe which game did I play
well no no hard remember yes no G some
doubts okay P thank you so much and I
wish you all the best tomorrow I mean
already 50% not so bad no 50% is a
miracle and I should celebrate tonight
okay see you tomorrow and we're back to
the studio thank you you
Fabiana they're not happy with his play
but it's been good enough to take down
the leader and yes the drama keeps
coming today absolutely uh we are
stunned while Fabby was being
interviewed because remarkably King and
Rook versus King and Bishop The Rook
loses why does The Rook lose because the
clock look at the clock
three two and make a move but he doesn't
in time and he got flagged exactly you
lose on time in there and did an realize
it immediately I don't think so no he
wasn't even looking he was he was sure
he was going to make it in time and
he there you see it and doesn't even
notice yet yet
yet but he is about to and it's going to
be a beautiful Revelation by the way how
does Anish gir win I oh dying
unbelievable we were talking about
forgetting the clock but Nish needs to
be careful of doing that but it's Liam
who guys not Liam it is uh I'm losing my
head exactly Sam Sean who gets flagged
at the end and these are the standings
at the end of the day a stunning change
at the end because of those last results
Ray Rob 15 games y said three decisive
games today wow because that one wasn't
drawn that was this is true four
decisive games but Liam tumbles Ray
Robson goes up mvl who kind of
been
disappearing and well let's go to the
man who's number two in the tournament
with
Anastasia and here we are together with
Maxim R graph we're absolutely shocked
with with news uh Sam just lost the game
I mean it's unbelievable Maxim but back
to you you won such a great game today
um and after so many draws finally you
managed to to score I remember this not
I mean not shaky game against Yan but
now let's go to the game which you won
against Wesley so yes uh against Yan I
definitely missed an opportunity so West
Lev was minus one so that's probably why
he went for this very sharp line and
that was like uh Vladimir played it
kumnick and leevon as well so it's very
topical uh I know was a twil game in US
championship against Mishka I think Mish
play Knight C6 so Knight
D7 G4 C8 so of course I want to take the
night yeah like sometimes you manage to
do so no this is like the topical like
Gary used to say like whenever you can
take on C you you do it you don't
hesitate yes you just you just do it but
was on G5 Knight H5 F4 and at first I
wanted Rook C3 mhm but then I realized I
might have Knight F4 so I did
I wasn't sure about the positions like
there's many moves for white you can
start with G6 sometimes I don't think
that
works um but even moves like Knight
Bishop D5 I was not sure like Knight D5
e d and maybe
H4 I wasn't sure about all these sort of
positions there's many ways like maybe
you can play Knight F5 and H4 so but
then I wanted again
Rook is3 no matter what and then he
played this knight6 and how did you
estimate the position after those
exchanges I thought knight6 was very
strange because well
here I assume I cannot be
worse um i s for a while Bishop G5 yes
but I couldn't make it
work I thought maybe there's something
work uh because the problem is Rook C4
you go maybe Rook F1 you threaten always
back Han mates and after Rook C3 BC
maybe some Queen H4 I don't know what's
going on yes but it's no problem yes you
give just same Rook F1 F1 is coming
always so I couldn't make it work so I
just took Bishop C and Bishop G5 I
thought um I thought here maybe bishop
D5 was
best uh Bishop D7 took me by surprise
cuz uh I mean it was very tempting for
me to play Bishop h H4 always to Uncle
the king but then I thought anyway my
Bishop on G5 is so good so let's first
provoke Bishop D2 I thought that you
played Rook C8 to give the second Rook
now no to play Rook C4 no I'm joking I
mean you just said that anytime you have
this chance to give the no it wouldn't
be so bad but um yeah and here Queen F I
think uh yeah W made bit of in accuracy
I think he wanted Rook D1 here but he
realized probably that after Rook C4
queen f8 king H7 so like Rook F7 would
lose because well
you uh you give one more check you are
first to give the Checkmate yes I mean
and if you go Queen F5 which must have
been his idea I think here D5 is
extremely strong yeah and then push PA
just they they run yes because yeah so
let's say then you entered the ending
right and um yes and at first I thought
that was winning here uh like I thought
this was very nice e for Bishop F2 and I
don't mind giving uh the per Bishops
because I mean given my Bishops because
of the Rook on A1 and King is stuck but
actually um H4 I
think like for instance
here if he goes hook
G1 I couldn't find a
win because after is
goes it feels like it's already almost
only one but he still has this ideas
with check and Rook A7 exactly yeah some
Perpetual so I couldn't find a win and I
was like uh not sure mhm but he didn't
play this mov yes yeah no in the end I
had found some idea to to keep the game
going
um maybe maybe I think I want E2 and
Bishop C4 mhm but even then King
F2 and yes yes but because the bishop no
but because the bishop on C4 prevents uh
the mate yes so then you have chance to
play Rook D1 and yes mhm okay Bishop C4
looks very strong yes so when was the
moment you realized that you already
like winning this game um I mean even
here I wasn't
sure like I would need to cheat to no
yeah I'm not surprised it felt it felt
like it's not winning this yeah mhm
because um I mean it could easily be
winning because my HP runs but but I
really wasn't sure and I wasn't sure
also because probably at some point it
gets like let's say something like
this and this positions I wasn't sure
because my pawns are running and I have
B Pawn so you can never give the Rook
but but because it's h& I assumed it
would be Dro because probably you can
just give um all the checks in the world
what was the final mistake of Wesley
which helped you to win the game uh I
think hook G7 I think hook G7 is bad
because then when my Bishop goes to F5
well have good feeling you and and and
the Machine yeah King one was probably
still but okay already very difficult
yeah Maxim I mean what what a great game
how do you feel about the start do you
feel that you didn't get some points
which you had to get or uh maybe I mean
especially the game before was Yan but
at the same you played very provocative
right um yeah I mean he just blundered
and then uh I was to P up I was trying
to make things uh easy for me but um
This Night 10 game turned out to be much
more complicated than I thought it would
be uh but there were some games where
like I mean of course against Fabiano I
was first winning but then I was
completely lost and against Anish in the
first round I was absolutely
lost without a chance so so in the end
plus one is not bad no plus one is good
score I had four blocks already so I'm
going to push my Lu tomorrow of course
and we wish you all the best of luck
tomorrow thank thank you and we're going
back to the studio to you guys thank you
Anastasia and well we're still in stunn
shock of Sam seon's loss on time and we
asked ourselves well did how
Didact find out how did they react and
let's do an action we have an action
replay here we go this was the
moment where Sam got flagged with that
last move he didn't make it in time and
is not he notices
until until now and he there's the smile
and it's sort of like oh my God I'm
sorry and uh Sam just nodded his head oh
this is heartbreaking for Sam and Anish
can't believe it himself he's in
disbelief
right an exchange up exchange down an
end game where you're trying to push for
eternity gift it's a gift unbelievable
and Sam he's got to be feeling the pain
right now this is brutal have you ever
done that Peter in your experience I've
done something very very close here
actually the last time I played here I
uh lost a game to sha where I thought I
had like 15 seconds okay in a position
that was clearly winning maybe three
moves ago but is no longer winning at
that point and he gave me a check and I
thought the move was there that was
winning on the spot and then I realized
that blunder is a fork and a full rook
in one move and instead of making other
any other move I spent like 10 seconds
giggling right just just giggling at
myself how stupid I was and not making a
move and when I eventually went to make
a move I lost exactly like that kind of
not pressing the clock between the one
and the Zer seconds and that was
unfortunate W and we have another guest
in studio we're going to jump back to
Anastasia over to you
Anastasia thank you yaser and I have
with me the hero of the day Ray Robson
Ray congratulations what a game it was
against ala but to tell you the it felt
like he gave you everything you wanted
when you play with white pieces right
you could push your Pawns you put your
knight on C6 like how did it feel for
you um yeah well it was definitely very
double-edged I mean it optically it
looks great for white with all the space
but I think this is actually just like
the start of theory so I actually
couldn't remember after Knight C6 if he
played Queen E8 somehow during the game
I was thinking is it Queen D7 maybe
maybe it was Queen E8 since he played it
and this line with like Bishop A6 Bishop
C5 BC Queen D2 I thought this was like
just the start of line which is very
double-edged the engine probably says
white has some Advantage but practically
you can go either way so I mean I was
happy but uh still not so happy yes I
mean still it was the start for you
something which looks quite new for me
sometimes looks very diff to move on
number 14 so let's say when do you think
things start started to go your way in
this game um well so I played this move
Bishop
F3 um and now I'm preparing to play
probably just G5 and he played
H6 and um I think this was probably
based on a
miscalculation so when he played H6 I
was first trying to figure out what's
wrong if I just go G5 um trying to
figure out what the point of H6 is and I
didn't think Knight H7 would be good
because I can just play H4 Bishop G4 H4
like I did in the game and his Knight
just became very passive and I'm just
pushed on the king side very simply so I
thought he must want to do something
with taking an H3 and then I saw maybe
there's this idea take and take and now
the point is if I take here he has uh
Bishop
H6 um but maybe he just missed I think I
have Bishop G2 here and then if he moves
let's say his Queen along the H fou to
keep the bishop H6 idea alive then I
have Rook H1 first and then I can always
take so I think there was something else
instead oop sorry I went all this way
yes I think somewhere here maybe not
Queen H5 maybe there was something
better like Queen uh Queen G3 or
something like that Queen G3
G and then it's a very crazy
situation yes that somehow computer
likes this position so much and all of
us we were shocked because I mean it's
not like direct way to win but Rook on
E1 is hanging and this bishop G5 idea
yeah so I thought I can play just move
the king or something
I don't have then there is a rook on ah
yeah I didn't realize my E1 Rook is
thing I thought I can just s side step
with the king and queen C2 but okay oh
yeah this is computer line of course I
mean Peter swiler was showing during the
show and I was just wondering how far
did you calculate I mean it's almost
impossible I think to find it over the
board and I think that's why he actually
thought maybe to play Queen H3 but maybe
decided to play Knight H7
instead yeah I mean I saw basically all
this idea but I thought I can always
just move the k and queen I didn't
realize my Rook on E1 was saying I even
saw so in this position yes I saw this
to try to block with Knight H5 if I take
but then there's even like even this
maybe it's possible Rook H1 and his
Queen is trapped oh nice and it's just
completely winning Queen is
trapped well looks nice but yeah after
Knight H7 Bishop G4 and H4 I mean this
position's like very critical already
like borderline losing it felt like
during the game cuz he has to do
something immediate otherwise I'm just
running over him probably with F5 so he
tried to close things with H5 and now if
I go Bishop F3 he maybe has Bishop C8 um
Knight B5 Queen D7 so he's trying to
stop F5 so Bishop H3 F5 um look looked
like desperate attempt you know to do
something yeah he's trying to close
things if my Bishop were on F3 here I
could play Rook E6 uh but now my Knights
unprotected so I thought I can just go
for this like direct attack even though
it was kind of nice like his pieces were
kind of all trapped so I wasn't sure but
the attack just felt U very difficult to
play against so I just went for this and
basically Rook G1 Bishop E6 yeah the p
is just coming okay apparently he can
still fight but I think during the game
it was very hard to put up like good
resistance here yeah are you happy with
the day today how how how it went and
how is it how it going at the moment uh
yeah I mean I'm I'm pretty happy I
there's always chances well chances to
do worse and chances to do better I
think in my first game against Anish at
first I was um trying to defend a bit
and then at the end of the game I think
I actually should have definitely played
on I had no risk and it actually was
good chances to win if I just continued
the game but draw was fine and then the
second game against Fabby he was trying
to beat me from a worst position because
I had was playing on the increment for
like the whole game so I think I also
had some chances to maybe win that game
but then when I I blundered something he
he was probably winning later on so uh
in the end I was happy to at least make
a draw and obviously this this was
definitely my best game of the day yeah
so actually you have plus two right now
and you're leading in the tournament
like have you realized it I mean because
Liam just lost the game I didn't realize
it but then someone told me after the
game that oh Liam lost when I releas so
yeah I don't know not very expected but
um yeah I mean it's the best position to
be in so I guess I should be happy about
it yeah absolutely thank you so much for
your um comments and see you tomorrow
hopefully all the best of luck thank you
and we're going back to the studio you
Anastasia and thank you Ray indeed it's
nice to be first T you take us through
our standing and finishing the day with
the best game for yourselves Ray Robson
a happy man at the top of and of the of
day two with eight points he Leap Frog
Liam Le in the standings and we've got a
bunch of flares with seven points right
behind Ray which actually means
including Maxim Anish and Liam which
means that day three it's going to be
some big action and everything to play
for it felt like Ray was surprised to be
in first I'm sure Anish is surprised to
be in second the way the day started and
where it's ended no one could have
predicted this Ali Resa tied for fifth
along with Fabby and uh we've got then
Yana bosi Sam savan with a heartbreaking
loss at the end the day against Anish
right now with five points at the bottom
of the leader board we've got Wesley so
if you told me that Wesley so was at the
bottom of the leader board I always I'd
ask you what candidates tournament are
we talking about I mean that's just
unprecedented I
mean he never he never does poorly in
the grun story it's a very very strange
thing to observe but a very remarkable
day which started with 11 draws in a row
and then sort of exploded into action
with the the final the final Act of the
of the day being that heartbreaking loss
which uh uh Sam had won that end game
and he was winning at some point would
have been would have catapulted him into
shared second exactly and now he is down
there sharing the penultimate place so
very very dramatic day and more to come
tomorrow I assume absolutely what was
the moment of the day for you cuz it
just feels like we had only four
decisive games out of 15 but so much
happened the Liam turnaround I I thought
Liam was going to win that game against
um Fabby when I saw that night on A8 and
I was reminded of Hans Ray's part I
thought you know Fab's toast yeah and he
turned that game around that was
remarkable that was Final uh but uh
we're going to go to studio and
Anastasia for her final thoughts of a
very eventful day too
Anastasia yeah exactly we had a very
eventful day I must admit actually that
player despite all this drama happening
around they have really great relations
and they are talking with each other and
we have really friendly atmosphere in
the plain venue between the rounds which
normally we cannot see and um I must
admit that I'm really happy that our
Peak Fabiano Carana finally scored the
full point even though yes it looked
really scary for him Anish giri who had
I think all games finished in a draw
before finally managed to win so he had
to do it in a really strange way but now
he has plus one and I mean still nepo it
seems like he's still suffering he's
trying to find his shape and um but okay
I mean he's provoking his opponents and
um he goes he goes in trouble but
somehow manages to find a way out uh
today yeah many draws but the last round
I think was really nice and um everybody
was paid for waiting for the results for
the size of games yes so back to you
guys it was a great day and I'm hoping
tomorrow is going to be the next
absolutely thank you Anastasia very
explosive finish and we're going to be
seeing you all tomorrow for day three of
the Rapids and guys I just got to say
Tanya you had my back the whole day it
was
terrific Finish Line tomorrow with just
three rapid games remaining for the
players and we're expecting big action
so we will see you then
[Music]
goodbye
this has been a presentation of the St
Louis chess Club any reproduction or
distribution of this content without the
express written consent of the St Louis
chess club is
prohibited